QUALITY. TO ORDER IN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND SO WE DO NOT YET
LEAST PROCEED- WE'RE OF COURSE
CONTINUING TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ON GOING
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND SO
WE WELCOME THE PUBLIC WE ALSO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON
AND TELECONFERENCE DISSIPATION
PROBABLE COMMENT. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT BY THE BY THE BY
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
DEPARTMENT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT'S ALSO
GONNA BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. I'M ALSO GOING OUTSIDE
NOW SO TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO SIX TWO TWO. SIX
THREE ONE SIX THREE THERE IT IS-
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE I'M
GONNA. WE'RE TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
HERE- ANYONE WHO'S DESTRUCTIVE
IT COULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
REMOTE MEANING SERVICE OR RATHER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'RE ALL
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING
WE'RE ASKING ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY
HUNDREDS WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BEGIN. UNTIL HAVE VOTES.
I DO WANNA THANK- THANK YOU FOR
THE CLAIMS PROCESS- WE'VE GOT
THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
TWO ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SO LET'S GO AND ALLOW
OUR- COLLEAGUES AND WIENER TO
PRESENT THE FIRST BILL THAT'S IT
HAS TO BE EIGHT EIGHT SIX ITEM
ONE IN THE- ATTENDANCE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR GERMAN AND- CENTER
MAKOWSKI- THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US IN
THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. AS PRESENTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THOSE.
AMENDMENTS AS ODD MISTER
CHAMBERS YOU AND I HAVE.
DISCUSSED WE ARE WINDING- WE MAY
GET SOME ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK
FROM UC OR CSU OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE FUTURE IF THEY
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WE WILL ASK
THEM TO ENGAGE WITH THE
COMMITTEE- BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THESE ARE AMENDMENTS. ON
ARE CALLING SIDE SPEEDY SEX IS
THE STUDENT FACULTY HOUSING ACT.
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO HELP US
ADDRESS THE PROFOUND. LACK OF
STUDENT AND FACULTY HOUSING- IN
OUR PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE KNOW THAT THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA IS PERVASIVE AND-
THE STUDENTS. ARE PART OF THAT
CRISIS- ALTHOUGH. THE ARE YOU
SINCE SYSTEMS ARE HAVE ADDED
NEARLY THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND BEDS
FOR STUDENTS SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN- EMISSIONS INCREASES
HAVE FAR OUTPACED BY THE GROWTH
IN HOUSING. AND IT'S GOOD THAT
WE'RE GETTING MORE STUDENTS AND
MORE STUDENTS ARE- ARE ARE.
BEING PART OF OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A HOUSING FOR
THEM AND WE NEED TO GIVE OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES THE
TOOLS TO PROVIDE THAT HOUSING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WE NOTE
THAT- IN AS OF THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- ONE THIRTEEN CSU
CAMPUSES WE HAD EIGHTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS ON WAIT LISTS
FOR HOUSING- AT UC CAMPUSES THEY
REPORTED- SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS ARE UNDER A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED. STUDENTS
ON A WAITING LIST FOR HOUSING
WHICH OF THOSE TWO- SYSTEMS A
COMBINED TOTAL OF OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO WERE
UNABLE TO GAIN ACCESS TO STUDENT
HOUSING. I AM IS TOO HUGE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ARE THESE
WAIT LISTS DON'T TRUST- PUSH
STUDENTS TO PRIVATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. FIVE GOOD
MINISTERS CAN AFFORD THAT OPTION
SO WE EITHER HAVE STUDENTS GOING
INTO THE GENERAL HOUSING POOL
AND THAT CAN COOK PRESSURES ON
THOSE ON THAT HOUSING- A POOL-
WORDS DALY IF WE BECOME HOMELESS
OR HOUSING INSECURE OF ELEVEN IN
TEMPORARY MOTELS. WHERE THEY
COUNTY SERVER THEY LIVE IN THEIR
CARS- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE R. L.
A. O. REPORTED THAT 5% OF YOU
SEE STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY.
HOMELESSNESS WHEN WE ARRIVE AT
IN THOSE LIVING IN MOTELS
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AT SIXTEEN
PERCENT. FOR CSU STUDENTS THE
RATE OF HOMELESSNESS- IS. ABOUT
10% AT ANY GIVEN TIME- AND FOR A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. A NINETY
SERVE OF FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGE STUDENTS
I FOUND THAT 90% OF STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN HOMELESS AT SOME POINT
IN THE PAST YEAR WELL 60% HAD
EXPERIENCED HOUSING INSECURITY.
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE RELATING TO
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT STUDENTS
IT'S ALSO ABOUT. OUR FACULTY
FACULTY YOU SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO LIVE ANYWHERE NEAR THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS. UNDER PUSH IN
THE LONG COMMUTES THUS
INCREASING- THEIR OWN STRESS
LEVELS REDUCING THEIR ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON TEACHING- AND
INCREASING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSIONS ARE WITH THESE
CONDITIONS ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE.
ARE WE DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
STUDENTS FACULTY HOUSING- ON
CAMPUS- SO- SB EIGHTY SIX WILL
HELP ADDRESS THIS CRISIS- OUR
BODIES STREAMLINING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR STUDENTS AND
FACULTY ON YOUR CITY LAND- IT
ARE BY- OF REMOVING THESE
PROJECTS FROM SEACROFT. AND
INSURING THAT THEY ARE NOT
STOCKTON ANALYSTS LITIGATION AND
APPEALS ONE OF THE CLERKS SICK
WAS NOT THE ONLY ISSUE. WHEN IT
COMES TO STUDENT HOUSING- WE
NEED MORE FUNDING WE NEED-
BETTER PLANNING BY OUR OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. I
SERVICE- IS NOT A SILVER BULLET
THERE ARE VERY FEW SILVER
BULLETS AND LYFT. THIS IS ONE
WAY TO ACCELERATE THE APPROVAL
WE HAVE WE ARE INCREASING OUR
BUDGET INVESTMENT AS SOON
HOUSING WE DID A LOT IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. WE'VE INCREASED OUR
INVESTMENT WE'RE GOING IN. THERE
I HOPE. ONE TO DEPLOY FUNDING
HOW QUICK. I SO I RESPECTFULLY
FOR YOUR VOTE I'M A COMMITTED TO
TESTIFY. CAUSING HIM- WHO IS-
THE TRANSFER STUDENT AFFAIRS
OFFICE AND VICE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS. WITH THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION ONE OF
OUR ARE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND DR JAMES MARTELL A PROFESSOR
AND JOHN CALIPARI FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER PRESIDENT.
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY SEE IF THERE'S
ANOTHER CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND THEN ON MARCH THIRD OCT CO
SPONSOR- THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES- IS PRESENT-
THROUGH GERMANY. THEN ANY OCT-
RELATING TO SOME OF THE LABOR
PROVISIONS. IN THE BILL THANK
YOU. THE REASON PERCENT. YEAH
OKAY. AFTERNOON CHALLENGED AND-
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE AND
ANYONE WHO IS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE MY NAME'S TARGETS
HUMAN ON THE VICE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND THE
TRANSITION AFFAIRS OFFICER FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION I'M
INTERESTED NOT UC DAVIS FROM TV
COLLEGE AND I CURRENTLY LIVE IN
AN ON CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING
COMPLEX THAT WAS A TARGET OF
THIS. LAWSUIT DURING ITS
DEVELOPMENT. THE ONGOING COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC I HAVE NEVER
VISITED UC DAVIS UNTIL THE END
OF MY FIRST YEAR AS A STUDENT.
WHICH WAS ENTIRELY ONLINE.
AROUND DECEMBER WHEN IT WAS
LIKELY THAT UC DAVIS RETURNING
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION THE
FOLLOWING FALL. I STARTED MY
SEARCH FOR HOUSING I DECIDED TO
ASK MY FRIENDS FOR ADVICE AND HE
TOLD ME GOOD LUCK. AND I SHOULD
HAVE STARTED SEARCHING LAST
SEPTEMBER. WHEN I LIVED IN OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING THE PRICES AND
COMPETITION FOR THEM WERE
UNBELIEVABLE. I WAS STRESSED
ABOUT WHERE I WOULD BE LIVING IN
A CITY WHERE I ONLY KNEW A
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE. BUT THEN I
FOUND OUT ABOUT THE NEW CAMPUS
VILLAGE IS THE LARGEST IN
HOUSING PROJECT UNITED STATES.
WITH THIRTY THREE HUNDRED BEDS
ACROSS THIRTY FOUR ACRES AND IS
PRIMARILY ORIENTED TOWARDS
TRANSFER STUDENTS LIKE ME. AS
THE NAME SUGGESTS ENVIRONMENT
SUSTAINABILITY WAS CENTRAL TO
THIS PROJECT AND HAS AN ANNUAL
GOAL OF 1100% NET ZERO ENERGY
USE. LIKE OTHER STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THIS PROJECT BASIS PEOPLE LOST
YOUR ATTENTION DELAY THE
CONSTRUCTION PLANS. THE LAWSUIT
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL BUT IF THE
PROJECT HAD BEEN DELAYED I WOULD
NOT HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITIES I
HAVE TODAY. FOR DECADES ENTICING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
WEAPONIZED SEE WHAT'S HOT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING PROJECTS
INCLUDING STUDENT PORTAL
HOUSING. SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX FOR
EXAMPLE ON CAMPUS STUDENT
FACULTY HOUSING FROM SYKORA
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE HOUSING
PROJECTS TYPICALLY RESULT IN
LOWER ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
BECAUSE THEY ALLOW STUDENTS. TO
RESIDE NEAR THE CAMPUSES INSTEAD
OF COMMUTER SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE LIVING IN ON
CAMPUS AND COMMUNITY THERE ARE
MULTIPLE BUS ROUTES IN THE
COMPLEX MAKING IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO GET AROUND THE CITY%
IN CLASSES. WHICH IS GREAT FOR
ME BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A CAR.
IT IS EASIER TO SUCCEED
PERSONALLY AND ACADEMICALLY WHEN
YOU LIVE ON CAMPUS HOWEVER THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS ONLY CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO SELECT GROUPS OF
STUDENTS AND THOSE WHO LIVE ON
CAMPUS OR CONSERVE THE LUCKY
ONES. THERE'S AN EXTREME
SHORTAGE OF STUDENTS FACULTY
HOUSING AT THREE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. THE UC'S ONLY
HAVE BEDS 435% OF STUDENTS AND
CSU HAVE 14% WE MUST DO BETTER.
ONLY ELEVEN OF THE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN FISCAL COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE HOW. HOW LONG
THE CITY COLLEGE A PILOT PROGRAM
HAS BEEN LAUNCHED FOR HOMELESS
STUDENTS SLEEP IN THEIR CARS IN
PARKING LOTS OVERNIGHT. SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE'S BILL EXPLORING
BUILDING HOUSING. FOR HOMELESS
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND IT
WOULD BE DEVASTATING. ABOUT
PROJECT WERE DELAYED BECAUSE OF
A CIVIL LAWSUIT. THE STATUS IF
THE STATE OF STUDENT FACULTY
HOUSING IS A DISASTER PROVIDING
FUNDING TO BUILD HOUSING IS NOT
ENOUGH. WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
TOOLS FOR THE HOUSING TO
ACTUALLY CONSTRUCT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. WELL S. B. EIGHTY SIX
WILL NOT COMPLETELY ERADICATE
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE WILL
STREAMLINE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING FOR OUR STUDENTS AND THE
HARDWORKING FACULTY TO EDUCATE
THEM. STUDENTS ARE NOT BILLIONS
LET US LIVE ON CAMPUS ON BEHALF
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ALL OF OUR
PRESIDENT. PRO HOUSING AND PRO
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. HAVE A THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A DOCUMENT TOUGH. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JAMES BY TALENT AND THE
CHAP REPORT. SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT EIGHT THANK. THE FAA THE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. I WANT TO
FOCUS MIGHT MY COMMENT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOTH THE
STUDENTS AND FACULTY IN THE BAY
AREA. AS YOU ALL CERTAINLY AWARE
CONSERVE MARKET THE HOUSING THE
BAY AREA AND BEYOND THE MEANS
OF. EVERYONE WHO DOESN'T ALREADY
OWN A HOUSE OR LUCKY ENOUGH TO
BE IN CONTROL OF THE SITUATION.
FOR MY UNIVERSITY THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS HOPING EXENCIAL THREAT
TO OUR UNIVERSITY AT THE MOMENT
ARE DROPPING DRAMATICALLY AND
WE'RE LOOKING BACK AT THE END
OF. I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
SITUATION COLLECTOR FACULTY IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THEIR
SITUATION IS. REALLY DIRE. THE
BUDGET OVER PER MARKET AT.
LECTURE WE GET VERY LITTLE PAPER
UNCERTAIN AND NOT EPISODIC WORK.
I NEED YOUR PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO CHANGES IN THE
MARKET AND IN THEIR HOUSING
SITUATION. ONE LECTURE FACULTY
WORKING WORKING WITH ROBERT THE
CASE IN POINT. HE LOST HIS RIGHT
CONTROL DEPARTMENT ENDEMIC
BECAUSE OF THE THREAT
BLACKBALLED. WITHOUT A PLACE TO
LIVE IN THE BAY AREA YOU TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM AND
HELP THE OKLAHOMA NOW AFTER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ANYONE WHO
WOULD MOVE THERE AND GET REMOTE
WORK. AT THAT TIME BECAUSE THEY
ARE REMOTE TO THE PANDEMIC INTO
ROB MOVED. TO UTECH BRING. A
DOWN PAYMENT ON A HOUSE. COMING
AT THE AGE OF FIFTY IN THAT
REGARD AND BE ABLE TO DO. BUT AT
THE CAMPUS OF MOVED TOWARDS
ENCRYPTION TEACHING AGAIN
MINISTRATION OF THE FIFTEEN THAT
EACH FACULTY MEMBER TEACHING
CLINICALS IN PERSON. I'M SO
SORRY TO MYSELF WE GOT A- IF YOU
COULD JUST WRAP UP WE HAVE.
LIMITS THE PRESS. I IDEA. OKAY
OKAY WELL I'LL- ANYWAY IF
YOU'RE- I WANT TO FINISH MY
THING AND EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT.
WILL HELP INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR BOTH STUDENTS AND
FACULTY AND IT'S FOR THIS REASON
THEY'RE ACTUALLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
MYSELF ALRIGHT HOW BOUT WE GO
NOW TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
THERE'S A SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
HERE IN THE COMMUNITY. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIN LEHANE ON BEHALF
OF THE HALF MILLION MEMBERS OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU THINK
YOU THINK CURRENT. ALL RIGHT-
OTHER FOLKS. GOOD AFTERNOON I
SHANNON SWANSON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS RYAN JOY I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN B. WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS SB EIGHT EIGHT
SIX I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL- I THINK VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU HELLO THANK YOU ARE MARK
WARNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING TRADES WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY PARA MONTEREY SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS JOHN
HERSHEY- ON BEHALF AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE UNITED ASSOCIATION
OF PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. MARK THE BILL WITH THE HEATING
PROCESS LEADERS LOCAL SIXTEEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS MAC
CRIMMINS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL EFFORTS OF
OPPORTUNITY NEARS HERE TO A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING JOHNSON PRASAD VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATORS FOR THIS
INCENTIVE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPRESENTING
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION. THREE
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE ANDREWS AND THE
LEGISLATURE ACTOR FOR THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF UC DAVIS
HERE FOR THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WITH ALL THESE OTHER
WONDERFUL YOU SEE STUDENTS HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS GREG
CRAWFORD I'M A UC DAVIS STUDENT
AND LIVING IN STUDENT HOUSING
NICE AND STRONG SUPPORT. HELLO
I'M IS PLANTED I'M A STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT IT'S SIX. MY NAME
IS THAT'S NOT WHAT I MEAN IS IT
A STUDENT I SEVEN FROM A SUPPORT
SB EIGHTY SIX. HI MY NAME'S
KHALIL MALIK I'M ALSO A STUDENT
UC DAVIS AND I'M ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
LOGAN RIPS OR STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS AND I'M HERE TO VOICE MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT
SIX. HI MY NAME IS EDEN MORRIS
I'M ALSO A STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
AND I AM AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX. WELCOME
HELLO MY NAME IS MAKAYLA ABOUT
TO SKINNY I'M A USER THAT UC
DAVIS AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
. HI MY NAME IS EVAN CRAIG AND
I'M A RECENT GRADUATE OF UC
DAVIS I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS SOPHIA CICADAS AND I'M A
CONSTITUENT APPEND ALLEN AND
REPRESENTING UCLA AND UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIX GO
BRUINS. WELL I'M KARINA- I'M A
STUDENT AT UCLA ALSO
REPRESENTING THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION I'M A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR BEN ALLEN AND SENATOR
SCOTT WEINER AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT. HUNDRED
HELLO MY NAME IS ALLEY ECHO AND
I AM A MEMBER OF OUR STATE
RELATIONS TEAM AT UCLA'S
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX ALSO
CONSTITUENTS HAVE BEEN ALLEN
THANK YOU AWESOME THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S SEBASTIAN
BAFFLINGLY UCLA STUDENT ALSO
CONSTITUENT BEN ALLEN I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF- SB EIGHT
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU. HI I'M CARL
SMITH MISS STUDENT UCLA I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF ALAN INCREDIBLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL EIGHT
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS FOR COMING HI I'M JENNA
TO LEE IMUS A UCLA STUDENT AND
ALSO CONSTITUENT ABOUT ALLEN AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB
EIGHTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MONIES ARE TEACHING LAW I'M A
STUDENT USER UCLA A CONDITION OF
THAT ALLEN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ESTIMATED SIX ZERO HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVES FOLDER. ALL
RIGHT THAT'S GOOD WELCOME
WELCOME UP HERE I THINK YOU GUYS
THESE ARE COMING UP. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S I'M- LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- FOLKS WANT TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THIS SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AT THE EIGHT
EIGHT SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE OF
THEIR- FOR SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THREE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ALLEN AND
MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AS YOU HEARD WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX AND SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE FOR TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON ALL MY NAME IS BRAD
EWING SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SAN
MONTH BEFORE URGING EITHER DAY
YOU'RE MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINEUP FOR TWENTY FOUR.
NINE FOUR TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEXICO
TO LINE THREE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU JOHN
COURSE IT'LL DROP NUMBER OF UA
LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT HOMERS AND
THE PRESIDENT THAT THIS GOAL
SETTING WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN ORDER THE BILL HELPS
PROTECT. IT'S A FUNNY
CONNECTIONS THANK YOU FOR TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS ROBIN. SAN FRANCISCO AGAIN
BEACON SCORE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE UP FOR
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIDNEY FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
TO GO TO LINE FOR ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SENATE DISTRICT
NINE I ALSO. THIS IS JOHN UP
EDUCATIONAL. A LITTLE AB. THEY
WHAT ARE GOAL YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE LINE FOR OLD
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
THAT BOOK BINDER AND YOU HAVE TO
STOP THE YOU'D BE LOOKING AT THE
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOT A LINE FOR THIRTY SIX IT
LENDS OPEN. I AM SINCE ALRP
INDIVIDUAL IN THE FAMILY HOME
OWNER IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
STREAMLINE ALL BUILDING PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN OCTOBER
NINE THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- READING DOLLARS SAN
FRANCISCO BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
THINK THE AUTHOR FURS SUPPORT
LEADERSHIP WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF FOUR NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
MATTHEW ID- AS A STUDENT UC
BERKELEY AND A MEMBER OF THE
ORDER THIS GENERATION UP- VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU. TO LINE FOR- TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JOEL
KOPPEL SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
IBEW LOCAL SIX SAN FRANCISCO
VOICING STRONG SUPPORT TO THAT.
THANK YOU NOT GOING TO LINE
THREE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND REOCCUR
CALLING PERCENT RECEIVE NEWS FOR
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE FOR TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS DAVID
BEATY REPRESENTING THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW A LINE OF FOUR OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON RICHARD MANY MEMBERS.
ONE OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISCOUNT OF WHATEVER'S WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB EIGHT EIGHT
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR BOTTOM LINE FOR FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT THE
FATHER TOLD ON BEHALF OF SANTA
CRUZ EMB IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE LINE FOR THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS KEVIN MULLIN
WITH NONUNION BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE THREE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLAY ALL I'M PUBLIC MORE CALLING
FROM OAKLAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL GO LINE
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
HAPPENING THIS YEAR SO BUSINESS
AGENT FOR LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT AND
FROST INSULATORS AND I STAND
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO
LINE OF THREE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON WHAT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS ON WITH THE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR DISTRICT
COUNCIL. SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU KNOW DIFFICULT TO LINE
THREE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JALEN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS COMMUNITY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TIMOTHY JEFFREY DAHMER
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS. STANDING AT THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT WELL GO TO
LINE FOR THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KRISTA JEFFRIES AND I'M
CALLING IN FROM SLOPE COUNTY
INDIANA WE ARE IN SENATOR LEHRER
DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS FOR CAL POLY AND
ALL OTHER STUDENTS. THANK YOU
NEXT. LINE THREE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS HERIS ROSENBLOOM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT FLYING
FOR FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS INDICATING WITH GLAZERS
LOCAL SEVEN EIGHTEEN DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN I AM JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHT EIGHT CENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF
FOUR THIRTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR NUMBERS JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN THAT DISTRICT
THIRTEEN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT
EIGHT EIGHT SIX FOUR THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE THREE SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
MY NAME'S DANCING WATERS AND A
MEMBER OF DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN FINISHING CRAFT AND I'M
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR HER
FOUR THIRTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS.
I GO TO MISSION COLLEGE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE SLOCAN
VALLEY AND I AND SPEAK ON BEHALF
GENERATIONS FROM. THE PORT
ITSELF OKAY- THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WE HAVE AVAILABLE CASKEY
CONSIDERED SO MODERATOR- THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
WE'RE RUNNING UP AGAINST OUR OUR
TIME LIMIT. ON ON THE ON THE
FOLKS CALLING IN SO- YOU KNOW
MAYBE MAYBE MAYBE WILL WILL LET
YOU KNOW. FIVE MORE OF FOLKS AT
AND THEN WE HAVE TO CUT IT OFF I
REALLY DO APOLOGIZE THAT WE
WE'VE GOT A LONG LIST OF SUPPORT
IN IN THE ANALYSIS WE DO ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT AND- AND
THAT WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE
FROM CALLING AND WE'VE GOT WE
GOT A REALLY TIGHT SCHEDULE
TODAY SO. LET'S LET FIVE MORE
CALLS AND THEN AND THEN WE HAVE
TO CUT OFF MINOR. OKAY THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR
ALL SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
GALLAGHER SHOULD. GO DEMONSTRATE
CONFIDENCE REGIONAL COUNCIL
LOCAL TWENTY TWO ON THE SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. AND THEN LET ME
JUST CLARIFY ALSO BENEFITS
CALLING IN BUT WE'RE THE I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL SO. DON'T I.
JUST KNOW THAT I IT IT ENJOYS A
RECORD A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WITH IT WITH OUR AMENDMENTS OKAY
KAREN THANK YOU. ONE THREE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOE SANDERS-
WITH- PAINS LOCAL NINE ONE NINE
ONE THREE DISCOUNT OF SIXTEEN
I'M STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SIX SIX. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI REALLY WORRIED WITH
BROWN'S STING ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW THE
LINE- FOR- FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MARTIN RODRIGUEZ I AUGUST
LOCAL FOR THIRTY THREE WE STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH BILLS TRADE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU AND
ARE LASSEN WILL COME FROM LINE
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JERRY BERMAN LOCAL THREE FORTY
THREE THE PHARMACY VENDORS AND
WE'RE JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY I THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WHEN WE KNOW WE HAVE MANY MORE
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE WE WE'VE
NOTED THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WE
WEEKS WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE TO
PARTICIPATE- I DO APOLOGIZE FOR
OUR- OUR TIGHT SCHEDULE- TODAY.
LET'S GIVE- AT FOLKS WANNA RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL THE OPPORTUNITY NOW GIVE
THEIR TESTIMONY- I BELIEVE WE
GOT I JENNER JENNIFER KANADA
FROM THE COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ON THE
PHONE LINES HI. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. OKAY I THINK YOU CHAIR
NUMBERS MY NAME'S JENNIFER
CANNOT AND THEN THE SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT OR CD CD EVEN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT ORGANIZES AND
WORKS ALONGSIDE COMMUNITIES IN
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES WELLINGTON
EAST OAKLAND AND RICHMOND. WELL. TO REMEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
PHOEBE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX THIS BILL WOULD
EXEMPT HOUSING PROJECTS BY
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. AND PUBLIC
CONCEPTS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT. WE
APPRECIATE THE OFFICE STAFF AND
THE BILL'S SPONSORS FOR TAKING
THE TIME WITH US. TO DISCUSS THE
CONCERN HOWEVER REMAIN TROUBLED
BY THE HARMFUL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE VULNERABLE PUBLICLY. THIS
BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE REAL
BARRIERS TO CREATING ADEQUATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS.
TO PROMOTE A DANGEROUS FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT SEEK WAS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
SEQUEL TO ONE OF THE FEW LEGAL
TOOLS THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE.
TO ENSURE THAT NEW PROJECT WILL
NOT BRING ABOUT SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ANOTHER
IMPACT. AS NOTING THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS SEE FOR
EXEMPTIONS OVERLOOK THE BENEFITS
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL IF YOU.
WOULD JUST CHEN FORMALIZATION
MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC ABOUT
PROJECT IMPACT IDENTIFY WAYS TO
AVOID OR SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE. DISCLOSED
TO THE PUBLIC REASON HE LINE
AGENCY APPROVED THE PROJECT
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPACTORS IDENTIFY. AND
INCREASE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND FIND
COST. THE FORTY PROCESS
NECESSARY BECAUSE IT ALLOWS YOU
TAKE MOVIES TO LEARN ABOUT
PARTICIPATE IN AND IMPROVE THESE
PROJECTS THAT WILL LIKELY IMPACT
THEIR FAMILY'S HEALTH AND THEIR
ABILITY TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
AND NEIGHBORHOODS. HE ALSO
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GROWING HOUSING CRISIS FOR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. THE BILL MISTAKENLY
TARGET SEQUENCE THE PROBLEM AND
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE REAL
BARRIERS CREATING MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
AND FACULTY. IT STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN US TIME AND AGAIN THE
PREQUEL EDUCATION IS OFTEN
GROSSLY MISSTATED AND ONLY ABOUT
2% OF THOSE PROJECTS ACTUALLY
WAS OPENED BY THE CASE. REAL
SOLUTION FOR THE UC BERKELEY
CAMPUS TO LOOK AT THE ABSENT
PLANNING AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL. REFORMING THE PROCESS FOR
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
pDEVELOPMENT PLAN IT HELPS
PREVENT SIMILAR SITUATION
HAPPENED FUTURE. ADDITIONALLY
THE LACK OF AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS. CAN EXACERBATE A
PATTERN OF MARKET REDEVELOPMENT
THAT DRIVES UP COSTS FOR THE
SURROUNDING AREA DIRECTLY
DISPLACING VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIX.
AND URGED COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
VOTE NO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IF YOU COULD
STAY ON THE LINE AND TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS OR HER
OR HEARD A DISCUSSION READY
PROJECT THAT. I'M AT DILLON HERE
PERSON WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL YES YES
MA'AM. THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ALLIANCE- REGISTERING
OPPOSITION ALIGNING WITH CP-
ALSO REGISTERING FOR LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ARE YOU ON THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ADMITTED ONE EMINENT FEAR OF
YOUR OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHERE WE
GIVE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
AGAIN THIS IS OPPOSITION. OF SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE UP FOR TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FEVERS
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF THE
LEADER- APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHORS DOING THE CANDY OF. THE
BILL BUT WISH TO POINT OUT THAT
NOT ALL DORMS ARE CREATED EQUAL
HE- TO BE ABLE TO LET IS FACING
THE STORM THAT WOULD BE FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED BEDS IN A SINGLE
BUILDING. NOT YOU KNOW THOUSANDS
OF ROOMS SPREAD OUT OVER
MULTIPLE BUILDINGS BUT IN ONE
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT
PERHAPS- SEQUEL REVIEW WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR PROJECT OF THAT
SIZE SO THEY WOULD DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO. A COMIC NUMBER SIX
IN THE ANALYSIS IF YOU'LL BE SO
KIND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY. AT
PRESENT THERE MR KERRY HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN KIEL OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING THE BILL
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS. I KNOW THAT OUR OUR
TERMS LIKE TO. GAUGE WELL NOW. I
THINK THE STAFF REPORT DOES A
WONDERFUL JOB OF. OF ADDRESSING
THIS FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
SEAQUEST SOMEHOW THE EVIL OF WHY
WE DON'T HAVE STUDENT HOUSING
WHICH IS I HOPE PEOPLE READ IT
AND YOU KNOW IT IS STILL.
PERCENT OF THE OF IT. OF THE- OF
THE- WHAT CONSERVING FALL THAT
OUR CALL BACK SURE ARE FILED TO
ACTUALLY GO INTO A LAWSUIT BUT
WHEN I WE REVIEW TO STAFF REPORT
ON THE EXISTING EXEMPTIONS YOU
KNOW SME OF THE STUDENT HOUSING
THAT'S ANTICIPATED YOU KNOW
FEELS INTO AN INFILL PROJECT FOR
RESIDENTIAL PRODUCT PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN- BEEN- AND REALIZE
COUNTY AREAS. AS THE AUTHOR JUST
REMINDED ME THAT THAT PROJECT
THAT MONSTROSITY IS COULD BE
BUILT AT UC SANTA BARBARA WENT
THROUGH SEEK WHAT THANK GOD
APPROVED I MEAN YOU KNOW YOU MAY
COMPLAIN ABOUT FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED UNIT BUT IT WENT THROUGH
SEQUEL AND GOT APPROVED. I THINK
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS THE- A
SITUATION WHERE TAG YOU'RE IT
IT'S NICE TO CARPABOUT STUDENTS
TO NOT POLLUTANTS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT. IS GOING ON BUT
REALLY UC BERKELEY WHICH UNDER
THE CHAIR AND I ATTENDED AT ONE
TIME IS REALLY. A CULPRIT HERE
IN IN IN FORCING SOME LAWSUITS
BY NOT UPDATING YOUR LONG TERM
DEVELOPMENT PLANS TONIGHT I HOPE
ALL THE STUDENTS IN THE TRADES
THAT HAVE CALLED IN TODAY. GO TO
THE UC'S AND PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR LONG TERM DEVELOPMENT
PLANS BECAUSE- I WAS SURPRISED.
HAPPY HAPPY THAT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND BEDS HAVE BEEN. BEEN
BUILT THAT'S IT THAT'S OTHER.
GREAT TO THE CSU AND UC SYSTEM
NOT. NEARLY A SNUFF IF WE GOT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS ON.
VARIOUS CAMPUSES ARE ARE ARE
UNDER HOUSE THE AMENDMENTS. MERE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WENT
INTO THE NOW PUBLICIZE YOU KNOW
YOU SEE. RICKLY THING WHERE THE
FIFTEEN YEAR. MASTER PLAN FOR
LONG TERM DEVELOPMENT PLAN FOR
THE UPDATE I'VE APPLIED THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I THINK AGAIN
IT'S TAG YOU'RE IT YOU SEE YOU
GUYS YOU KNOW. I DON'T WANT TO
BE HERE IN SEVEN YEARS AFTER
THIS IS THIS BILL EXPIRES AND
HAVE NO STUDENT HOUSING CRISIS
YOU SEE SINCE ISSUES HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THEIR ACT TOGETHER ON
DOING IT SO- I'M GONNA SUPPORTED
. I KNOW THE SECRET WILL BE A
BALLOT. IN IOWA- A PUNCHING BAG
FOR SOME PEOPLE TO SAY THIS IS
THE PLACE FOR THIS THIS IS THE
SOURCE OF ALL EVIL BUT I THINK.
THE EXEMPTIONS THAT THEIR
EXISTING NOW FIT NICELY INTO THE
TONE OF WHAT WE ALREADY LOOK AT
IT EXISTING PROJECT PROJECTS AND
IF I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE AUTHOR
ANTICIPATES WITH THE STUDENT
HOUSING. BUILT AROUND- OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES TODAY SO PLEASE
UC AND CSU SPEND SOME WORK ON
YOUR LONG TERM PLANS. S. N. WHAT
THAT- CLOSE TO THE ACT I GUESS
IT'S ON THE TOPIC THAT IS A
QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN YES
AFTER ON SO IN TURN IN TERMS OF
THE MARKET AND THE REASON I
MENTION THE MUNGER PROJECTS I'VE
AND FOR THE CITY OF ALEDO TELL
YOUR YOUR SENATORS CENTER ALONE
HAS BEEN EXTREME A STRONG
ADVOCATE OF FOR YOU AND TALKING
TO ME ABOUT THE MUNGER PROJECT
AND SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU SEE SANTA BARBARA SO SHE IS
VERY FOCUSED ON BEING AN
EXCELLENT REPRESENTATIVE AS
ALWAYS. ON BUT THE- RIGHT THE
POINT WAS THAT THE MUNGER.
PROJECTS WENT TO SEE WHAT AND
STILL. GOT APPROVED TO THE- SO
FOR THOSE WHO THINK. THE CITY OF
THE LEADER THAT WE NEED TO GO TO
FIGHT PROJECTS TO FIGHT A
HORRIBLE PROJECT WITH THE MUNGER
PROJECT. HE COULDN'T EVEN FIGHT
EXTENDED IN TAKING A MUCH LONGER
TO GET. APPROVED BUT ULTIMATELY
GOT APPROVED. AND THAT'S ALSO
THE OTHER PIECE HERE- AND I KNOW
THAT THESE DEBATES HAPPEN ALL
THE TIME AND MISS COMMITTEE AND
I'M NOT GOING TO IN A SENSE
PRETEND LIKE I KNOW MORE THAN
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
WHAT I DO KNOW ESPECIALLY FOR MY
TIME AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS YES
IT MAY BE THAT ONLY 2% OF
PROJECTS. THAT SUIT ON THE
SEQUEL. BUT THAT IS ONLY THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG BECAUSE- WHAT
WHAT THE IMPACT THAT SEQUENCE I
AM I DON'T. I'M NOT GONNA
DEMONISE SECRECY WITH A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS. BUT FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE REQUIREMENTS THE MOBILE
WHAT CAN HAPPEN IS TO PROCESS
ALL TO ME. WITH EARTH OR DIE.
THEIR NEVER GETS SUED A DOG. OR
MAD. IN THE- YOU'RE NEVER.
PROCESS UNDERSEA QUAFF. ON AND
UNDER LOCAL DISCRETIONARY
PROCESSES. AND EVERYTHING. GET
STELLAR AROUND TRYING TO AVOID A
LAWSUIT- THERE ARE OTHER
EXEMPTIONS BUT WE KNOW THAT
THOSE DON'TALWAYS APPLY AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE BEEN IN
YORK'S BEEN QUITE A BIT OF
SICKLE LITIGATION AROUND STUDENT
HOUSING I DO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT SENATOR AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE JUST A MOMENT. I WILL OF
COURSE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS YEAH AND MR THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT ABOUT THE
SEQUEL OF PROVIDING A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BECAUSE YOU KNOW
MANY OF TE STUDENTS WHO CAME IN
TODAY IN THE TRADES LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD WE KNOW THAT THE
BILL REQUIRES AT LEAST ONE
PUBLIC HEARING. AND WE HOPE THAT
THE U. SEASON THIS YEAR IF YOU
GET THE MESSAGE THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S VALUE IN HAVING INPUT
FROM THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE
CITY AND THEN THE STUDENTS AND
IN THE TRACE WHOEVER WANTS TO
COMMENT ON WHAT THE PROJECT IS
IN ITS ITS- YOU KNOW JOIN THE-
THE- THE TABLE WHERE DOES THESE
TEN THE COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
ARE OPEN AND EXPLAINED WHAT THE
PROJECT IS WHAT THEY THINK THE
DEFECTS COULD BE I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S AGAIN. SOMETHING AN
IMPROVEMENT. YEAH MEAN THAT'S
ACTUALLY RIGHT- AND OF COURSE
WE'VE ALSO- REQUIRED LEED
PLATINUM WHICH I JUST CAN'T
IMAGINE. OF WINDOWLESS. DORM
LIKE THE ONE THAT WAS APPROVED
TO SEE WHO AT THE END. YEAH
WHATEVER WHATEVER GET LEAVE PLAN
AND SO- AND A BUNCH OF OTHER
AMEND SAID I THINK OR OF A VERY
SEED OF GREAT SIGNIFICANCE ON
THE- BOTTOMS OF THE ANTI AND-
ARE THERE GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE HI I'M
- BUT- YOUR YOUR YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN I MEAN THAT IS THE
AND THEN THE QUESTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY ARE OF
PREVIOUS JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CHAIR. I WAS WITH A- WAS A REAL-
REALLY PUSHED BACK HARD ON THE
IDEA THAT THAT THAT. THAT THE
SEQUEL IS THE ONLY. PROBLEM THAT
I AND I KNOW YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THAT EITHER- SENATOR- SO. BUT AT
THE END AND IT WAS OF THE
HEARINGS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS AND I AND I DO YOU MAY
MAYBE MAYBE WE CAN- YEAH WORK
TOGETHER TO JUST MAKE SURE
THAT'S A MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY
FOR INPUT YEAH I AM HAPPY TO DO
THAT I WILL. NOTE THAT. THERE'S
ALSO OBVIOUSLY THE OUR GPUS HAVE
TO GO THROUGH C. FIVE DÍAS A- A
FOR PROCESSORS. AND AGAIN THAT
IS ON I UNDERSTAND THAT DOESN'T
SO I TOUCH ON EVERY SINGLE PIECE
OF IT. BUT PARTICULARLY IF
YOU'RE TALKING. FOR LIKE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ ORACLE LEAD- WORKS
OUT OR OR- OR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE.
WE R. INDIVIDUALS OR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE. CAN ARE
CONSISTENTLY INVOLVED THAT IS A
- AN OPPORTUNITY- TO ALSO-
INVOLVED IN ADDITION THE FACT.
THAT WHEN THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
FOR CS YOU ARE APPROVING
DIFFERENT PLANS THAT'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY SO THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE INVOLVED
THREE. OTHER QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS ALSO IT IS
THIS WILL BRING A SUNSET IN AS
WELL SO WE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW HOW THE-
PROGRAM GOES AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BILL TO
RECONSIDER THIS IN THE FUTURE-
YES WE CAN STEPS REQUIREMENTS
RIGHT. I THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER- CHICKASAW PLEASE COLOR
ALLEN HERE ALLEN HERE BATES.
BATES HERE DALY YOU'RE DOWN HERE
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN BURKE
OWSKI MAKOWSKI HERE CHRIS WE OF
COURSE WE CAN VOTE. PERSON THE
BILL'S MOVED AS AMENDED BY
CINEMA CASKEY CENTER HOW WINNING
A CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIVE- OKAY I THOUGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN AYE ALLEN
AYE FATE. ALL RIGHT. DALLI DALLI
IS AYE BATES NOT SOMETHING OUR
BATES NOT VOTING RALLY. DALY AYE
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN AYE
CASKEY AYE CASKEY AYE. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON- BUT-
THANK YOU AND THANKS AGAIN FOR
THE CARS ARE WE HAD TO CUT IT
OFF WE JUST GOT A VERY LONG
ATTENDED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY LET'S LET'S CALL UP
FROM CENTER MCGUIRE WHO'S HERE
TO PRESENT ITEM FOR IN YOUR CHEN
IS THIS SB. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
CENTER YOU MAY PRESUME RIGHT.
WHERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO CHEER ALLEN INTO HIS
TREMENDOUS STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
EFFORT ON THIS BILL SB NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT LET ME JUST BE
VERY CLEAR THAT THIS BILL IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS- WE HAVE BEEN
MEETING WITH A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS FOR ALMOST TWO
YEARS NOW ON HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
IMPLEMENT THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE WILDFIRE DEBRIS
REMOVAL PROGRAM. IN THE NATION.
IN JUST LIKE CENTER DOLLY SCENE
SEASON. AFTER SEASONAFTER
SEASON WE'VE SEEN THE SAME THING
ON THE NORTH COAST IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. NEARLY THOUSANDS OF
HOMES AND BUSINESSES BURNED. IN
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO MOBILIZE TO
BE ABLE TO GET OUR COMMUNITY'S
CLEAN UP AND REBUILD. IN WHAT
THIS PROGRAM WOULD DO IS ONE
THAT PUTS THE NEEDS OF NEIGHBORS
WHO LOST EVERYTHING FROM
WILDFIRES FIRST IT DELIVERS FOR
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR REBUILDING
PLAN. AND ENSURES TAXPAYERS SEE
THE MASSIVE CLEANUP PROJECTS
FINISH SAFELY ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET. AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING A NEW
NORMAL FOURTEEN THE LARGEST
TWENTY WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY HAVE OCCURRED IN THE
LAST DECADE. AND IT'S NOT GONNA
BE STOPPING ANYTIME SOON WHICH
MEANS CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL REMAIN IN
DANGER. AND WITH EACH OF THESE
DISASTERS FIRES THOUSANDS OF
LIVELIHOODS ARE OFFENDED. IN
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED AND WHAT
EACH OF YOU KNOW IN OUR BUDGET
SUB TO CHEER KNOWS IS THAT. THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART OF A
RECOVERY IS THIS MOVES. RE CLEAN
UP PROCESS. THROUGH S. B. NINE
SEVEN EIGHT STREAMLINES AND
ENHANCES THE PROCESS FOR WATER
CLEAN UP RECOVERY CONTRACTS LIKE
TO WALK THROUGH THE POINTS AND
THEN I'D ALSO LIKE TO. CATCH
FOLKS UP ON WHERE WE BEEN OUT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. THE
BILL REQUIRES CAR RECYCLE TO
ESTABLISH A PRE QUALIFIED LIST
OF CONTRACTORS WHO CAN BE
DEPLOYED ANYTIME. WITH THEIR
STAFF TEAMS TO BEGIN COMMUNITY
CLEANUPS THIS IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE FEMA PROGRAM HAS. ON
THE NATIONAL LEVEL. THIRTY SET A
STANDARDS HERE TO STATE THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE ESTABLISH WHAT
CONTRACTORS WE NEED IN ORDER TO
BECOME PRE QUALIFIED SO FOR
EXAMPLE. THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
BILL REQUIRE CONTRACTORS HAVE
PROPER LICENSING. EMPLOYEE
SAFETY TRAINING THAT'S CALLED
HAS WHOPPER- IN THE IT TAKES
ABOUT TWO WEEKS TO BE ABLE. TO
COMPLETE THE MUSON ROLE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT INVESTOR RELATIONS
CONTRACTORS WE NEED TO HAVE A-
RECORD OF SAFE WORK PERFORMANCE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT WOULD
ENSURE THE AWARDED GENERAL
CONTRACTOR PERFORM ABOUT 30% OF
THE WORK THEMSELVES. IN WORK
WITH A REGISTERED APPRENTICE
PROGRAM WHICH CREATES A PATHWAY
TO SKILLED JOBS. NOW WE ALSO
BELIEVE CONTRACTORS SHOULD BE
QUICK PREQUALIFIED FOR HAZARDOUS
TREE REMOVAL. AS WELL AS DEBRIS
CLEANUP. NOW I WANT TO GET TO
THE NEXT STEP INTO A CATCH UP ON
WHERE WE'VE BEEN OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS. THE FULL DISCLOSURE
THE GOOD FOLKS THE GOOD FOLKS AT
CAL RECYCLE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
ESTABLISHING THIS PROCESS OF PRE
QUALIFIED. THE PROCESS IS WELL.
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A PRE
QUALIFIED CONTRACTOR LIST. AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT. BECAUSE
OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS INVESTED
IN AN ENTIRE NEW DEPARTMENT AT
CAL RECYCLE- THAT IS SOLELY
FOCUSED ON DEBRIS REMOVAL. NOW
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
SAME FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL PROCESS
IN GETTING PRE QUALIFIED
CONTRACTORS WELL I CAN NEVER
SPEAK FOR THE AGENCY OR THE
ADMINISTRATION. I CAN NEVER
SPEAK FOR THEM- WE ARE GOING TO
BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM AS
WE HAVE BEEN OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS- TO BE ABLE
TO GET THIS DEAL LANDED. AS I
SAID IN THE BEGINNING OF MY
PRESENTATION THIS BILL IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS IN FACT WE HAD OUR
LATEST MEETING AT EIGHT THIRTY
THIS MORNING. MEMBERS ARE GONNA
SEE REFINEMENTS TO THE BILL AS
THERE ARE TWO APPROACHES TO
SPEEDING UP THE CLEAN UP PROCESS
ONE THAT'S ADMINISTRATIVE. OTHER
IS LEGISLATIVELY AND I CAN I CAN
PROMISE EACH OF YOU TODAY THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE COMPLEMENTARY.
I'M IN AGAIN WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR TWO
YEARS NOW FOR THE WORKING WITH
THEM IN THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAD
BEEN AT THE TO. THE FRAMEWORK OF
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
USE OF THE MOST HIGHLY TRAINED
WORKFORCE IS AVAILABLE THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO DELIVERING PROJECTS
ON TIME WORK IS PERFORMED IN A
SAFE MANNER AND THAT THE BEST-
IN IT. AND WE ALSO ARE ABLE TO
PROTECT WORKERS. CONTRACTORS
HAVE EXPERIENCE DOING THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I WITH ME TODAY TIM
CRIMMINS WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS AS WELL AS ERIN HAYNES
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT SOME COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING ANY CONVERSATION
RESEARCHER. MISTER CRIMMINS
DURING THE FIRST. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TEMPERAMENTS ARE PRETTY GENEROUS
OF CO SPONSOR THE BILL ALONG
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES I
THINK THIS BILL IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD A PRE
QUALIFICATION HAITIAN OF
CONTRACTORS ALLOWS US TO
ANTICIPATE WORKFORCE NEEDS
TRAINING NEEDS- THESE ARE HIGHLY
UNSTABLE HAZARDOUS WORK
ENVIRONMENTS. MYERS EXTRA
TRAINING A UNIQUE TYPE OF WORKER
A WORKER FAMILIAR WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY ON ON HAZMAT REMOVAL
AND THIS WILL IT HELP US
ANTICIPATE THOSE NEEDS. AND ALL
AND ALSO- A CONTRACTOR KNOWLEDGE
OF WITH KNOWLEDGE OF HIS LABOR
REQUIREMENTS- AS EVIDENCED BY
HAVING TO REGISTER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL AT THE
STATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I UNDERSTAND WHIMS LINE GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN- ERIN LEE HANNA
WE HAVE THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL-
HERE'S YOUR WITNESS. ABOUT A
YEAR- IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THERE'S NOT MUCH ELSE I CAN SAY
THIS IS YOU KNOW- SADLY A VERY
UNIQUE PROBLEMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND- THIS BILL- WILL
SERVE. AS A RESPONSE TO THAT- IS
A WAY TO BRING CALIFORNIA
WORKERS- TO REMEDIATE THIS VERY
CALIFORNIA PROBLEM. AND WE WILL
BE READY AND ABLE TO GO- TO TAKE
CARE OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAVAGED BY- UNFORTUNATELY
BY WHY FIRE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME IF YOU MISTER
WHERE. THE FIRST FOR SAYS NO WE
GOTTA GO NOW. THIS IS A- MAN.
ALL RIGHT NOW APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THANK YOU- LET'S-
LET'S. LET'S GO TO- AND I HAD
THE ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO ADD ON
SUPPORT HERE IN PERSON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TODD BLOOM
STEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS ARE
MEMBERS THAT ARE CONDUCTING SOME
OF THE SOIL REMEDIATION OF THAT
THE CENTERS TALKING ABOUT- WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT WE
THINK THIS CLEANS UP THE PROCESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE THE PHONE LINES
MODERATE WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
AND SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT. SB NINE SEVEN EIGHT
. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE FOR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY
YES I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
GARY BISHOP OF THE WILDFIRES
LEAD UP. THANK YOU. A LINE OF
FOUR FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANY BERNACCHI ON BEHALF
OF UNITED CONTRACTORS
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
CONTRACTORS STATEWIDE HUNDREDS
OF THIS WORK IS DONE BY OUR
MEMBERS- WE ARE ALSO VERY MUCH-
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK AT THE
CENTER OF THE FORWARD ON THIS
MEASURE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HIM AND
HIS STAFF AND- STRONG SUPPORT
THE MEASURE IN APPS THAT MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE FOR FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON THIS IS JAMES THROUGH
ACT OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT OF NINE FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION AFFECTS ONE
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
ANYONE HERE IN PERSON. ANYONE
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THEN THEY'RE UP HERE
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IQ AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE LET'S
BRING THEM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS THOUGHTS COMMENTS
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRED FOR BRINGS FOR I JUST
WANT TO. I KNOW THAT YOU SAID
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS LOOK
I. KNOW NO QUALMS WITH SOME.
SKILLED LABOR AND ALL THAT BUT-
I'VE I HAD- PARADISE AND ALSO-
GREENVILLE AND OBVIOUSLY TOO
MANY MY COMMUNITIES AS AS WELL
AS YOU HAD THOSE SAME ISSUES IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES AND- WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT WE LEARNED A LOT
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW. WHEN WE
PERCENT SO PARADISE OBVIOUSLY
WHAT WAS OF MOST. UNBELIEVABLE
SCENE IF YOU LOOK LIKE A NUCLEAR
BOMB WENT OFF THERE AND THERE
WAS A LOT OF CONTAMINANTS IN A
LOT OF THE THINGS HAPPEN SO
NUMBER ONE YOU COMMUNITY GETS
DESTROYED. NUMBER TWO- YES COMES
IN AND THEN. THEY BRING FEDERAL
DOLLARS AND UNDER THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AND YOU BRING IN
CONTRACTORS RATHER SEE YOUR
COMMUNITY JUST GOT HIT THEN YOUR
CONTRACTORS IN YOUR LOCAL AREA.
YEAH HAMMERED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
GET TO WORK SO USE A DOUBLE
WHAMMY. ON YOUR COMMUNITY AND SO
IN THESE VERY. IS SO IN
POPULATED AREAS WE HAVE THE
WORKFORCE WE QUITE BRING WE HAVE
THE SKILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE
AND SOMETIMES. AND LIKE
GREENVILLE LET'S TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE GREENVILLE. I DON'T
THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A HALL
THERE. I KNOW THERE'S ANOTHER
SKILLED WORKFORCE ARE. NOT TO
LEVEL SO I WANT YOU TO BE CAUGHT
I WANT YOU TO BE IT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT I'M SURE YOU DO.
THERE'S GOT TO BE AWARE THAT WE
DON'T HAMMER THE LOCAL
CONTRACTORS AND THE COMMUNITY
ARE THEY LOST OUR COMMUNITY IN
SECOND WHEN THEY DON'T ANY WORK.
SO THAT'S HOURS WERE BRING A
CONCERN UP BECAUSE IT'S REAL AND
IT HAPPENS. THE OTHER THING THAT
HAPPENS TO IS- ON THE RECYCLING
SIDE OF IT WE SAW WE SAW- THE
CONTRACTOR THAT GOT THE BID IN.
IN PARADISE- WASN'T A LOCAL GUY
AND THEY ACTUALLY TRUCK THE STEP
FURTHER BECAUSE- CONTRACT GOT
THE- I COST THE- COST MORE MONEY
AND IT ALSO HURT A LOCAL
CONTRACTOR BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
GET THEY DON'T GET TO LAY DOWN
SO I JUST WANNA SAY THERE THAT
IS SOUNDS GOOD ON IN THE BILL
AND I I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I WANT I
WANT YOU AS IT GOES FORWARD
THERE HAS TO BE. ABILITY TO HELP
MAKE THE COMMUNITY HOLE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY LOST
EVERYTHING IF THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS AND THEY HAVE THE IN THE
FACILITIES TO DO IT. RIGHT THIRD
HERE VETERANS PLEASE YOU I'M AND
I WILL SOMETIMES GET CHOKED UP
ABOUT IT AND I APOLOGIZE JUST
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN. IT'S BEEN
AWFUL. SEEN YEAR AFTER YEAR SO
MANY COMMUNITIES WHETHER IT'S IN
SIR DOLLARS ECHO THE WORDS ARE
ON THE NORTH COAST SO MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEVELED.
AND WHAT I HAVE LEARNED IS THAT
WE WERE NOT PREPARED FOR THIS
REALITY THAT WE'RE ALL FACING
RIGHT NOW. SO THERE BEEN THREE
THAT'S RIGHT THINK THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE AND- CANDIDLY THANKS
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF. CARE BY
CASKEY- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET
THERE ON TO THE STEPS THE FIRST
AND FOREMOST. WE LEARN A LOT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AFTER THE
VALLEY FIRE TORE THROUGH
MIDDLETOWN. AND BURNED DOWN
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED HOMES. IT
DESTROYED CAL RECYCLE THERE WAS
NO INTERNAL DEPARTMENT THAT WAS
FOCUSED ON DEBRIS AND WE HAD TO
BE A REBUILD IT FROM THE GROUND
UP. AND IT WAS A STATE SPONSORED
PROJECTS THE OF TWO DIFFERENT
PROJECTS WHEN IT COMES TO CLEAN
UP DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
FIRE RIGHT STATE AND OR FEDERAL.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT
WAS STATE WE LEARNED THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT AN
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT FOR DEBRIS
REMOVAL INTERNAL ACCOUNT
RECYCLE. THANKS TO THE DIRECTION
OF DIRECTOR WAGNER. AND THAT MAY
SEEM LEADERSHIP I'VE JEREMIH
CASKEY THEY ARE NEARLY FULLY
STAFFED WITH AN INTERNAL
DEPARTMENT AND ALL THE FLIPPING
DO IS TO BRING. DURING THE
SUMMER AND FALL. AND THEY
COORDINATE WITH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. AT THE TABLE
WHEN WE'VE BEEN HAVING THESE
MEETINGS HAS BEEN. INFORMALLY OF
COURSE HAS BEEN CONTRACTORS HAS
BEEN CARRY CYCLE HAS BEEN- YES
WE TRY TO WORK THROUGH THE
CHALLENGES THAT- CENTER DOLLY
HAS JUST ADDRESSED. WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED TO A STEP TWO WE GOTTA
GET OR PRE QUALIFIED LIST THIS
IS CRAZY WE'RE BRINGING IN LARGE
CONTRACTORS FROM FLORIDA. I TO
COME DO THE WORK. AND THEN THEY
SCRAMBLE TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE SO WHAT WE
DID IN MIDDLETOWN AND OFFERING
JUNIORS CAN TALK ABOUT THIS IS
THEY ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE
STATE OFF THE MERCY SERVICES
WERE ABLE TO HIRE A LITTLE LESS
THAN A THIRD OF THE ACTUAL
CLEANUP WORK FORCE. FROM THE
COUNTY. FROM THE CAP YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH TWO WEEKS
CERTIFICATION HAS WHOPPER
TRAINING THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE UNDER THIS
PLAN WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO GET
MORE FOLKS BACK TO WORK AND WHEN
THEY NEED IT MOST BECAUSE THESE
FOLKS HAVE LOST LITERALLY
EVERYTHING. IN OUR LIFE. SO IT
IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT TO DO
THAT. THE THIRD ITEM I WOULD
JUST SAY IS- WE HAVE TO HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. WE HAVE TO
GET- TREES OUT PLUS WE HAVE TO
GET DEBRIS OUT AND SO THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE A PRE QUALIFICATION.
I CALL A CONTRACTOR COULD BE
QUALIFY FOR BOTH OR IT COULD BE
QUALIFIED FOR ONE OF THE OTHER.
IS THAT ANY OTHER PIECE I'M JUST
BEING REALLY TRANSPARENT WITH
YOU CENTER DOLLY. WE ARE NOT
FOCUSING ON THE RECYCLING IN
WITHIN THIS BUT SIMPLY ON GROUP
DEBRIS REMOVAL AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATION
WITH YOU ON THIS CASE. YOUR
OPINION IS HE YOU HAVE IS CREEK
- JUST. A REMAIN. JUST OF COURSE
SO. IN THE TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE. OR BUILDING YEAH. PARADISE
CAR FIRE REDDING YEAH GREEN BILL
LAST YEAR FOR MAJOR EVENTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE GETTING A
LOT BETTER AT THE RESPONSE I
MEAN IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE TIME FROM. ORVILLE PARADISE
TO LAST YEAR- YES CARRY CYCLE
THEY WERE ALL ON THE GROUND
BEFORE THE FIRE WAS EVEN PUT
OUT. A BEFORE WE LOS GREENVILLE
THEY WERE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN HELP MITIGATE SO WE
HAVE MOVED MOUNTAINS IN
COORDINATION AND I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT BUT THERE HAS TO BE
COORDINATION FOR IT'S NOT JUST.
TREE REMOVAL IT IS IT IS THE
CALORIE CYCLE GOING TO BE THERE
TOO AND WE HAVE TO THE
CONTRACTORS DO THAT AS WELL SO
THAT THAT BUT I THINK YOU SHOULD
LOOK AT AT IN THIS PROCESS. I'M
I'M GONNA BE HELPFUL BUT I DON'T
WANNA LEAVE ANYBODY BEHIND IN MY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES EITHER.
TOTALLY AGREE AND- I NEVER WANT
TO BE COREY. WHEN I SAY THERE'S
A WORK IN PROGRESS WE REALLY
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
TWO YEARS. I BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE- THE DEPARTMENT
MOVES IN THE COMING. FEW MONTHS
ON A PRE QUALIFIED LIST THIS IS
ALL DONE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP.
OF OBVIOUSLY GOVERNOR NEWSOM. IS
WELL AS DIRECTOR WAGNER AND CAL
RECYCLE SHE HAS BEEN AMAZING. I
GOT TO SAY. AND WE ARE SO LUCKY
TO HAVE MARKER THE DUTY. AS
DIRECTOR OF- YES BECAUSE THEY
BECOME GOOD AT IT. NOW WE NEED
TO BECOME. GREAT IN TURN THIS
INTO A MODEL BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING BACK TO WHAT WE HAD IN
I'M- CENTER DIED BE HAPPY. IF
YOU BE WILLING TO. ENGAGE ON
THIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
ASKING. I DON'T THINK YOU GIVE
YOURSELF ENOUGH CREDIT- I'D LIKE
FOR YOU TO ADDRESS. SIX YEARS
AGO SEVEN YEARS AGO ALL THE BIG
FIRES WERE HANDLED BY FEMA BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET THIS
NARRATIVE OF. SOME GUY FROM
FLORIDA COMING IN NOT RECYCLING
STUFF NOT KNOWING THE LOCAL ALL
THE LITTLE FIRES WERE. PRODUCTS
OF- OF CAL RECYCLE AND EVEN THE
LITTLE FIRES CAL RECYCLES. AND
A- CHALLENGED THE LAST SIX YEARS
THERE'S BEEN AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE TO QUIT CAL RECYCLED AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN YOU.
EXPLAIN WHERE WE'RE AT BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT THE EXTERNALITIES
ARE ALSO A WORK IN PROGRESS OF
WHERE WE'VE COME WITH IF WE HAVE
A BIG FIRE COMING UP THIS YEAR
HOW THAT'S GOING TO BE TREATED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
UNDERSTANDING YEAH NO ABSOLUTELY
SO RIGHT NOW- WHICH IS BEEN
REALLY IMPRESSIVE AND I'M GONNA
USE THE TUBBS FIRE FOR EXAMPLE.
OF THE WAY THIS NEW MODEL HAS
WORKED IS THAT YOU HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
DIRECTOR ON THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES DIRECTOR MARK
OF THE DUTIES LITERALLY
OVERSEEN. WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH- ROBERT FENTON WHOSE THAT I
REGION NINE ADMINISTRATOR FOR
FEMA ON CO MANAGEMENT OF THE
ENTIRE DEBRIS REMOVAL. SO YOU
HAVE US DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN.
TERROR- EXCUSE ME I'M HERE
BECAUSE HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND WHAT I THINK THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE A TO SEE GOING
INTO THIS. IS THREE LEVELS OF
DISASTER SMALL MEETING MARCH.
RIGHT INTO YOU WOULD HAVE
CONTRACTOR- IN THIS IS WHY STATE
TO WORK IN PROGRESS BECAUSE THIS
IS STILL BEING WORKED OUT. THAT
WOULD BE THAT COULD QUALIFY FOR
ALL OR QUALIFY FOR SOME OR
QUALIFY FOR ONE OF THOSE
CATEGORIES. AND SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
WITH THIS BUT- MR SENATORS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN REGARDS THE
WAY WE CHANGE THIS THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IS THIS. ONE OF
THE WORST EXPERIENCES THAT WE'VE
HAD OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS IS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IS
WHEN WE HAD TO CHANGE
CONTRACTORS MIDSTREAM FOR THE
TUBBS FIRE YEAH. IT WAS AWFUL.
IN ORDER TO GROW JUDE SHE
BROUGHT A STATE. BENEFIT THE JOB
. I'M BUT IT SAID BEHIND FOUR
WEEKS. SO THAT'S WHY IT'S THIS
PRE QUALIFICATION THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
I'M SORRY CENTER CASCADED NO NO
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S GOOD I
GUESS I DON'T LIKE TO GET TO THE
SECOND PIECE BECAUSE- ONE
PORSCHE ON. DEBRIS REMOVAL AND
THIS IS TREE REMOVAL CAN YOU
TALK I MEAN WHAT'S WHAT'S YOUR
THINKING ON BECAUSE WHEN THESE
FIRES COME SOME OF THE TREES
THAT NEED TO BE REMOVED ARE.
OUTSIDE THE LIVEABLE AREA SOME
OF OUR MARK YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
NEIGHBOR'S TREE- HOW IS ACT HOW
IS THAT APPROACHED. BY FOR YOUR
VISION ON THIS- BY CAL RECYCLE I
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO- PRE QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS
FOR BOTH. ON AND ONE CONTRACTOR
COULD DO BOTH OR JUST ONE BUT
LOOK SO RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU HAVE
A LARGE IRE THAT COMES THROUGH.
TYPICALLY AND I AM NOT A
PROFESSIONAL BUT I'LL JUST TELL
YOU WHAT I'VE SEEN CRITICALLY
YOU HAVE A LARGE AT TIMES
MULTINATIONAL TECH. ALL THIS TO
BE A- WHAT IF TO FACE OF REMOVAL
YOU HAVE- WHERE I. THE COMPANY
ALSO HAS IS THE REMOVAL AND THEN
YOU GET RID OF ALL THE
FOUNDATIONS AND THE REMAINDER OF
THE CARS EXCEPT DR THEN YOU HAVE
THE DEAD AND DYING TREES AND YOU
REALLY HAVE A TREE OUTSIDE
COMING IN ACTUALLY OF ALL THE
EGGS THAT ARE OUT THERE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT ARE EITHER DYING
OR DEAD. SO JUST BEING HONEST
WHERE I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE
THIS PLAY OUT IS IT THERE'LL BE
TO PRE QUALIFIED LIST ONE FOR
DEBRIS. ONE FOR TREES IN YOU'D
HAVE TO SEPARATE LIST OF
CONTRACTORS THAT WOULD NOT BE ON
THAT PRE QUALIFIED THIS TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE BUT AGAIN I DON'T
WANT TO JUMP AHEAD OF MY SKIS
BUT I BELIEVE THAT'S WHERE THIS
IS GOING TO END UP. THANK. OKAY
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS FROM
THE- FROM MEMBERS OKAY THANKS
AND MOVED WILL GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE RESPECT
FASTER. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
TOM PLEASE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR S.
B. NINE SEVEN EIGHT BY SENATOR
REQUIRE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BATES. IT'S
DOLLY AYE DADDY AYE GONZALEZ
SKINNER STERN ALL RIGHT STERN HI
MY COUNTY BY COUNTY I. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THINK CENTER. PART
WILL ASK OUR CENTER HERTZBERG TO
APPROACH THE DICE NOW TO PRESENT
ITEMS TWO AND THREE YEAR GENESIS
IS THE SB NINETY ONE NSP NINE
EIGHTY NINE.
ANYONE BUSINESS LIKE YES YOU'RE
DOING NINE EIGHT NINETY ONE THIS
IS THE- BUSINESS LICENSES
STORMWATER DISCHARGE COMPLIANCE
. OKAY ALREADY MR YES PLEASE
SURE YEP OKAY. THIS IS ONE OF
THESE KINDS OF BILLS. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET LOW GOVERNMENT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. WE WANT THEM
TO GET HEIR PERMIT. THEIR
INDUSTRIAL GENERAL PERMIT TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL WATER
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS OKAY. MAKES
PRETTY SIMPLE WE PASSED THE BILL
THINK ABOUT THIS HEY WE PASSED
THE BILL AND WE TRIED TO USE THE
BUSINESS LICENSE APPROACH TO BE
ABLE TO THEN GATHER THE
INFORMATION. AND THE SUCCESS TWO
THOUSAND ENTITIES AND UP BUT
GUESS WHAT. HOME LOCAL COMPANIES
DON'T HAVE BUSINESS LICENSE
THEIRBUSINESS CERTIFICATES AND
IS IT THE LAW DOESN'T APPLY TO
US. SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO WE
HAVE TO NOW REWRITE THE LAW WE
HAVE A NEW LAW SPEND ALL THIS
MONEY OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS SO
THAT WE CAN NOW SAY NOT JUST
BUSINESS LICENSES BUT BUSINESS
CERTIFICATES SO WE CAN GO AFTER
HIM TO MAKE SURE. THAT THEY WILL
COMPLY WITH THE LAW THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AS THEY SAY
IN YIDDISH- WALKING CARP YOU
GOTTA HOLD YOUR HEAD. THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE TO ME WITH THAT I
GOT A VERY GOOD WITNESS HERE'S
WHO'S BEEN WORKING WITH ME SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER SEAN BOTHWELL HER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WHO'S BEEN
WITH ME ALL THE WAY ON ALL OF
THESE VARIOUS MEASURES OVER THE
YEARS. IF YOU SEE. THANK YOU
TERRY AND ERIC MEMBERS AND-
SEVEN HERTZBERG- WE PASSED SB
TWO OH FIVE SEVERAL YEARS AGO. I
WAS REALLY WE CAME UP WITH AN
ELEGANT SOLUTION- US WORKING
WITH PERMIT TEAS DOWN NEXT TO
THE LA REGION. A CAME UP WITH
THIS THIS CONCEPT- AND WE REALLY
WANTED TO COMMIT TO MAKING SURE
THAT- THAT IT WAS AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD FOR BUSINESSES-
AND THAT WE- ALSO STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS. LOCAL GOD SO THAT
IT WASN'T BURDEN UPON THEM- AND
NOT BILL PASSED HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SENATORS- AND
SO WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THERE'S BEEN
A COUPLE ISSUES THAT HAVE POPPED
UP- THE SENATOR BROUGHT UP THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONE WHICH IS
THERE'S CERTAIN CITIES AND-
THROUGH THIS BILL WE'VE GOT TO
DISCOVER THAT. THAT THEY'RE
QUITE LARGE CITY SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES SAN JOSE. I HAVE
BUSINESS CERTIFICATES INSTEAD OF
BUSINESS LICENSES. BUT THE
INTENT IS THE SAME. ARE THAT
THEY'RE ESSENTIALLY PERMITTING
OR ALLOWING A BUSINESS. WITH
THEIR- I SAID YOU'RE BILL BUT
ARE COMPLYING WITH LAW BECAUSE
AREN'T IN. UNDER THIS INDUSTRIAL
STORMWATER PERMIT AND SO WE WANT
TO FIX THAT ISSUE- THE SB TWO A
FIVE YEAR ORIGINAL LAW IS
WORKING WE HAVE OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND NEW BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE ENROLLED UNDER THIS
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMITS
SINCE. SINCE IT WAS ADOPTED ITS
ONLY A COUPLE YEARS AGO- COUPLE
OTHER THINGS THE BILL DOES
THAT'S IMPORTANT- SOME OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PHARNACES.
PROVIDING THE INFORMATION. IT
WAS PROVIDED TO THEM FOR THEM TO
GET THE BUSINESS LICENSE AND
WE'VE IDENTIFIED CERTAIN
FACILITIES THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE
SHOULD A LICENSE BECAUSE THE
GENERAL IN THE PERMIT. SO WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME
TRANSPARENCY SO THE PUBLIC KNOWS
WHAT THOSE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS ARE. IT'S VERY SIMPLE
IT'S JUST JUST OF A FOUR DIGIT
CODE- THAT WE WANT TO BE
PROVIDED ALONG WITH THE- NAME
ADDRESS DATE WHICH IS ALREADY
BEING REQUIRED- AND THEN LASTLY
THERE'S A LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT
IN. SAID THAT THEY WERE EXIST-
PROBLEM FOR FROM THE PROCESS.
AND THE- OVERSIGHT BY THE BOARDS
TO GET ON TO THAT. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT SOME OF THE NEW
PERMIT FEES ARE. FOR IT ACTION
TO TURN POST TRUTH ARE. FROM
PERMITS REQUIREMENTS- AND THAT
THEY'RE DOING THEIR FAIR PART.
AND THEN LAST BUT JUST REALLY.
TOTAL. YEAH BARMOUTH. INSTEAD
SURE. BUSINESS ADDRESSING THEIR
INDUSTRIALS POLLUTION. BUT IF
IT'S NOT ADDRESS. THE POLLUTION
AND RUNNING INTO THE- THE NEW-
STORMWATER I KNOW THEY BECOME
LIABLE FOR IT AND SO THAT'S ONE
OF THE REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS
WERE ALSO TRYING TO HELP THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS YOU OF THEIR
OWN STORMWATER LIABILITY BY. ALL
THE INDUST COASTS ARE ARE IN THE
SAME BEEN PLAYING FIELD I WOULD
COMES TO COMPLY WITH THE PERMIT
SO. WITH THAT I ANSWERED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S GO TO
ON THE PHONE LINES TO SEE- SORRY
SOON AS A PERSON ONE TO RAISE.
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. OKAY
PHONE LINES ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU WANT TO. VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT NINETY ONE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB BE
EIGHT NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
WHAT AND THEN THERE ARE FEWER
PARTS. AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHIP. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF THREE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS THAT TO JUSTIN MILLAND A
POP OF HEAL THE BAY IN SANTA
MONICA AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH ART SIDE
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL CONCERNS
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY RARE
DISPOSITION. AND HERE PERSON ON
THE PHONE LINES CONCERNED ABOUT
THE BILL ON A VOICE OPPOSITION.
MONITOR EFFECTIVE. THANK YOU FOR
NOT THE VISION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. FOR ANY
OPPOSITION THAT IS THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NOT THANK YOU
AT THE FRONT MITCHELL K. LET'S
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS COMMENTS.
SENATOR STERN. THAN FARMERS AND-
I WOULD JUST PRIVATELY
EXPRESSING MY FRUSTRATION THAT
WE HAVE TO DO THIS BILL BUT
THAT'S HOW IT GOES I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TO DO THE CLEAN- WE
NOT GET THIS THROUGH. QUICKER I
MEAN HOW FAST DO WE NEED THIS
THE SOLUTIONS IN THE FIELD IN
YOUR GUYS VIEW. THINGS LIKE A NO
BRAINER BILL SEEMS TO BE SEND
COMMITTEE IS IT WORTH TRYING TO
GET IT THROUGH AN EMERGENCY
LEGISLATION. YEAH MY- WE ARE AT
NOT A BY. BAKER BE I MEAN LOOK
THE POINT I WANT TO SEE MY
CLOTHES NOW RESPONSE POINT SINCE
YOU'RE NOT 5% OF CALIFORNIA
WATERS WATER WHICH ARE
CONSIDERED IMPAIRED ALREADY
POLLUTED SO CLEARLY TONIGHT
SHOWING WE'VE GOT SEVEN THOUSAND
ENTITIES THE REGISTERS OF THE
BILL WHICH YES. MAKE IT IS
POSSIBLE PROVOKES. TO COMPLY IT
ALSO SEAN WAS SAYING IT HAS A
REALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO LIABILITY THAT WE'VE
SEEN. HEY WE WANT TO HELP THEM
TO. THIS IS RESTORING THE
BURDEN. MLB ABOUT IDEA TO PUT IN
THE URGENCY LEGISLATION. I MOVE
THE BILL. THANKS THANK YOU
SENATOR A SENATOR ALI. SO- I
HAVEN'T GOT THROUGH THE WHOLE
BILL BUT I JUST JUST IN GENERAL
HOOPS I MEAN WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
GO TO. GET A BUSINESS LICENSE.
WHICH I HAVE IN THE PAST RIGHT
YEAR YOU GET YOUR BUSINESS NAME
AND GO TO THE COUNTY OR CITY OR
WHEREVER YOU'RE AT IN YOUR
BUSINESS LICENSE SO. IS IT THAT
POINT IS WHERE THEY CAN ASK.
WHETHER YOU. HOW TO QUALIFY FOR
ASTATE JUST CHARGE FROM IT I
MEAN. THERE WAS LEDGES THERE WAS
FEDERAL LEGISLATION. THAT STATE
LEGISLATION AT ONE POINT THAT
WAS IF WATER RAN OFF THE ROOF IN
YOUR GUTTER. AND INTO THE STREAM
YOU HAVE TO GET A PERMIT. THAT
WOULD AND THAT FAILED. IT WAS IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BUT- I WANNA I
WANNA KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHAT WHAT WHO'S GONNA FACT
. WHICH I THINK SHOULD ANSWER
THANK YOU SENATOR- SO WITH THE
SYSTEM WE CREATED AND- ALSO
RIGHT OFF THE BAT THERE'S A
PROVISION IN- THE TWO OH FIVE
BILL WE- TO BE CLEAR THAT. NONE
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO
SET UP ANY PROCESS OR DO ANY OF
THE ANALYSIS THEMSELVES WE ARE
NOT. PUSHING THE REGIONAL BOARD
OF THE WATER BOARD'S
RESPONSIBILITY AND AUTHORITY ON
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. SO THE PROCESS
CREATED INTO A PRIVATE. THE TWO
STEP PROCESS THE FIRST IS THE
APPLICANT PROVIDES THEIR S. I.
C. CODE NUMBER WHICH EVERY
BUSINESS HAS ITS THREE TO FOUR
DIGITS- AND THEN FROM THERE. IF
THAT AS I SEE CODE NUMBER
MATCHES UP WITH WHAT SO THE
STATE WATER BOARD COUPLE YEARS
AGO PUT TOGETHER A WEB PAGE.
ALTHOUGH THE CODES THAT NEED TO
BE UNDER THE INDUSTRIAL PERMIT
IF THOSE CODES MAY UP. THE LOCAL
- I DID. NUMBER THANKS TO PERMIT
. THAT THEY HAVE. AND SO THAT'S
IT THEY HAVE TO TWO NUMBERS IN
THE APPLICATION. AND THEN IF
THEY HAVE THE NUMBERS THEY'RE
GIVEN THE BUSINESS LICENSE. IF
THEY HAVE THE S. I. C. CODE BUT
DON'T HAVE A THE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER. THERE HAS TO GO TO THE
WATER BOARD GET. THAT PROCESS
GOING WHICH TAKES ABOUT SEVEN
DAYS. WE PUT A PROVISION INTO S.
B. TWO OH FIVE THAT IF THERE'S
AN EXISTING BUSINESS AND THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY NEEDED
THIS PERMIT COVERAGE. IF THREE
MONTHS TO GO SEE THAT- GET THAT
NUMBER FROM THE WATER BOARD
WHICH AGAIN. THEY SAY TAKES
ABOUT SEVEN DAYS TO DO WE
HAVEN'T HEARD ANY ISSUE WITH. IT
HOLDING ANYTHING UP OR DELAYED.
AND SO ONCE THEY HAVE THAT THAT
SECOND NUMBER THAN THEY CAN
RETURN BACK TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND GET THE REST. SO
AS SOMEBODY WHO. YOU KNOW
ELECTED IN UNDERSTAND THERE'S A-
YOU KNOW. A THOUSAND LAWS PASSED
IN THIS BUILDING EVERY YEAR AND
THE GUY THE PERSON THAT'S OUT
THERE THAT DOESN'T THAT'S BEEN
CARRYING ON. HE'S GONNA HAVE
THREE MONTHS OF THIS BILL PASSES
FOR HERE SHE'S GONNA HAVE THREE
MONTHS TO FIGURE OUT FIRST OF
ALL. DON'T KNOW PART NOT
COMPLIANCE. SO IN IS ARE GONNA
BE A FINE OR AND WHAT'S THE COST
GOING TO BE FOR THE PERSON THAT
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THAT DOESN'T
FALL LEGISLATION OF DAYS JUST
TRYING TO RUN THEIR BUSINESS AND
WHOSE IN FORCE WHO'S GOING TO.
ENFORCE SO THE IDEA WOULD BE
THAT THREE MONTHS TO SUBMIT
THEIR APPLICATION TO THE WATER
BOARD. AND THEN THEY GET THE
FOUR DIGIT CODE. AND THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS UP FOR
THOSE THREE MONTHS- AND ONCE
THEY HAVE THE NUMBER THEN THAT
THE GOVERNMENT GIVES THEM THEIR
RENEWAL BUSINESS LICENSE. OR
THEIR NEW BUSINESS LICENSE- SO I
HOPE I HOPE I MEAN. BASICALLY
WHEN YOU FILL OUT THE IN OTHER
WORDS YOU GET YOUR NUMBER YOUR
FOUR DIGIT CODE RIGHT AND SO NOW
THE NEXT YEAR LET'S ASSUME YOUR
BUSINESS YOU'VE GOT TO GO AND
RENEW YOUR QUESTION SLICES LIKE
EVERYBODY DOES IS GONNA BE OF.
THIS CAN BE A FOREMAN THERE YOU
GO BY YES TELL WHAT YOUR COACH
CODE IN BINGO THAT'S WHAT IT IS
IT'S JUST YOU'LL SEE IT ON THE
FORM WHEN YOU GET YOUR BUSINESS
LICENSE THAT'S WE TRY TO MAKE IT
SIMPLE. ARMISEN GONNA. SOLVE THE
DILEMMA. DAY INTO A LITTLE MORE
BECAUSE- OF WHAT I'M CONFIRM
CONCERNED ABOUT IS. THAT IF THE
PERSON THAT DOESN'T KNOW. THE
DOESN'T KNOW IT. DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THIS BUILDING EVERY DAY. AND I
WANT TO SEE WHO FALLS INTO WHAT
CATEGORY BEFORE I. JUST BLANK AT
LEAST SAY YES BECAUSE- WE PASSED
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS LAWS.
OVER TIME AND MOST PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW THEY'RE BREAKING THE LAW
UNTIL SOMEONE. COUNTY ITEMS OUT
THERE AND SAYS OH YOU. YOU GOT
SIX VIOLATIONS IN THERE'S A FINE
THERE'S- LIKE I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
SOMETHING. I DON'T FALL UNDER
THAT LAW. HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT SENATOR DICK
OKAY HE'S HE'S LIVING ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS. A CENTERS FOR
EXPEDITING THE BILL. INTENTLY
YEP THE KEY FOR THE CONSEQUENCES
YEAH. THE MEASURE ON THE ON THE
THERE'S SO TO RESPOND TO THAT
SENATOR THERE ISN'T A
CONSEQUENCE FOR NOT KNOWING THE
WHOLE POINT OF THIS BILL IS
ALMOST EDUCATION TO LET THEM
KNOW HEY YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
ENROLLED UNDER THIS PERMIT. GO
APPLY FOR THE PERMIT BEFORE WE
RENEW YOUR BUSINESS LICENSE
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF THE INTENT
OF THAT THERE THERE IS NO
PUNISHMENT FOR NOT KNOWING OR
NOT BEING ENROLLED- TO BE HONEST
IF IT WITHOUT THIS BILL SOMEONE
LIKE ME QUITE FRANKLY OR THE
REGIONAL BOARD AN NGO IF WE
FOUND OUT THAT SOMEONE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE UNDER THE
PERMANENT NOT. THERE COULD BE AN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION CHALLENGE- IN
THAT CASE BUT IT IN THIS BILL
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT I THINK
IT GETS TO PROP THEM HEY YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE UNDER THIS PERMIT
AND THEN THEY WOULD GO GET THE
APPLICATION NUMBER. YEAH I THINK
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LAST PAGE OF
THE MEASURE ON PAGE TWELVE TALKS
ABOUT JUNE FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE STATE PORCHER REQUIRE
ALL RECIPIENTS OF NOT OF A NON.
APPLICABILITY OF IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER TO. GET THE INFORMATION
BUT THERE IS I SEE NOTHING IN
THE BILL THAT REQUIRES THAT AS A
CONSEQUENCE FOR THAT. I PROBABLY
IS YOUR CALL YOU KNOW IF YOU
THINK TO THE LAWS AYE SOME CATCH
ALL. VIOLATION OF THE STAFF
KNOWS THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION BUT TO. BUT I ABSENCE
IF YOU POINT I DON'T DISAGREE OF
HIS HARD TO FOLLOW ALL THE STUFF
THAT COMES OUT OF THIS PLACE
YOU'RE NOT WRONG. A BUT I THINK.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE WE'RE
NOT IMPOSING SOME BIG NEW THING
ON ANYBODY ELSE ALL WE'RE TRYING
TO DO PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY'VE
GOT THESE PRECIOUS STUFF FOR
THIS LOSS IN A PLACE FOR A LONG
TIME. WE'RE TRYING TO JUST PUT A
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
TO MAKE SURE ALL OF THESE FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE PER. THAT DON'T
KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE PERMITS
ACTUALLY HE- FIRED MEETING PLACE
IN THEIR BUSINESS CERTIFICATE IN
A BUSINESS LICENSE TO COMPLY
MAKE IT SUPER SIMPLE FOR THEM TO
DO SO. RIGHT THERE'S A WEBSITE
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE POSTED. YOU
GO LOOK AT IT. IS COULD BE A
BLANK FORM IT'S REALLY ALL ABOUT
THE INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE REQUIREMENT. FOR THIS
DISCHARGE FROM THE STATE TO THE
LOCALS AND MAKING SURE
BUSINESSES COMPLY. THAT MINUTE
THE IMPACT. GOVERNMENT SICK.
HOWEVER THIS CHART THE STORM
WATER RUNOFF AND STUFF. A. N.
AND- HOLD PEOPLE RESPONSE FOR
ARE ACTUALLY CAUSING THE
CHALLENGE LIKE TO ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROWS THAT ARE
UPSTREAM FROM MY FARM. THEY
DON'T GET PERMITS FOR ANYTHING.
BUT I DON'T OF THE NECESSARY
APPLIES WELL THAT'S WHAT WE GOT
TO COVER YOUR BILL THE CLAMP
DOWN ON THE MAGISTRATE OUT THERE
NOT GO SOURCES GLORIA. BUT I
JUST CO AUTHORED I SEND YOU THE
PICTURE OF IT YOU SEE IT AS A TO
THE- I DON'T KNOW TECH STUFF YOU
SENT ME RT. WE SHOULD. ALL RIGHT
OKAY ALL RIGHT US FOR NOT VOTE
THANK YOU- THE- ASSEMBLY HOLLOW
. I ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT
NINE ONE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING TALLY.
DALLY NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
SKINNER STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY AYE.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S THREE VOTES
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S LEAVE
THE ROLL UP AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH THEIR NEXT BILL CENTER
THAT'S IT. SB NINETY NINE. SO WE
CREATED THE IT WAS- AUTUMN BURKE
AND- KIM WHO THE OTHER CO AUTHOR
WAS CREATED A PROGRAM FOR THESE.
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES WHO IS IT. ARAMBULA
STRAIGHT ASSEMBLY MERIMBULA.
GAME AND WE CREATED THIS TCC THE
CRATES HE GOES COUNCIL WHICH
CENTER THERE WAS A MEMBER. WHEN
HE WAS IN HIS OLD JOB. AND IT'S
NUMBER EIGHTEEN VARIOUS PROGRAMS
EIGHT OF IT'S A SERIES OF
PROGRAMS. WHERE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A PHD IN FILLING OUT FORMS IN
DEALING WITH THE STUFF IT'S
USUALLY COMPLICATED WE SPENT
OVER A YEAR AND AT POINT BUFFER
PROCLAIM A BEAUTIFUL TRYING TO
GET THEM THE THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. GENERAL CAST YOU KNOW I
ACTUALLY WENT TO. POLAND WITH
THE HEAD OF THE VIEW CO COUNSEL
I WAS LOBBYING HIM FOR QUITE
AWHILE HOLDEN TO LOBBY OF. FOR
THIS BUT IT WAS VERY COMPLICATED
AND VERY DIFFICULT. THE PROGRAM
IS A GREAT PROGRAM IT'S
IMPORTANT AND ALL THE OLD YOU
KNOW AND CENTER ACCOUNTS YOU
WILL REMIND US OF THIS BECAUSE
HE'S RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT START
GREAT. BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
BASICALLY LOCKED IN ESSENCE IS
DOING T. C. C. LIGHT FOR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES SMALLER COMMUNITY
PROJECTS THAT AREN'T SO
DIFFICULT THAT MAKE IT EASIER
FOR COMMUNITIES TO GET INVOLVED.
BACKYARDS TO BE IMPACT
ESPECIALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMITTEES COMMITTEES ARE
CHALLENGED TO GIVE THEM A CHANCE
TO PARTICIPATE WITHOUT HAVING TO
HAVE THESE PARTNERS IN ALL OF
THE COMPLEXITIES OF WHAT IT TOOK
FOR US WHICH ULTIMATELY WAS
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
KOYNA. AND JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
PROCESS AND MAYBE THAT'S GOOD
FOR THE BIGGER STUFF AND AN
ADMITTEDLY IS SORT OF A CASKET
WILL TELL US. THAT IF THIS DOES
NOT COME CLOSE TO WHAT AN
AEROBIC DIGESTER DOES IN TERMS
OF IMPACT BUT IT IS IMPORTANT AS
WE DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE EXTREME HEAT ALL
OF THESE THINGS TO GIVE LOCAL.
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACCESS FUNDS AND- AND ACTIVISTS
THIS PROCESS IN A IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY IT IS IT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND SO I HAVE. OF MY
RESEARCH A CHRISTIANSEN FROM THE
FRIENDS OF THE L. A. RIVER AND
READ ADDIS NATURE FOR ALL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF. THIS
MEASURE. OKAY THE GERMAN YES
LET'S GO AHEAD WITH THE- MERCED
FIRST YOU WANNA. BUT- SHE'S.
WHICH ARE READING BECAUSE HE'S
IN WHO GOES OKAY OKAY WE'LL GO
IMMERSE ACROSS. ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON. MAYOR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG MY NAME IS
BRENT CHRISTIANSEN AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF. LOS
ANGELES BAKER. WE DON'T HAVE TO
BE FOR COMMUNITY STUDENTS AND
FUTURE LEADERS TO ADVOCATE FOR
NATURE CLIMATE AN ATHLETE ON THE
L. A. RIVER. OR IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE CELL BECAUSE THE RIVER WE
WORK ON FLOWS THROUGH SOME OF
THE REGION'S MOST DENSELY
POPULATED AND POLLUTION BURDENS.
COMMUNITY THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AT THE
FRONTLINE. MANAGING CLIMATE
IMPACT. SB NINETY. WITH SUPPORT
. WORK THE BILL RESILIENCE
PERSPEX COMMITTEE. CRUCIAL
BECAUSE AS WE'VE ALL SEEN FROM
NUMEROUS DIRE SCIENTIFIC REPORT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY HÌNH LAST MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS. EVEN IF
THE ENTIRE WORLD ALL SEATS HE
EMISSIONS ZERO TOMORROW THE PLAN
IT WOULD STILL BE EXPECTED TO
WARM. FOR OVER A DECADE. DUE TO
THE GASES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
OUR ATMOSPHERE. THOUGH BELIEVE
IRAQ REALITY IS CALIFORNIA HAVE
TO PREPARE FOR A FUTURE THAT IS
LESS PROFITABLE WHILE DOING ITS
PART BECAUSE INITIALLY
CONTRIBUTING TO IT. SB NINE NINE
EIGHT NINE WILL HELP PREPARE THE
STATE SENATE FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTIES FOR TAXIS SURE. THERE
ARE NUMEROUS PRODUCTS THAT CAN
BE DEVELOPED OUR REGION AND
ACROSS THE STATE. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE I'M A FAN OF THAT AS
WELL AS OTHER MULTIPLE BENEFITS.
THAT WE NEED THE STATE AND STATE
AGENCIES LIKE TO CURRENCIES HELD
BACK. FOR THAT REASON WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I THOUGHT
ON SP. NINE EIGHT NINE EIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL GO TO
YOU MISTER AT. I THANK YOU
MEMBERS RE OUT OF SOME. OF NEW
FOR WE'RE A LOSS BASED
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING AND RESTORING. THE
PUBLIC SPACES OPEN SPACES AND
PARK LANDS AND MAKING SURE WE
HAVE COMMUNITIES CONNECTED TO
THOSE PROJECTS. OBVIOUSLY JUST
AS YOU'RE GRAPPLING WITH IT OVER
THE YEARS WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND THEN WANTING TO LOOK
AT OUR CONSERVATION PROJECTS
THROUGH THAT FILTER WANTING TO.
DEVELOP MULTI BENEFIT CLIMATE
FOCUSED PROJECTS THEY ARE BOTH
DEALING WITH NATURE OPEN SPACE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE THINK THIS
MEASURE GOES A LONG WAY
PROVIDING US AN ABILITY TO GO
PROVIDE THE- ACCESS DOLLARS IN
GRANT FUNDS. WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS WITH LOCAL STATE
AGENCIES LIKE CONSERVANCY'S
DEVELOP THIS PROJECT. BACON IS
MULTI BENEFIT AS POSSIBLE. BUT
TO THE SENATORS PORT- POINT%
ALLOWING US TO ACTUALLY DO THAT
IN A WAY THAT WITH OUR LIMITED
CAPACITY. AND WITH OUR LIMITED
GROUPS THAT WE WORK WITH WE CAN
DO THAT AT A SMALLER SCALE WITH
THOSE PROJECTS TOGETHER AND
APPLY FOR A GRANT. WITH WITHOUT
YOU KNOW YEARS OF WORK AND-
EXPERTISE. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE'RE WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE WE
APPRECIATE THE WAY THAT THE BILL
BREAKS OUT IT AND TO BE SICKLY
THREE DIFFERENT GRANT PROGRAMS
ONE BASED ON COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY WANNA LANDSCAPERS ON
CM ONE FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. WHICH WE OFTEN ALSO
THINK IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT TO US
SO FOR THOSE REASONS INSTRUCTOR
FOR TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO- ANYONE
ELSE WANTS TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. HELLO ABIGAIL MILE AND
A HALF. THIS IS THE ASIAN OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS LA
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST.
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLAN COALITION. AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND- IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES IN
ONCE A VOICE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL SB NINE EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN IT IS ONE
AND THEN VIDEO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE EIGHTY NINE.
WE DO HAVE ONE ONE MOMENT FUTURE
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. AFTERNOON CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS
THAT BECAUSE FOR SOME BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF CENTER HERTZBERG SB
NINE EIGHT NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AGAIN WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. NINE EIGHT NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THE- ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL FOR YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- ARMS I'M HERE I'M
SO SORRY I'M SO SORRY THERE IS
NO RESERVATION BUT I BUT
CERTAINLY WE WOULD WELCOME
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL- EITHER
ANYONE IN PERSON ON THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR. I DO APOLOGIZE
. ON THE PHONE WHEN YOU'RE IN A
POSITION OF S. B. NINE EIGHT
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE OF MEANT
THEY OFFER ANY OPPOSITION.
MISTER CAREY AT NOT FINISHING
CAN- GREAT OKAY WILL REMIX
COMMITTEE I MEAN MY MAIN CONCERN
THE BILL IS THIS. REALLY LONG
TITLE. THE C. C. P. R. J. C. P.
THE COULD COOK COOKER RECOVER
FROM. I HAVE SO ARE YOU YOU TO
STICK WITH THIS TITLE FOR THE
PROGRAM THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
REPAIRS RESILIENCY JOBS
COMMITTEES PROGRAM. WHERE ARE
ALSO BUT I DON'T REALLY CARE YOU
ARE H. BORDER I DON'T CARE RIGHT
NOW ANYWAY. IT'S VERY
DESTRUCTIVE THE DISTANCE
DESCRIPTIVE OKAY ANYWAY
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS COMMENTS YES-
CINEMA COUNTY. PHOMICINDA STERN
. SO YOU KNOW THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PUT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE TCC
PROGRAM OVER THREE YEARS
CORRECT- SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE HIS IF
IT BECAUSE HI I WILL I LIKE THE
IDEA THAT A SMALL COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COMPETE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND YOU HAVE A
FRIEND IN CENTER COVER HERO WITH
HER BILL ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. WHICH FOR A LOT. THE
GATORS TO THE NAVIGATORS- A
PROGRAM TO HELP HAVE THE OPR
HELP THESE ARE OF SMALLER CITIES
TO SMALLER CONSERVANCY IS WITH
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BUT
I'M I. FOR THE YELLOW SHIRTS
WALKING AROUND THE- THE- HOT
BUILDING TODAY AND I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND AS
YOU SO ELOQUENTLY STATED DEGREES
OF MAGNITUDE CORRECT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THAT I PULLED
OFF FROM THE AIRPORT AIRPORT
PROGRAM IF YOU SEE THAT WE ARE
THERE'S IN THE STAND WHEN WE
DID. SB THIRTY TWO AND WE SAID
THAT WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY.
TWENTY FORTY WE FROM TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY FORTY WE
HAVE TO REDUCE. EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS AS IS PAGE SIX OF
FOOD EXCELLENT STAFF ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT. ALL EIGHT OF THE
CURRENT TCC PROGRAMS
COLLECTIVELY IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS WILL REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND POUNDS. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED TONS. BY THE GREASE OF
COMPARISON WE'VE GOT LAST YEAR
WE PUT FORTY THREE MILLION INTO
THE PCC PROGRAM AND ART ACT OUR
ACTUAL CALCULATION WAS TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND FOR THE FOR THE
FIRST YEAR. A JURY DAY JESTER WE
PUT IN SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR DERRIDA GESTURES SO THAT'S
ABOUT A THIRD WE GOT ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CARBON RENEWAL IN. THEY INDICATE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WAS 78%
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE BY THE
SPIRIT DIGESTERS 78% OF THEM ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND PEOPLE DON'T
WE DON'T WE THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPOSITION TO THEM VERSUS 83% OF
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE IN THE- TCC PROGRAM SO
SEVENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE
COMPARE IT. COMPARISON BUT IF WE
COULD SPEND THE MONEY THE SAME
MONEY ON VERY TIGHT GESTURES
FORTY THREE MILLION AS WE DID ON
PCC'S WE WOULD HAVE FIVE MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON REDUCTION.
COMPARED TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
WITH THAT SAID I'M JUST I'M
DOING THAT FOR COMPARISONS
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO GET
EIGHTY UP ON REDUCING CARBON-
BUT WE HAVE THIS PROGRAM. AND
ITS COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS AND
SOME SMALLER FOLKS ARE NOT BEING
A- COMPLICATED. AS TO THE HAVE
NOTS SO. BUT LIKE WE GOTTA GET A
LOT OF BANG FOR OUR BUCK BUT
SINCE WE ALREADY GOT THE PUCK
OUT THERE ARE GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS OTHER
SMALLER ENTITIES TO COMPETE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS TO GET PERHAPS
MAYBE A LARGER BENEFITS THAN
WHAT WE'RE SEEING FROM THE EIGHT
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
NOTWITHSTANDING WHAT COIN IS
DOING TO BE UNIFIED THEIR THEIR
CITY BUT THAT'S THAT'S- I
THOUGHT IT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR CLIMATE LESSONS SO I TOOK
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND I MOVED THE
BILL- IT IS UNDERSTOOD. THAT'S
ALL I WAS GONNA DO IS MOVE THE
BILL COULD PLEASE LEGISLATION
NOT MY OWN MAYBE IN YOUR CLOTHES
YOU CAN DRESS BUT- HOW SMALL CAN
YOU GET WITH THESE LIKE- BECAUSE-I NOTICED IN THE DEFINITION OF.
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES COULD
EVEN BE A LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD.
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITY BUT
BILL. I JUST DON'T I I'M TRYING
TO THINK. OF THESE LITTLE
POCKETS OF AREAS LIKE IN LA
WE'VE CANOGA PARK RIGHT. LOST IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. HARD TO
ORGANIZE THEIR IT'S TOUGH. AND
BUT SO YOU KNOW THEY HAVE ALL
KINDS OF OPPORTUNITY BUT- I
DON'T LIKE HOW MUCH ORGANIZING
AS A COMMUNITY. HAVE TO DO TO
QUALIFY FOR ONE OF THESE IT
COULD JUST BE A- HOUSEHOLD
QUALIFYING INTERIORS. WHAT'S
YOUR WHAT'S YOUR VISION YEAH IN
THEORY SENATOR AD YES BUT I
THINK IN PRACTICE WILL PROBABLY
FIND IS PROJECTS THAT ARE
PROBABLY THE ONE TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE THAT. WOULD OKAY
YOU KNOW AND NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL
OF PROBABLY THE SMALLEST UNIT IF
THAT MAKES SENSE YEAH. IT DOES
OKAY THANKS. GREAT GUY CLOSER
QUICKLY. BUT YES BUT I WOULD
LIKE I MEAN I REPUBLICAN FRIENDS
OF ASKING ABOUT THE MONEY I MEAN
I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THERE'S
A BUDGET ASKS US HERE WITH THIS-
IF YOU COULD CLARIFY. AND JUST
REAL QUICKLY HI I LIKE THE GOAL
OF THE BILL BUT- TO HAVE JUST
YOU KNOW NO IDEA OF HOW MUCH
MONEY AND- TO SENATOR STERN'S
QUESTION HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
SMALLER COMMUNITIES CAN COMPETE.
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY BUT I DO
LIKE THE IDEA. OF THAT. GIVE
GOOD JOB. THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET I ASKED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TCC SO IS AS I READ THIS I
WITHOUT THAT THAT WOULD BE
FORTUNATE THAT. I HAVE FOR.
RIGHT WHAT WILL BE. ULTIMATELY
CITIES YOU SEE LIGHT. YEAH SO
LOOK I THINK THE ANSWER HERE'S
THIS. I MEAN I THINK WHAT YOU
KNOW AND I'VE BEEN HAMMERING THE
SAME POINT THE SENATE WOULD COST
YOU DID ALL OF OUR CLIMATE
GROUPS. YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GETS GET MONEY TO
REDUCE CAUGHT PEOPLE'S BILLS
LET'S HAVE MONEY TO DO THESE
OTHER THINGS AND IF OUR CLEAR
OBJECTIVE IS JUST TO REDUCE GHGS
I THINK WE SHOULD SPEND THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND ADJUSTERS
AND THEY SHOULDN'T BE A PLACE
WHERE WE COULD POSSIBLY PUT IT
DIGESTED SHOULDN'T BE THERE. NOT
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
THE GHGS BUT ALSO THE METHANE
THE SHORT TERM POLLUTANTS THE
IMPACT EIGHT WHAT EIGHTY TIMES
WHAT THE IMPACT IS OF CARBON
EXTRAORDINARY RIGHT IT IS A IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION
ABOUT. WHAT OUR OBJECTIVES ARE
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED WHERE WHERE WE TALKED
LAST ON THE FLOOR THAT WAS WILL
CONTROVERSIAL ABOUT THE IDEA OF
CLIMATE CHANGE VERSUS CLIMATE
CHANGED WE NOW FIFTEEN EXTREME
HEAT WE'RE NOW FACING IMPACTS ON
INDIVIDUALIZED COMMITTEES. THE
IDEA IT SEEMS TO ME IN TERMS OF
THE DEMOCRACY IS TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMMUNITIES
THAT CAN'T DON'T HAVE THE P. H.
D.'S IN AND A BUREAUCRACY TO GET
ACCESS TO FUNDS TO IMPROVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NOT REDUCE
EXCHANGES MUCH BUT MAYBE MAKE
THINGS MORE COMFORTABLE MAYBE
DEAL EXTREMELY MAYBE DO OTHER
THINGS. THAT IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF THE COMMITTEE BEING FORMED A
COMMUNITY IN A WAY THAT DEALS
WITH THIS CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE
TO YOU KNOW WHEN WE DID AB
THIRTY TWO BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX RIGHT HE WAS WITH DARIA FROM
ARE USED TO CALL THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER BILL NO ONE REALLY
BELIEVED IT NO ONE KNEW WHICH
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL. LOVE
ABOUT BLOOD SO WE JUST SAID FINE
LET'S JUST GIVE THIS ALL TO AN
AGENCY AND SEE WE CAN MOVE IN
THIS DIRECTION NOW WE'VE EVOLVED
INTO A MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT
DISCUSSION AROUND CLIMATE THE
IMPACT. AND GOING FOR. THE WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE. AND SO AS WE
ARE TO CREATE THE ARE. FRAMEWORK
IF YOU WILL. YOU KNOW YOU COURSE
CORRECT ALONG THE WAY. YOU LEARN
YOU GROW WE DO TEACH YOU SEE
THAT SOME INTERESTING IMPACTS.
YOU KNOW AND SO NOW WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS IT'S HARD. FOR
SMALLER GROUPS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS GLORIA BOARD THAT HAS TO GO
BECAUSE PROCESS THERE'S A CHECK
AND BALANCE OF ALL THE SYSTEMS.
IS NOT JUST WRITING CHECKS AS
THE WHOLE PROCESS YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OTHERWISE INSPIRED. THE IMPACT
THEIR LOCAL NEIGHBORHOODS TO
ALLOW THEM TO DO SO. AND I THINK
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
THAT REGARD NOW STRUGGLE. HI
THANKS FOR CALLING I THE NUMBER
THREE SB NINE EIGHT NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN ALLEN AYE BATES BATES NOT
VOTING TALLY. DALLY NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN ALL RIGHT
STERN I WHITE HOUSE LIKE
MAKOWSKI I. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE
SENATE CAREER YOU MAY PURCHASE
THE DYESS SB FOURTEEN TEN WE
WERE YEARS MUST BEEN BURNING WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT YOUR SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
CLAMPING DOWN ON. DANGEROUS
CRIMINAL- ILLEGAL GROWERS
UPSTREAM FROM SENATE DOLLIES
FARM AND HE'S VERY INTERESTED IN
GIVING HIS THOUGHTS ON THIS IS
WE CAN MAKE THAT BUILD STRONGER
AND BETTER SO AS TO ADDRESS THAT
ENORMOUSLY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUE WHICH I'VE I'M PROUD OF
COSTS OF YOUR BILL SENATE
KRIGING OTHERS TO DO THE SAME.
YEAH WITH THAT IN MIND LET'S GO
ON TO SB FOURTEEN TEN. AND YOU
MAY PURSUE IN RIGHT RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB FOURTEEN TEN TODAY
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THEIR WORK ON
THAT THIS COMPLEX ISSUE AND A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS IN THE BILL IT
WAS REALLY WELL DONE. AS YOU
KNOW IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SB SEVEN FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR STEINBERG THAT
BILL ESTABLISHED AS A TOOL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS UNDER SYKORA FOR
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO TO
STREAMLINE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION. OF THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER DOWNTOWN IN ADDITION THE
BILL ALSO TASK THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
FOR PR WITH THE TASK TO DEVELOP
NEW C. CORE GUIDELINES TO
REPLACE AREN'T QUITE YET USED.
TO MAKE. IMPAX WHICH MEASURED
THE LEVEL OF SO AT INNER.
IMPACTED BY THE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT. THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPMENT IMPOSSIBLE TO
MITIGATE AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
YOU FOUND IN THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER. HAD THEY USED THE- THAT-
MEASUREMENT OF LEVEL OF SERVICE
AT THAT POINT THERE JUST NO WAY
THAT YOU CAN INCREASE THE
CAPACITY OF THE STREETS. TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE TRANSPORTATION-
THROUGH GIVEN THE SIZE OF THAT
OF THE CONSTRUCTION. IN TWENTY
TWENTY- PURE DEVISED ANOTHER
METHODOLOGY TO SATISFY SECRET
FOR INFILL PROJECTS. IN TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREAS AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT TRANSIT PRIORITY
AREAS. AND THEY CALL THAT
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED- OR VMT.
BMT IS A MEASURE OF HOW MANY
VEHICLE TRIPS ARE GENERATED BY A
POP PROJECT. AND MUST NOW BE
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ANY NEW
DEVELOPMENT REGARDLESS OF WHERE
IT'S LOCATED. ROGERS WITH IBM T.
THE DEVELOPER MAY BE ASSESSED TO
BE EMPTY MITIGATION FEE OR BE
REQUIRED TO BUILD AMENITIES OR
DESIGN FEATURES. THAT REDUCE BE
EMPTY. AND THERE'S A GREAT LAST
IN- ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT TALKS ABOUT WHAT
THOSE. AMENITIES DESIGN FEATURES
OR- MITIGATION MEASURES ARE AND
I AND I AND I WANT YOU TO FOCUS
ON THAT BECAUSE- MY DISK. HERE
TODAY REALLY HAS TO DO WITH WHAT
WHAT THAT EXPANSION DID. TWO IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE LIST OF
MITIGATION OPPORTUNITIES THAT
YOU HAVE THEY THEY JUST DON'T
WORK IN RURAL CALIFORNIA- BUYER
TO SEND MY DISTRICT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE CITY OF SALINAS
IN THE CITY NOW THATIN THE NEW
DISTRICT THE CITY OF FRESNO.
THERE THERE IS VERY VERY LIMITED
TRANSIT OPPORTUNITIES- THAT YOU
CAN USE ON A REGULAR BASIS TO
GET TO WORK IN REALLY KEPT RURAL
CALIFORNIA YOU ABSOLUTELY DEPEND
ON THE VEHICLE. TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO WORK MANY PEOPLE TRAVEL.
MINIMUM THIRTY MILES TO GET TO A
FIELD OR- OR A PROCESSING
FACILITY AND IT NOW WITH THE NEW
INFLUX OF PEOPLE FROM. THE BIG
CITIES THAT MOSTLY SUBCONTRACTOR
IN THE BAY AREA THEY TRY. BROKEN
IT. AN HOUR AND A HALF SO TO
INCORPORATE NEIGHBORHOOD
ELECTRIC VEHICLE NETWORK OR-
ORIENT PROJECT. TRANSIT BICYCLE
AND PEDESTRIAN FACILITIES METHOD
THAT'S A JOKE YOU DON'T WANT TO
BE RIDING A BICYCLE OR SENDING
YOUR KIDS ACROSS THE STREET WHEN
YOU'VE GOT- PRODUCE TRUCKS AND-
BIG VEHICLES THAT ARE ARE MOVING
EQUIPMENT COMING THROUGH YOUR-
YOUR COMMIT COMMUNITY PROVIDE
BICYCLE PARKING IMPLEMENTED
PROVIDE ACCESS TO COMMUTE
REDUCTION PROGRAM. PROVIDE CAR
SHARING BIKE SHARING RIGHT
PROGRAMS DOES IT JUST DO NOT
WORK AND SO THE CHALLENGE
BECOMES AT. BAD IN MANY
COMMUNITIES- TO USE A V. M. T.
THAT WOULD THE THAT THAT THAT
METHODOLOGY WOULD REQUIRE THEM
TO IMPOSE SOME KIND OF A FEE AND
A FEE AS YOU KNOW STARTS TO
IMPACT. HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE AND IT PITS ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS AGAINST
OUR HOUSING INTERESTS AND
BECOMES MORE EXPENSIVE- TO BUILD
HOUSING THE HIGHLIGHT HOW
EXTREME IMPLEMENTING VM TEAM
MAYBE. SAN DIEGO COUNTY RECENTLY
PROPOSED A VMT MITIGATION FEE
RANGING FROM FIFTY FROM FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TWO MILLION
PER NEW HOMES FOR RECENT HOUSING
PROJECT. AND WHILE THIS SPACE
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION IT AND
HAS NOT YET BEEN APPROVED IT'S A
CLEAR EXAMPLE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF BE EMPTY AND
THAT'S IN SAN DIEGO WHERE THEY
HAVE- INTO IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE COMMUNITY A MORE ROBUST-
TRANSPORTATION PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT IN
MOST OF. OF OF CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR IN MY IN MY REGION.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS NOT
ONLY A SUPPLY ISSUE AND IT'S AN
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE AS A MEDIUM
HOME PRICE IN THE STATE
CONTINUES TO RISE MANY FAMILIES
ARE FORCED TO BUY OR RENT IN THE
SUBURBS OR IN RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE. TO FIND HOUSING THAT
THEIR BY. AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENING EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING MY DISTRICT AND PEOPLE
COMING. INTO MY NIELSEN
PATTERSON IN NEWMAN FROM THE BAY
AREA THEY'RE SUPER COMMUTERS.
THE DRUG OVER AN HOUR AN HOUR
AND A HALF TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
TO BUY A HOME. IN CALIFORNIA
MANY READ HAVE NO BUT TO COMMUTE
LONG. DUE TO THE LACK OR OR OF
OR RELY AND RELIABILITY OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT IN ORDER TO
COMMUTE TO THEIR JOBS OR TO RUN
ERRANDS ERRANDS. BMT WILL
DISCOURAGE THE MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN OUR STATE'S RURAL COUNTIES
AND CITIES WHICH IS WHY I'VE
AUTHORED THIS BILL TO LIMIT ITS
APPLICATION TO TRANSIT PRIORITY
AREAS WHICH WAS THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF SB SEVEN FORTY SIX.
AND RETURNED TO LEVELS OF
SERVICE OR ALTERNATIVE METHODS
TO MITIGATE AIR POLLUTION FOR
THOSE AREAS OUTSIDE OF THE
TRANSIT PRIORITY AREAS AND
FRANKLY- I'M- MIKE MY AT ONE OF
THE CO AUTHORS ON THIS BILL
SENATOR ROTH ONE OF THE REASON
HE IS SO SOLIDLY IN FAVOR OF
COMING UP WITH A SOLUTION. IS
WHAT THEY HAVE SEEN IN RIVERSIDE
IS. OF PEOPLE. IN THE LA AREA
WHO CAN WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO BUY THEIR OWN HOME AND
THEN GET OUT- IN IN RIVERSIDE
AND THE CONGESTION AND THE- THAT
DRIVING IS SO. DIFFICULT THAT
THEY- THEY THEN START TO
ORGANIZE AROUND. AT THAT IT
IMPACTING THE FREEWAY SYSTEMS
ARE EXPANDING THE FREEWAY
SYSTEMS- IN AND WHEN YOU REALLY
THINK ABOUT IT ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IS THAT
WERE IMPOSING THIS SYSTEM ON TOP
OF IN AN EQUAL DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE
AND SO WE WE'VE DONE IT IN A WAY
THAT ACTUALLY THAT PENALIZING
THE COMMUNITIES ARE BUILDING THE
HOUSING AND THAT PENALIZING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE POOR-
BECAUSE- PEOPLE MOVE THERE
BECAUSE THEY CAN AFFORD TO MOVE
THERE- AND IT STARTS PUSHING OUT
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY.
IN THE GUEST BOOK THAT ARE
MOVING IN ARE EARNING TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE THAN THE PEOPLE
WHO ORIGINALLY LIVED THERE AND
SO IT STARTS CREATING THESE
INEQUALITIES AND- THE CHALLENGES
SAID THEN PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
BUILD ANYMORE HOUSING BECAUSE IT
BECOMES IT STARTS IMPACTING
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEIR AND
THEIR COMMUTE SO. DO WE HAVE
HERE. WE FLARED OVER A SYSTEM
IN- IN OUR ATTEMPT TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES BUT WILL THE
COMMUNITIES IT REALLY SHOULD BE
PROVIDING A LOT MORE HOUSING-
AREN'T DOING IT AND PEOPLE ARE
STILL GOING TO COMMUTE LONG
DISTANCES SO NOT ONLY YOU THINK
IT'S GONNA COMMUTE LONG
DISTANCES BUT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PAY A LOT MORE MONEY FOR THE
HOUSING AND- AND OF COURSE AS I
SAID IT DRIVES UP THE- THE COST
OF HOUSING IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
SO THAT. LOCAL PEOPLE CAN AFFORD
IT EITHER SO- I THINK THAT THE
WHOLE POINT OF THIS IS THAT-
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS TO
BRING SOME LOGIC AND SOME-
CONSISTENCY IN THE STATE AROUND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO- PLAN TO
MITIGATE AIR QUALITY ISSUES
AROUND TRANSPORTATION AND DO IT
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T END UP
NEGATIVELY IMPACT US AGAIN I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH THE
CHAIR- ABOUT THIS- SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR
AND- ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT DUE
TO- I SUBMISSION ERROR. THAT
THE- THE ANALYSIS DOESN'T
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE FULLEST
OF SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. AND I
WANNA- HIGHLIGHT THAT THE BILL
HAS SUPPORT FROM GROUPS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA UNITED
CONTRACTORS CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF LABOUR'S BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION OPERATING
ENGINEERS JUST TO NAME A FEW- IT
RIVER SOME ERROR IN TERMS OF
SUBMITTING SUBMITTING THAT
INFORMATION SO- AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE CHAIR I'M IN
IT EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AT THIS TIME THERE
OUTLINED ON. PAGES ELEVEN AND
TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS IN WITH
THE CAVIAR- I DON'T LIKE STUDIES
IT'S USUALLY A WAITED TO SHELVE
SOMETHING AND NOT GET ANYTHING
DONE BUT I THINK THIS THERE'S A
REAL INTERSECTION HERE BETWEEN
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE HAVE TO GET
IT RIGHT AND SO- IT MAY BE THAT
THAT THERE'S A SOLUTION THAT WE
CAN COME TO IF WE GET ALL THE
GROUPS TOGETHER AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. WE KNOW SOMETHING
SHORT OF A STUDY BUT IT MAY BE
THAT THE STUDIES THE ONLY WAY TO
GET THAT INFORMATION I JUST
DON'T WANT TO SEND THIS BACK TO
THE SAME ENTITY THAT PREPARED.
THE IBM T. IN THE FIRST PLACE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GOING TO END UP WITH A DIFFERENT
RESULT AND I DON'T THINK THAT.
THAT THERE WAS ENOUGH OF AN
ANALYSIS OF OUR PRIORITY ON
BUILDING HOUSING AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
BUILD TWO POINT FIVE MILLION OR
THREE MILLION HOUSING UNITS- WE
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN THIS ISN'T
THIS ISN'T GOING TO GET US THERE
SO- I PUT I PUT. THE CHAIRS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ISSUE- AND-
I'M THANKFUL FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO WORK ON THE ISSUE FURTHER TO
CLARIFY WHAT ACTIONS WE SHOULD
TAKE. WE NEED. ALSO SALUTE. WILL
ACHIEVE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
AND NOT STYMIE THE NECESSARY
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THAT IS SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT THAT MY- MY A
GOOD FRIEND- FROM- SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE SUGGESTED AS WE STOP
GIVING TAX CREDITS TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT
BUILDING THE HOUSING BETTER
ADDRESSING THE JOBS- OR WE TAKE
ALL THAT TRANSIT DOLLARS AND WE
PUT HIM TO EXPAND TRANSIT TO.
RURAL AND SUBURBAN COMMUNITY SO
THAT WE CAN. HAVE PARITY IN
TERMS OF THE TRANSIT
OPPORTUNITIES. THOSE ARE ALL
POLICY CHANGES THAT ARE WAY
BEYOND KIND OF WHERE WHERE WE'RE
AT BUT IT IT JUST IT STARTS TO.
EXPLAIN WHY THIS ISSUE IS SO
DESPERATELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
NEED THAT WE NEED TO AMELIORATE
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE- WE'VE-
PRODUCED IN THE PAST AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO. CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMITTEE
COMMUNITIES TO BUILD HOUSING TO
GROW AND IT. OF THE NEEDS OF
THEIR CA. THIS WELL SO. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT- AND FOR YOUR IN
YOUR- WORK ON IT. MISTER CHAIR
AND WITH THAT I WILL- WE HAVE
SOME WITNESSES. FLASK WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS STEVE
CRUZ WHO'S HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WILL TESTIFY IN
PERSON IN MY QUICKLY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR JOB AND HE'LL
TESTIFY REMOTELY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STEVE CRUZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
THEIR CAREER THEY'RE WONDERFUL
JOB- IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM WITH
THE EXISTING V. M. T.
REGULATIONS AND- I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE-
HOW SERIOUS- THE CONSEQUENCES
HAVE BECOME IN TERMS OF AS YOU
SEE IN THESE. REGULATIONS PUT IN
PLACE. THEY ARE CREATING-
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS- TO
BUILDING. ENTRY LEVEL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- MULTI
HOUSING A MULTI UNIT PROJECTS-
AND I'D HAVE PASSED OUT A
GRAPHIC IF YOUR- IF THE IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO SEE IT IF NOT
I'LL JUST REFERENCE IT IS. THE
PHENOMENA AS YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE
IT IS THE DRIVE UNTIL YOU CAN
AFFORD INITIATIVE A GRAB BAG OF
SORRY YOU CAN GET IT BUT- JUST A
GRAPHICS IT DEMONSTRATING THAT
THE FURTHER YOU MOVE OUT FROM
THE JOB CENTERS HOUSE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE YOU'RE
PAYING. FOR HOUSING COSTS- AND
JUST DECIDE SOME OF THE NUMBERS
YOU MIGHT GET TO A DOLLARS A
SQUARE FOOT IF YOU'RE BUILDING
SOMEWHERE FURTHER OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY. OPERATE THE CENTER.
AND YOU MIGHT BE A HUNDRED. A
SQUARE FOOT SO. A HER THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
HOME AN INFILL PROJECT- CITY. IS
NOT AFFORDABLE AND SO WE WERE
LOW TAKING- HOUSING. OFF AND
SHELVING PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T COMPLY. AGAIN CENTER
COMMUNITY GREAT JOB OF
DESCRIBING THE- HOW THE VMT
METRIC WORKS AND HOW IT'S
APPLIED- I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE
THAT- ON THE ON THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT. WE I THINK
SEPTEMBER TWELFTH THAT LOCKS
NIGHT OF SESSION- IT WAS ABOUT
THE GOLDWASSER BILL THAT THAT
LANGUAGE WAS IN THERE TO GIVE A
PRICE AT THE READY. AND IT WAS
IN OUR PERSPECTIVE ALWAYS MEANT
FOR TRANSPORTATION PRIORITY
AREAS AND SO THIS BILL IS VERY
CONSISTENT WITH THAT- AND WHILE
THERE WAS A PROCESS THROUGH. TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS WE
PARTICIPATED HUNDREDS OF HOURS
IN THAT PROCESS. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT WASN'T A
CONSENSUS PRODUCT WRITERS LIKE
HERE HERE HERE HERE HERE THEY
ARE THAN OURS ARE DOING WITH
THOSE CONSEQUENCES. I ALSO WHAT
IT DECIDED. WE FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THIS BILL WORK WITH THE
CENTER THAT IT'S BRINGING
TOGETHER PRETTY DIVERSE
COALITION OF SUPPORT YOU KNOW
WITH- WITH BUILDERS WITH WITH
LABOR- WITH THE WITH THE MPO
ISN'T THERE'S A NUMBER OF NPOS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE HAVING.
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES WITH THIS
AND SOME AS YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR OWN DISTRICT- THAT THEY'RE
CREATING THESE INEQUITIES AND
HOUSING COST AND SOCIAL
INEQUITIES- WE JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT IN THE ANALYSIS-
BEFORE I. FINISH UP HERE IS
THAT- THERE IS A REFERENCE TO
THE COURT CASE- THE TWO HUNDRED
VERSUS OF THE ARTIFACT. TECH
CASES NOT BEEN DISMISSED BUT
THEY WERE ASKED TO- MAKE IT
AMENDMENTS SO IT'S STILL PENDING
AND I THINK THERE'S A HEARING ON
MAY TWENTY FIFTH- IN THE LAST
THREE AS YOU SAID- WE CAME WITH
THE BILL TODAY- WE THINK THAT'S-
A SOLUTIONS THAT THE ONLY
SOLUTION IS A CENTER ALLEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I KNOW WE HAD
A CHANCE TO SPEAK AS WELL- TO
GIVE THIS MORE CONSIDERATION. I
THINK WHEN YOU HEAR FROM OTHER
WITNESSES THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS REALLY NEEDS TO LOOK AT-
THERE ARE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU. THANK YOU THINK STEVE.
AYE MR QUICKLY WE SAYS YOU TO.
TRY TO GIVE A BRIEF- STEVE DID A
GREAT JOB AT THE TAKE UP SOME
TIME SO- IF WE- WILL TURN
UNANIMOUS A QUICKLY. THANK YOU I
WILL BE A- BIT WITH BRIEF HERE.
ARE MY QUICKLY IT IS ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR JOBS. WE ARE A LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP.
REPRESENTING TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED. YOU NEED TO TRUCKING
CONTRACTORS AND OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
TO. BUILD AND MAINTAIN OUR
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE. AND I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE. A COUPLE
OF POINTS- IMPORTANT TO THIS
DISCUSSION. ONE IS THAT THE
CURRENT. ANALYSIS OF. USING THE
EMPTY. INTO JUDGE FOR
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING IMPACTS.
BUT IT WAS REALLY OUTSIDE OF
THIS- WHILE WITH THE ORIGINAL
WAS NOT AS WAS POINTED OUT THIS
WAS. A MEASURE DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT INFILL TYPE
PROJECTS. THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH EXISTING TRANSIT CENTERS
AND NOW UNDER THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEING UNIFORMLY APPLIED.
ACROSS THE STATE AND IN AREAS
WHERE IT ACTUALLY MAKES NO
POLICY SENSE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF IN THIS SORT OF
THE ANTI ANALYSIS. IS THAT THE
EMISSIONS PROFILE AND REDUCTION
. THAT IS GOING TO BE. FROM THIS
SORT OF- ANALYSIS IS SO FAR
INCONSEQUENTIAL COMPARED TO WHAT
THIS OVERALL STATE OF GOALS ARE
IN TERMS OF. REDUCTION OF. THE
NINE IN ONE IN THE COMPARATIVES
AS A GLOBAL PROBLEM IT'S REALLY
INCONSEQUENTIAL AND THE REAL
IMPACTS OF THIS ARE GOING TO BE
INCREASINGLY AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IN THE STATE INCREASING
THE HOUSING CRISIS. HE WITHOUT
THIS BILL'S PASSAGE- YOU'RE
GONNA SHE INCREASED COSTS AND
MORE SEPARATION BETWEEN THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS IN THE
HOUSE ARE THE ONES WHO WERE IN.
URBAN AREAS THAT HAVE- YOU KNOW
MILLION DOLLAR APPRECIATING HOME
VALUES AND HAVE TRANSIT SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IS YOU'RE GOING
TO LIMIT THE ABILITY FOR ME.
WORKERS. TO SORT. ECONOMIC
ASSETS IN BY OPENER HOME YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE MORE P. ARE
GOING TO BE PUSHED INTO RENTING-
MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
HAVE. THE ABILITY TO RISE THE
MIDDLE CLASS. TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM BY THE SORT OF REGULATIONS
IN ORIGINALLY THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT RUSSIAN APPRECIATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY ALL
RIGHT WILL WILL ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. MISTER CHAIR SENATORS MET.
WITH A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE GROUP SUCH AS BOMA
CALIFORNIA NAPA CALIFORNIA AND
ICSE WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU- ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. THE MODERATOR.
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT WILL ALIGN
FOR NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AS CHAIR MEMBERS ADAMANTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE BEFORE THANK YOU FOR. AND WHAT A LINE FIVE HUNDRED
THIS BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS JAMES DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABOR'S
. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE
FOR TWENTY FOUR WEEKS BUT- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA AND
UNITED CONTRACTORSTHIS
AFTERNOON IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE FOUR
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON CARE ALLEN AND LINDY
HATCHER SPEAKING AND SUPPORT- SB
FOURTEEN TEN ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION THE HOME BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE CENTRAL COAST
AND WE SERVE RURAL AREAS WITHOUT
HIGH QUALITY I'M TRANSPORTATION
THE CURRENT FORMULA WOULD
INCREASE THE PRICE OF HOMES THAT
ARE FURTHER AWAY FROM JOB
CENTERS. AND PREDOMINATELY THOSE
THAT CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE WHERE
THEY WORK A. K. A. LOW INCOME
AND MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ARE THE
ONES LIVING IN THOSE- HOUSING
ELEMENT FOR THE JOBCENTRE. AND
WE'RE OFF PLEASE REPEAL HOUSING
ACT ON CAN LEAST AFFORD IT AND
NOT DEEP IN OUR WHITE AND THAT
CAT- WHERE FOR ME TO USE ONLY
I'M SO SORRY BUT- WHICH IS.
THANK YOU FOR STATION. HEY WE DO
HAVE A LOT FOR TWENTY ONE PLEASE
WHAT. THURMOND THREE MEMBERS
NATALIE OF CALIFORNIA ROUNDTABLE
AND COURT. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
FOR EIGHTY ONE PLEASE WHAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ALLEN VICE CHAIR
BATES THIS IS CONNOR MEDINA WITH
THE ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FIFTY FOUR HE SAID THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE FOR SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN
MEMBERS DAVE BUTLER ON BEHALF
THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK A COALITION OF LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE OR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
FIVE OH ONE THIS FIVE. THE BILL
MCGOVERN COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
OPPOSE. AND WE DO HAVE LINE FOR
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ROBERT
OFF A DOCTOR. FOUR THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO FOR
THE WIDELY QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY- SO LET'S GO OVER TO-
OPPOSITION FOLKS ONE OF WAS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL I'M
OBVIOUSLY IT'S BEEN HEAVILY
AMENDED BUT THERE IS. THERE
PLANS FOR IT VERY SERIOUS
DISCUSSION FORWARD- SO. AS
MATTHEW BAKER OR AND THEY WOULD
KNOW THE VERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME'S BETTY
BAKER POLICY DIRECTOR OF
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE-
SAY FOR THE RECORD THAT WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE TO THE
BILL AND PRINT- HI HEARING THAT
THAT THE SENATOR IS WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT-
I'LL SPARE YOU. POTS AND TO SAY
ON THAT POINT- AND ADDS A ALSO
THAT- RECEIVE NEWS CENTER CENTER
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE WORK ON THE I'M
THINKING THROUGH THIS BILL AND
WHATNOT ACTUALLY AND WE ASK YOU
TO SHARE SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS
MAYBE NOT ALL OF THEM BUT SOME
CUT. MS OF OUR- WITH WORK. WE'RE
ALL GETTING PUTTING WITH YOU THE
CENTER STAFF AND SENATOR US-
WHOEVER AUSTIN THE COMMITTEE WAS
RESERVE BATES YOU KNOW AND THE
AND THE PROPONENTS SO WE CAN
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW WITH PASSED
HORS D'OEUVRES TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED WHILE
UNDERMINING. THE COR. THE THAT
THAT THOSE OF US WHO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PER IN IT ARE THERE
BAKED INTO THE VMT METRIC I. YOU
KNOW WILL MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
THOSE ARE JEOPARDIZED SO IT
WOULD BE GOOD FOR YOU TO
OUTLINED SOME OF YOUR YOUR YOUR
BROAD BASED CONCERNS WITH. IT
WAS A- ALL. THREE YOU KNOW WE
ARE A STRONG SUPPORTER OF SEVEN
FORTY THREE ARE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN ITS DEVELOPING
IMPLEMENTATION WE BELIEVE THAT
SEVEN FORTY THREE MAKE. THE KIND
OF HOUSING WE NEED IN PLACES
THAT WE NEEDED EASIER HOW WE
THINK OF THE APPROACH THE
REGIONAL APPROACH OF SB FOURTEEN
TEN WOULD HAVE ONLY MADE THE PRO
EASIER AND KIND OF HOUSING WE
DIDN'T PLACE WE NEED. IT HARDER-
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT. THEN FORTY
THREE AS ONE OF THE STRONGEST
POLICY TOOLS WE HAVE IN MEETING
OUR CLIMATE EQUITY GOES IN THE
BELIEF THAT. THE OVERWHELMING
ECONOMIC BENEFIT INCLUDING IN
THE INTEREST OF ECHO HOUSING
WILL BE WILL BE IT. WILL BE
GREAT THE STATE AND THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE. IF ALLOWED TO PUT
OUT IN THE LONG TERM TO BE. THE
BENEFIT FOR FORT WORTH ANY
IMMEDIATE NEAR TERM IMPACT FEES
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THIS
TRANSITION PERIOD TRYING TO JUST
IMPLEMENTATION WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT'S A TRANSFORMATIVE LAW.
AND THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTATION AND
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WORKING
ON AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT CAN BE
WORKED OUT. AT SPEAKING. FOR
MYSELF FOR PC ALONE ENOUGH FOR
THE ENTIRETY OF THE COALITION-
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT BECAUSE
IT'S NEW BECAUSE THERE ARE
CHALLENGES BECAUSE THERE'S A
STILL A LOT MORE WORK TO DO TO
ESTABLISH. MEDICATION PRAYER.
ISN'T BEST PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS- YOU KNOW WE THINK
THAT A- HAVING STUDIES
REASONABLE AND WE THINK THAT THE
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAM COULD BE
VERY USEFUL ESPECIALLY FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT. THAT LACK
THE MODELING CAPABILITY TO DO
THAT KIND OF THE ANTI ANALYSIS
AND REDUCTION STRATEGIES THAT
THEY COULD BE DOING WITH A
LITTLE ASSISTANCE- I'M NOT
STATING A POSITION ON ON THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT UNTIL YOU
KNOW WILL REFRAIN ON THAT UNTIL
WE SEE- THE LANGUAGE AND I THINK
THAT THE DEFINITION OF THIS D.
A. N. AND THE- THE GRANT AND
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
THAT THE OTHER MANY RACIAL. BUT
BEING FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW WE
WONDER IF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS
REALLY LONG ENOUGH REVIEW PERIOD
TO REALLY THE SEVEN FORTY TO
PLAY OUT ON THE GROUND AND-
AFFECTS WE WONDER IF THAT REVIEW
PERIOD SHOULD BE LONGER- OKAY
THE INTERNET EVERY FIVE YEARS
BUT- I REFRAIN FROM THE REST OF
MY THOUGHTS ON THAT BUT- I WILL.
THANK WITH SENATOR AND COMMITTEE
AND- WE WELCOME THE AMENDMENTS
AND LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE AND
WE HOPE THAT THE CENTER WILL
WORK WITH THAT- IN TRYING TO
SHAPE. THIS GOING FORWARD SO
THANK YOU YEAH BUT IN FACT THE
CAN MEET THE CENTER HAS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU-
IN IN IN PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS.
THAT WE HAVE OUT THIS MORNING.
SO I'VE WHAT YOU STICK AROUND
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE A
DISCUSSION- AND- IT. DAVID MCKAY
VERO IS YOU'RE ALL SET UP TO
RAISE A COUPLE AND CONCERNS. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS-
WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
DEDICATED TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES BUSINESS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BY LOCATING
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PLACES WHERE
IT SUPPORTS QUALITY OF LIFE. OUR
BUSINESS OF OUR ADVOCACY AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REDUCTIONS IN
COST CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE AN EXEMPLARY JOB OF
REDUCING BARRIERS TO INFILL
DEVELOPMENT IN LAST SEVERAL
SESSIONS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT OUR JOB IN THE INFILL
INDUSTRY HAS BECOME. EASIER AS A
RESULT. THE VM THREE T. V. M. T.
TOOL IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPLEMENT
TO THOSE DEVICES. BY
DISCOURAGING SPRAWLING TO BE
CLEAR THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
BILL WAS NOT JUST GREENHOUSE
GASES IT WAS TO HELP FACILITATE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CORRECT
PLACES NOT THE WRONG PLACES
RIGHT IT ENCOURAGES REINVESTMENT
IN AREAS WITH GREAT NEED TO ALL
OF YOU PROBABLY HAVE JUST AREAS
LIKE THAT. IT IS THE CAR THE CAR
TURNER CHIPPED THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN CAR COST TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S EQUAL TO ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS HOUSE. AND IT
MAKES HER SAFER IT LOWERS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE COSTS
FOR GOVERNMENT INSPECTORATE SAID
PROF. WE NEED ONLY LOOK AT
PORTLAND FOR THE POSITIVE
HEALTHY IMPLICATIONS OF SPRAWL
CONTROL THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
NOW IS DOMINANTLY INFILL
DEVELOPMENT 70% OF WHAT HAPPENS
IN PORTLAND IS INFILL THEIR V.
M. T. HASN'T BEEN REDUCED BY IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS NATALIE AND
REGULARLY THEY'RE ON PROGRESS TO
BECOME A COMMUNITY THAT
ACTUALLY- PARTICIPATES IN THE
CLIFF SOLUTIONS TO GLOBAL
WARMING. THIS IS AN UNFORTUNATE
BELL- I SIT ON A CALTRANS
COMMITTEE WITH C. B. I. A. R.
THERE IS INTENDED TO IMPLEMENT-
THE V. M. T. PROCESS I'M EVEN
TALKING FRUITFULLY ABOUT DEALING
WITH LOS BECAUSE LOS IS
DEFINITELY A BARRIER TO GOOD
DEVELOPMENT. AND THAT'S ACOSTA
SHOULD FIGURE OUT HOW TO REDUCE-
I WANT TO SAY TO THE SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COOPERATION WITH WITH THE CHAIR
STAFF- AND WE AND WE AYE WE
OPPOSE THE BILL- WEENCOURAGE
CAN SCAN CAN YOU DIALOGUE
BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE THERE'S
IMPLICATIONS THAT ARE WORTH
DISCUSSING. THANK YOU THE- AND-
FOLKS YOU. THIRTY RECOGNIZE OUT
OF THE I WANT TO CALL AND WE
WILL HAVE. YOU KNOW THAT THE
BILLS IN A VERY DIFFERENT PLACE
THAN THAN IT WAS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN IT WITH IMMENSE IS
ACCEPTED BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ABOUT CONTINUING THIS DIALOGUE-
SO AS TO SEE. WHAT WE CAN.
RECONCILE THE VARIOUS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
EXPRESSED- SO IT'S IN THAT
SPIRIT THAT- READ ANYONE EXPRESS
YOUR CONCERNS AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES TO. THANK YOU
TERENCE DETER READ OUT OF SOME
BEHALF AND NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION FIND. IN
OPPOSITION BUT ALSO WHEN I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO WATCH THIS
CONVERSATION AS WELL SO. VERY
HAPPY WORK WITH COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE ARE GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU THINK YOU READ THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR- YES. I HAVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO FOR THE
SPEAKER. WE HAVE LINED. FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN WISPA HAS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG AND YOU SACRAMENTO
PROPOSED TO THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED AT AMERICAN
CIVIL CONVERSATIONAL STAKEHOLDER
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS AS WE REPORT. AND WE DO HAVE LINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLUS WHAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
PRINT THAT LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DIALOGUE. AND WE HAVE LINE
BEFORE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NORTHERN IRELAND
CALIFORNIAN BERMAN OF THE FAMILY
OPPOSED THE BILL AND PRINT ONE
ALIGNER COMMENTS WITH THOSE FROM
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE DETAILS
OF THE CHANGES. THANK YOUNG.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU'RE
TELLING ME YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES PROGRESS
REPORT PLEDGES ARE BEING LIKE.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE. LINE FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON
FOR CIVIC WELL I AM SPEAKING AS
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR MANAGER FOR
SB SEVEN FORTY THREE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN PRINT BUT
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WITH WITH THE
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
IN THE SENATORS WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
FOUR OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS NICK RADO ON BEHALF
OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
ORIGINAL PRINT TO THE BILL BUT-
BUT ALONG THE LINES OF MATT
BECAUSE COMMENTS- LOOKING
FORWARD TO FURTHER DIALOGUE AND
WE NOW HAVE LINE FOR EIGHTY NINE
THIS BY THE- YES WILL BRING HER
FOR THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IN PRINT. AND WE DO HAVE A LINE FOR
EIGHTY SIX PLUS FIVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA ROSENBERGER HAIDAR
SHREDS NOW. NUMBER POST TO IT
BRIGHT PINK SHOP LOCATIONS WILL
CHANGE TO A- THE WHOLE LIFESTYLE
GOING TO CHANGE. AND WITH THAT
THERE ARE NO FOR THE WINDING HE
WITH THE STAFF ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH EVERYBODY
FOR PARTICIPATING HI LET'S BRING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS- SENATE. FIRST
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
BILL FORWARD I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT SIMILAR TO YOURS. AND I
JUST WANT TO BRING TO THE
ATTENTION OF YOU KNOW. THE
OPPOSITION I'M I'M A FORMER. WE
DON'T FUND WILLIAMSON ACT IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
PRESERVATION TO HELP OPEN
SPACING KEEP FERTILE GROUNDS
RIGHT HERE YOU DRIVE OUT I FIVE
AND I HAVE TO GO HOME THAT WAY
AND WE'RE PAVING OVER AND
BUILDING HOMES ON. THIS FARM
GROUND WORLD. THAT'S NUMBER ONE
. NUMBER TWO WE NEED HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS A VERY
LARGE STATE AND IS VERY HAS
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHY HAS
DIFFERENT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS YOU CAN THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL THIS IS THE COMES OUT HERE
DOESN'T WORK. IN ALL PLACES AND
- IT WORKED REALLY WELL I VOTED
FOR ALL THOSE INFILL BILLS I
AGREE WE NEED INFILL AYE I. HAVE
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES ABOUT.
GOING BY THE HOSTESS FACTORY
RIGHT HERE ON FIFTY. THERE'S A
PERFECT PLACE TO PUT IN HOMES.
YOU HAVE LIGHT RAIL YOU HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND YOU HAVE A-
HAVE A BROWNFIELD ALL IN THE
SAME PLACE WHERE WE SHOULD AND
WE HAVE JOBS RIGHT HERE IN THIS
TOWN. I MEAN HOUSING. IT OFFERS
IN MY- I WILL THAT. THERE'S ALL
. FOR THE BILL TO LOOK AT
RESIDENTIAL. THAT DOESN'T MEET
ALL THESE CRITERIA THAT WE'VE
PUT ON IT STARTED BACK WITH SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WAY BACK IN
THE DAY WHEN WE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT BUILDING THESE AND LET I
CAME AT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHERE. I DID SUBDIVISIONS. AND
THE WARS OF THOSE I'M GLAD I
DON'T HAVE TO SEE. AT THE AT
THIS LEVEL OF MY JOB. BUT THE
PERFECT PLANNERS OF THE WORLD
WILL TELL YOU. THAT WE NEED TO
PUT ALL THESE PEOPLE IN IN A-
CONDENSED AREAS SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT THE PEOPLE
REALLY DON'T WANT THAT ONE A
LITTLE PIECE OF AMERICAN WANT
PEACE OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE LITTLE
TO SPACE IT'S REALLY WHAT THEY
WANT BUT WE'RE WE'RE SHOVING
THOSE BOXES SO. AND WE'VE AND
WE'RE DOING THAT WE HAVE CREATED
. A VERY WEALTHY BUNCH OF PEOPLE
THAT GET WHAT THEY WANT AND A
VERY BUNCH OF A BUNCH OF POOR
PEOPLE THAT CAN'T GET. WHAT THEY
WANT THEY THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
GET STUCK. SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY- LONG WAY IS A KEY. FOR TO
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
WORK IN. AND GIVE THE SERVICE
IT'S ALL THOSE RICH PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT REALLY IS PLACE AND
I'VE BEEN TRAVELING THE STATE
RECENTLY AND I SEE IT EVERYWHERE
THE PEOPLE THAT PROVIDE THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY TO THE WEALTHY.
DON'T LIVE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND I HAVE. THE PLACE LAKE TAHOE
. THIS IS NOT IN IT NOT IN A
VERY POPULAR JERRY BUT THE
BILLIONAIRES ARE KICKING OUT THE
MILLIONAIRES AND THE PEOPLE THAT
WANNA. THIS IS TRUE THIS IS THE
FACT. AND YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS IN THOSE AREAS
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
SERVE YOUR FOOD AND CLEAN HOTEL
ROOMS IN THE SUCH WHEN YOU VISIT
MY DISTRICT DON'T LIVE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE MUSIC IN RENO
NEVADA. AND THEY TRAVEL TO TAHOE
TO SERVE. THE WEALTHY PEOPLE FOR
SAM'S IS GOING TO HAVE THEIR
SECOND THIRD HOMES THERE. THAT'S
A FACT. SO THERE'S A LOT TO BE
SAID ABOUT YOUR BILL I. I AM
AMID THE STEPS YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
AS A LEGISLATOR IT IS AWESOME
THAT YOU'RE TO BRING. TO THE
TABLE AB SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I COMMEND YOU FOR
THAT I'M ONE OF SUPPORT YOUR
BILL OBVIOUS TODAY. BUT KEEP IN
MIND ALL OF THE- WE'RE DRIVING
HARDWORKING PEOPLE OUT A COMPANY
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE HERE BECAUSE
THE MEDIAN INCOME FOR HOMES LIKE
. SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS IS
INSANE SO I THINK WE NEED TO
COMPROMISE I THINK WE NEED TO
REALIZE THAT CALIFORNIA ARE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL WE SHOULD BE DOING
INFILL WHERE SPORT MAKES SENSE
BUT WE SHOULD ALLOW THEM SO
GREAT FOR THE IT IS THAT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE SENATOR ALSO
. NAGA BE. UNDER T. I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HELP I THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK AT. FINDING THINGS LIKE THE
WHIMS. IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. AFTER THE DEBATE YEAH
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD ARE
SENATOR CAFIERO AND I AM GOING
TO SUPPORT IT BUT I JUST MAY
HAVE TO MAKE ONE OF THE TORIO
COMMENTS SO YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS AND- THERE'S A- OVER.
THEIR VM. INCREASES ARE. WHEN
THE CBI. THAT BILLS AND
FINANCES. THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TELL. THAT THAT
PARTICULAR REQUIREMENT FOR YEP.
E. R. B. M. T. OF MITIGATION
RAISES THE COST OF A HOUSE WE
NEED TO LISTEN THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE FINANCING IT THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE BUILDING AT
ONE THIRTY IN THE PEOPLE FOR.
TRACTORS IT ALL IN A CAR ARE SO
I IT WOULD BE I THINK I WOULD
PERSONALLY APPRECIATE WE HAVE
THESE DEBATES THAT A FAIR
REPRESENTATION OF TWO DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ON THINGS LIKE THIS-
ADEQUATELY. PRESENTED IN OUR
ANALYSES HAPPENED TO ME THIS
MORNING ON ANOTHER BILL YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA DEBATE INFORMATION
THAT DON'T WANT. I DON'T LIKE TO
. REPORTER RUSSIA AND I TO GIVE
EQUAL OF WAIT WHEN I READ THAT
BUT WHEN I READ SOME OF THESE IN
OUR THESE ARE COMING OF CA. M.
PRICE BECAUSE- TACTIC BEEN
INVOLVED IN BUSINESS FOR THIRTY
FORTY YEARS AND NO BOTTOM LINE
WHAT RAISES THE COST OF HOUSING
NOT JUST IN THE STATE BUT IN THE
NATION IN FRONT NEEDS TO A- TO
THE- THERE THEN. ALL WE- TO BUY
A PARTICULAR POSITION WE HAVE I
SUPPORT YOUR THANK. ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. AND I THINK SENATE
DOLLY. DID HI I'M. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK THAT THE TURKEY MEAT- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY- THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE COST OF HOUSING RIGHT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT. SPRAWL IN THE
COSTUME ARCHER AND SOME WOULD
ARGUE THAT THAT VERY PHENOMENON
THAT- THAT SENATE ALI WAS
MENTIONING- INVOLVING. HAVING TO
DRIVE IN FROM LONG DISTANCES TO
COME WORK IS. REYES IS ACTUALLY
PARTLY WHAT THIS THEY WERE THE
ORIGINAL SCHEME OF THREE SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FOUR THREE ARE TRYING
TO AVOID RIGHT WE DO WE DO WE
REALLY WELL KNOWN COURAGE FOR
MORE THE SUPER MEETING THAT YOU.
THAT APPLE BY THAT STATE GOT OF
OUR FREEWAYS AND- IT POLLUTE OUR
AIR AND CRISP THAT PORCELAIN
PEOPLE SPEND SO MUCH TIME BEHIND
THE ROLE IN THE CITY WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. SO ANYWAY. THEY'RE
GONNA BE GREAT DISCUSSION I LOOK
FOR TO AYE AYE I THINK YOU FOR
DISCUSSIONS MORNING AYE AYES I
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
THE MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION. AND A
HALF. WITH A PARTITION THE
AMOUNT COMMUNITY IN YOUR
SPONSORS. WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS
GOES- AND I THINK YOU FOR YOU
CERTAINLY PRODUCT IMPORT ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO. TAKE IN WELL
THE AND GRAPPLE WITH. ARE WHILE
ALSO STILL. MAINTAINING THE
SPIRIT AND INTENT OF. THAT I
THINK THAT I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF IT WITH IT WITH SB SEVEN
FORTY THREE- AND SO WITHOUT A
CLEANING. YES. OKAY WE'LL CENTER
BATES IS MOVING BILL. AND- AND
WILL WILL- BECAUSE WHAT WILL LET
YOU CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO TESTIFIED IN AND
HAS A- AN OPINION ON IT- I'M
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED INFILL IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I'M STILL
WORKING SO HARD ON SB SIX IT'S
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY. I'M
WAITING TO BE HEARD INCOME WHICH
WOULD ALLOW US TO CREATE PRETTY
CLOSE TO TWO TO THREE MILLION
HOUSING UNITS USE IT AND- I KNEW
THAT OR UNDER UTILIZED
COMMERCIAL AND RETAIL- PROPERTY
THAT'S LOCATED IN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT THIS
REALLY- THIS REALLY AFFECTS THE
WAY BEYOND THAT- AND ANNA IT
OCCURRED TO ME AS I'M I'M
LISTENING TO PEOPLE SPEAK THAT.
YOU KNOW PART OF THE CHALLENGES
IS YOU MAY NEVER VISIT ANY OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DESPERATE FOR HOUSING. ARE VERY
POOR LOCATED RURAL CALIFORNIA
WHERE. THERE ARE VERY LITTLE IT
BY THE IN THE WAY OF SERVICES
BOTH BOTH IN TERMS OF- GROCERY
STORES AND PHARMACIES IN THE
KINDS OF AMENITY. ONE EIGHT
COMMUNITY THEY- THEN YOU. BUT
EVERYTHING THERE SO THAT YOU
FIND- AND SO MAYBE WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS ORGANIZE A TRIP
COMMANDO TO AND A FIRE BINDER
HERE ON INTO- CHOWCHILLA SO
PEOPLE COULD SEE- THAT THE- AND
TALK TO THE ELECTED OFFICIALS SO
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE. SENATOR YOUR CALL
IT'S ABOUT- LISTENING TO A BROAD
GROUP- ARRAY OF PEOPLE THAT THE
FIRST. JEWELS THAT BROUGHT THE
IS. IT'S BECAUSE HE SAID WE WANT
TO BUILD WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CHANGE OUR- OUR METHODOLOGY AND
THIS IS REALLY HARD ON OUR
COMMUNITY SINCE I STARTED ASKING
WHAT IS THE COST SAN DIEGO CAME
OUT WITH THAT THE COST FIRST AND
YOUR FIRST KNOWS WORKING ON
THEIRS RIGHT NOW WE SPEAK AND
THERE'S A COST TO CHANGING THE
METHODOLOGY- BUT THE REAL ISSUE
IS IT IT IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
BIG A BIG IMPACT ON THE SMALLER
COMMUNITY THAT BETTER LOOKING
FOR HOUSING AND HAVE THE
CAPABILITY. FOR YOU CAN STILL
BUY AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES- AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT AND- WE STUCK WITH THE
ORIGINAL TENT OF THE OF A BILL
WHICH WOULD CEASE IT SAID AREAS
- YEAH WE EXPECT IT TO S. T. HI
TRANSIT AUTHORITY AREAS AT. I
POINT. THE WENT IT ALL CENTER
BECAUSE ABSOLUTE RIGHT JUST
DOESN'T IT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND THE SWEET SPOT I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR- HIS HIS HIS COMMENTS
AND- INTEREST IN WORKING WITH ME
GETTING GROUPS TOGETHER TO
FIGURE THIS OUT BECAUSE I THINK
THEY'RE THERE IS A NEED FOR US
TO LOOK AT THIS AND IF IT IS. IT
WAS ONLY IF DOING VMT MEANT THAT
OTHER COMMUNITIES WOULDN'T SEND
THEIR RESIDENTS. TO OUR TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE CAN BUILD FOR
OUR OWN. I'D BE FAT DUMB AND
HAPPY I MEAN I JUST BE HAPPY THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WHEN WE BUILD
HOUSING- IT ATTRACTS PEOPLE TO
COME FROM AREAS THAT WERE THERE
NOT BUILDING HOUSING RIGHT AND
SO. I YOU KNOW I'M I'M I
STRUGGLE BECAUSE- I REALLY DO
WANT. THESE COMMUNITIES. TO GROW
BECAUSE WHEN AFTER TALKED TO THE
RETAILERS THEY SAY WERE WILLING
TO GO IN BUT THEY NEED MORE
HOUSING YOU HAVE TO HAVE MORE
PEOPLE LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
US TO BE THERE. AND- AND SO IS
THE CHICKEN AND EGG THING HOW DO
WE GET THERE HOW DO WE- HOW DO
WE REALLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES BUT WE DO IT IN A WAY
WHERE PEOPLE WERE COMMUNITIES
ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING HOUSING
FOR THE JOB. CREATING AND THAT
THAT GOES BEYOND THIS BILL BUT
SOMEHOW WE NEED TO TALK. TO GET
. NOW THERE. ON THAT THAT. I
THAT I BELIEVE THE TESTIMONY
WHEN THEY SAY IT THE BE. THE
IMPACT ON GREENHOUSE GASES IS
GOING TO BE MINUSCULE. IN
COMPARISON TO THE COST- CAN
BUILD A HOUSE IN THAT. COST THEN
GETS TRANSLATED INTO THE
INABILITY OF PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
BE TO LIVE THERE SO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS- AND
- I LOOK FORWARD TO COMING UP
WITH A SOLUTION THAT. THAT
HOPEFULLY REALLY MANAGES. WHAT I
THINK RIGHT NOW IS A REALLY
TOUGH SITUATION. OKAY FOR THE
MOTION AS DEEP AS AMENDED YES
WITH LOTS MORE WORK TO BE DONE-
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
ON BOTH SIDES LET'S SEE WE CAN
SEE WE CAN WAS HE WAS SORT OF
PROGRESS WE CAN MAKE HERE-
PLEASE. CALL SURE THE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FOURTEEN TEN BY
SENATOR COVER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ALAN
HI ALAN ALL RIGHT BATES BATES
ALL RIGHT ALI AND ALI I CAN
SALAS SKINNER STERN STERN
HIGHWAY CAL SKI MY COUNTY I.
OKAY THAT'S FIVE VOTES- ALL
RIGHT LET'S HAVE US THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATE CAREER. J. WILL I
SEE SO HERE. COME ON UPSET
ALERTS GOING TO PRESENT ITEMS
SEVEN- I NOW I KNOW NOTHING BUT
- THE BILL HAS HE. ALL DELIVER
ARE YOU SET MISTER CHAIR YES YES
SIR THANK YOU OF. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON THIS
BILL AND THE EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE HAD I AM
TAKING THE AMENDMENT ON THE
FILING NOTICE. THERE TO OTHER
ITEMS. CYST THAT I'VE COMMITTED
TO CAN YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON
WITH THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
STAFF THOSE ITEMS INCLUDE
WORKING ON ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT OUTLINES THE OVERSIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTS WHEN A
NOTICE OF EXEMPTION. AND ANNA WE
IS FILED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS CULTIVATION ACTIVITIES
AND HOW TO ENSURE. VITAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OCCURS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. YEAH I MEAN
PIZZA THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT SENATOR- ONCE
AGAIN GOOD PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS THIS WEEK- I WANT
TO- YOU KNOW BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH MY
STAFF AND WITH ME ON THIS IS A-
TEST. WE POINT IS THERE IS THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS.
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO WORK WITH
WITH YOU ON ON ON THE ON THESE
COMPONENTS SO PROJECTS THAT I
FEEL LIKE. WE HAD A PATH WE
JUST. DIDN'T HAVE A PATH THAT
WOULD GET US LANGUAGE BY TODAY
RIGHT. I THINK WAS GOOD. THIS IS
KID FISCAL. AND GOES THERE SO
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE TO DEAL WITH
THAT. YEP WHAT ARE THIS BILL
AIMS TO STREET IN THE REAR VIEW
AND APPROVAL OF ANNUAL CANNABIS
LICENSES AND- AND TO MAYBE
SYNTHESIZE IT. A RIGHT NOW A
PROJECT. WE ARE ON THE LICENSE
PROJECT IS REQUIRED TO DO SECRET
TWICE FOR THE SAME PROCESS AND
THE OAL OF THIS BILL. IS TO GET
IT TO ONE. AND WE ARE FACING-
THE SITUATION IN THE STATE.
WHERE ARE WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE A
REGULATED SYSTEM WORK AND WHEN I
WAS SECRETARY OF RESOURCES. WE
WERE DEALING AND IT IS NOT. OUR
FOR MR DOLLARS DISH BUT THERE
WAS ONE PARTICULAR. A GREGIS.
ARE A BLAST OF STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT INVOLVED A MASSIVE
DIVERSION OF WATER AND I KNOW
SENATOR CAFIERO HAD A BILL ON ON
DIVERSION OF WTER YESTERDAY
WHEN WE WERE. ON THE SUIT IT
MORE SKETCHY PAST. INVOLVE
PEOPLE BEING ARM. OUR OF AND THE
REAL IDEA IS IF THIS IS GOING TO
EXIST IT'S GOING TO EXIST IN A
LEGAL FRAMEWORK AND NOW WE'VE
DESIGNED A LEGAL FRAMEWORK. THAT
IS REALLY HARD TO NAVIGATE AND
IT SUCH THAT LAST YEAR IN THE
BUDGET A WE DID A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SISTANCE IN
THE CANNABIS LICENSE AND PROCESS
BUT WE DID A HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REMEDIATION OF THE BAD STUFF
AND- IT'S OF LIKE OUR- HASN'T
BEEN. HIT IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND WE ARE MAKING IT HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO EXIST IN THE WEEKLY
MARKET. AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO THE APPROVAL
PROCESS INVOLVES COMPLYING WITH
SEEK WELL WHETHER RESULTS IN
APPLYING FOR AN AVAILABLE
EXEMPTION OR PREPARING THEM
WROTE MORE ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEWS SUCH AS A NEGATIVE
DECLARATION OR AN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT WHEN THAT LOCAL
PROCESS IS COMPLETED AND THE
APPLICANT APPLIES FOR STATE
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS LICENSE THE
STATE MUST COMPLY WITH SEQUEL.
EVEN THOUGH FOR THE PURPOSE. OF
THIS SEQUEL REVIEW THIS FOR THE
PROJECT IS THE SAME AS IT WAS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. OF THE
DEPARTMENT CAN RELY ON A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS COMPLETED
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW BUT MUST
UTILIZE ITS OWN INDEPENDENT
JUDGMENT A PROCESS WHICH CAN
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL. TO RE. SO
DATA FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. OF THE STATE DESIGN.
APPLICANTS IT WIGGLE COMPLIANCE
BY UPCOMING DEADLINES IN THIS
BILL SURE SIX WE'RE VIEW IS
STREAMLINED. AND COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS LICENSES MAY BE ISSUED
BY THE STATUTORY DEADLINE DIEM.
IS HE WILL NOT BE DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ONCE AND WHAT WE ARE
WORKING OUT IN THE- IS MAKING
SURE THE LOWER LEVEL. IS DONE IN
AN APPROPRIATE WAY THAT IT TRULY
DOES MEET WHAT WHAT OUR- NEED AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND WITH THAT-
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
KAREN WOODS AND THE DIRECTOR OF
COMPLIANCE LICENSING AT KIVA AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT
. THANK YOU SENATE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO YOU KAREN ON THE
PHONE LINES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ALAN BY SURVEYS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF MY
NAME IS KAREN WATSON AND ON
BEHALF OF CUBA IT IS A PLEASURE
TO TESTIFIED TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY SEVEN
EARLIER. WHICH STREAMLINES THE
PEOPLE CAN PROCESS THE NECESSARY
TO OBTAIN AN ANNUAL CAMPUS
LICENSE ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL. HE WAS
FOUNDED IN TWENTY TEN AND IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST OPERATORS IN THE
STATE. BUT LIKE SO MANY OTHER
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ARE
DISTRIBUTION LICENSES REMAIN AND
PROVISIONAL THAT. AND WHAT THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE OFFERS AND
THE ABILITY TO OPERATE IT
PROVIDES NO VESTED RIGHT OR DO
YOU PROCESS. I MENTION THIS UP
FRONT BECAUSE THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL CHANGE NEEDED TO
TRANSITION THOUSANDS OF
PROFESSIONAL OPERATORS. TO
ANNUAL LICENSE HOLDERS.
UNDESIGNATED A PER PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND MARKERS THAT. CANNABIS
LICENSING IS GOVERNED BY LOCAL
CONTROL AND LICENSEES UNDERGO
EXTENSIVE SEEK OVER A FEW OF THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND FRANKLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE BEST POSITIONED
TO ANALYZE THE PROJECT POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. PROPERLY
EVALUATE STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS
AND MAKE DETERMINATIONS ABOUT
ANY NECESSARY MEDICATIONS. IF AN
APPLICANT UNDERGOES PEOPLE
REVERE IN A JURISDICTION THAT
HAS FILED A NOTICE OF MOTION.
FOR DETERMINATION FOLLOWING THE
ADOPTION OF A NEGATIVE BACK OR A
CERTIFICATE OF ANY I. R. THIS
EFFECT TO THE COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS ACTIVITY. AND THAT
THERE IS NO CHANGE IN THE
PROJECT FORM FUNCTION OR OFFICE
WHEN SEEKING A STATE ISN'T. IN
THE LOCAL APPROVAL SHOULD
SUFFICE TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE'S FOR
IS THE LOOK AT THOUSANDS OF.
LICENSEE HAVE WAY MANY YEARS TO
TRANSITION TO AN ANNUAL LICENSE
AND THE ONLY HOLD UP IS THE
SAFETY FOR RUBIO. IT COSTS US
OPERATORS TIME AND MONEY
ACCORDING TO THE B. C. C.
ROUGHLY 70% OF ALL LICENSES
REMAIN IN PROVISIONAL STOP.
ELIMINATING THE DUPLICATE OF
REVIEW FOR PROJECTS THAT DO NOT
POSE ANY ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
WILL EXPEDITE THE APPROVAL OF
THESE LIFE SAYS BOB HERTZBERG D.
FOR UC'S AUTHORITY IT'S A
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL FEE FOR A
VIEW ON THE PROJECT THAT REALLY
NEED IT. LASTLY THE OVERWHELMING
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT CREATED BY
CANNABIS PRODUCTION OCCURRED AND
CHANNELS WHICH ARE. AND WHICH
ARE ILLICIT AND REMAIN ENTIRELY
UNAFFECTED BY THE SEQUEL RUBIO.
SHORTENING THE TIME IT TAKES TO
OBTAIN OF HANIEL AN ANNUAL
LICENSE HOLDS IN STORE THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET REMAINS. AND
CREATE ASSURANCES FOR NEW
OPERATORS OF THESE REASONS GIVEN
THE ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTS
ASKING FOR ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
AND URGES- I ABOUT TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU KAREN THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY FOLKS WHO WANT TO.
SUPPORT RENT. THIS IN TURN RAN
FOR NON OF THE PARENT COMPANY
WHICH IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANIES IN THE STATE WITH OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. WE ALSO
THIRTY SIX PROVISIONAL LICENSES
THAT ARE AT RISK OF BEING LOST
ALTOGETHER WITHOUT A SENATOR US
LETTERS BILLS AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FOR PERSONAL AUTO
LINE FIVE ELEVEN PLEASE BUT-
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF
OF BODY AND MIND A MULTI STATE
CANNABIS BUSINESS WITH RETAIL
OPERATIONS AS LONG BEACH. THE
SITE IN SAN DIEGO WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
LINE FOR SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FOR SIXTY THREE YEAR
OPEN. MOVING ON WE HAVE LINE
FIVE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA MAY I AM
THE ASSOCIATE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR GOOD FARMERS GREAT NEIGHBORS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SELF
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JEANINE
COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ORIGIN HELPFUL. IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KELLY TOMATO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO FOR THE LINE TO
KEEP THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL ANYONE HERE
PERCENT. ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES. ARE WE HAVE YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A RESTAURANT HIS
ANSWER. ALL RIGHT I OWN THERE
WAS WAS OPPOSITION WE HAVE
SHARED. THAT THE MOMENTS WITH
THEM AND I KNOW THAT TO LEAD A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER THE CONCERNS-BUT- LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OF THE SEASON WITH THE CLIENT. I
WE DO HAVE- OPPOSITION WE HAVE
LINE FOR SIXTY THREE WAS WHAT.
ONE FOUR SIXTY THREE MAY WANT TO
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE HAVE ONE FIVE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY FOR HEALTH
TRIALS CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND TROUT UNLIMITED. I'M REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- CONTENT OF THE
AUTHOR- IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
AVOID DUPLICATE IS- IT'S A
CURRICULA HOWEVER AND WE ARE
CONCERNED AS WE LAID IT OUT IN
OUR OFFICE AND LET. THAT THE-
THAT THAT WE DO ARE THE TO SEE
THE- ANALYSIS BY THE- THE
COMMITTEE AND- AND ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
LAYERED- WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS ABOUT ASSEMBLY RELYING
ON AND NOTICE OF EXEMPTION OR
NOTICE OF DETERMINATION- WE ARE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED AROUND.
THE ADVERSE IMPACT THAT CANNABIS
CULTIVATION CAN HELP ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IT IS IN LINE WITH VOTER INTENT
BEHIND THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR THAT THE STATE DOES INSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH REQUESTS THOUGH.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM MOVING FORWARD-
AND HOPEFULLY CAN WORK OUT- AND
AGREEABLE ADDITIONAL THE BILL.
THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
FIVE FOURTEEN. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY THIS IS
EDWIN FOR BONE WITH CANNABIS A
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FOR THE WHY DID YOU. ALL
RIGHT I THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY LET'S- LET'S NOT BRING
THEM ITEM TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS THOUGHTS. YEAH OKAY TO
MOVE I APPRECIATE OUR WORK
SENATOR I THINK THERE'S THE
OTHER STUDENTS FROM THE SYMPTOMS
STILL TO BE DONE I MEAN ONE OF
THE I WAS SEEING WE GOT A LITTLE
STUCK ON THE HOMELESSNESS OF
EXEMPTION ISSUE I MEAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR KIND OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT GETTING THAT
ADDRESSED. COMMUNITY NEED TO BE
. CONCERNS ABOUT- CALL TO.
ACTIVITIES AND EVEN IN THE
COURSE OF THIS MEETING TODAY
WITH ITS COME UP SEVERAL TIMES-
FOLKS IN A GROVE COMMUNITY IN
THE FACT THAT THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF. ILLEGAL GROWS OUT THERE THAT
YOU KNOW AREN'T YOU COMPLY WITH
THE COURT ALL AND- SOMETIMES OUR
BIGGEST CONCERNS WITH THOSE
FOLKS- BUT- I THINK WE'RE- I
THINK YOU KNOW. WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
CLOSER CLOSER TO A PLACE WHERE
THERE WILL BE ROBUST SEQUOIA-
EXAMINATION- BUT THEY WERE NOT
BE DUPLICATIVE. THAT'S
ULTIMATELY- MY UNDERSTANDING OF
YOUR OF YOUR GOALS AND I THINK
WELL WITH THE UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'VE JUST THE ARTICULATED
EARLIER I'M I'M SO HAPPY TO.
SUPPORT THE BILL SO. AS TO MOVE
BY SENATE AND SALAS AND IF IS
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YES
UNDERSTAND JUST. WASN'T TRACKING
WITH DID THE TO THE AMENDMENTS.
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION. ONE WE AGREED
TO WORK ON TWO OTHERS WERE IN
ESSENCE WE HAVE A PATH WE
COULDN'T HAVE THE AMENDMENTS
READY FOR TODAY AND SO WE'VE
COMMITTED TO GET TO THE END AND
TRY TO TAKE AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND ADDRESS TWO
ISSUES ASIAN ISSUE BUT IT REALLY
ADDRESSES- THE NOTICE ISSUE AND
I THINK WE HAD OUR DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY THAT INVOLVED
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE STATE
AGENCY WHO DROVE DOWN ON EXACTLY
WHAT THEY DO TO. THE STATE THAT
EVEN. WHAT'S OF THE OPPOSITE WAS
JUST THERE'S A INTENT TO
ELIMINATE THE SECOND REVIEW OF
SEA QUEST THE FIRST WITH
MINISTERIAL. AND ARE THERE IS A
REVIEW OF WHAT WAS DONE- WITHOUT
THERE HAVING TO BE A COMPLETE
RE. QUOTE THE SECOND LEVEL AND I
THINK THERE WAS SOME CONCERN
THAT THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE
FIRST ONE IN WRITING. ON SOME
LEVEL WHETHER IT MEETS THAT TEST
AND SO THEN THE QUESTION IS THIS
HOW WE WRITE THAT DOWN TO GIVE
PEOPLE ASSURANCE THAT THAT'S THE
ACTUAL SITUATION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DO. OKAY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING A BILL THAT THEY
HOPE YOU CONTINUE WORKING TO
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK BEFORE THE
FLOOR BUT PREVIOUS TO WORK ON
THIS. THANK YOU OKAY ARE HAS
BEEN MOVED WE'LL TAKE THAT THAT
WAS MY CLOSE THANKS EVERYBODY
FOR TESTIFYING APPRECIATE YOUR
RIFLE WILL. KALRA ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. FIELD FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION D.
PAPPAS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
RE REFER TO AN APPROACH TIONS.
ALLEN I BATES. EIGHT ITALIE
DOLLY I CAN SEE. CONSOL ICE.
STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY CASKEY I.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I IS SENATE
COMMA HERE WHO IS HERE TO PRESS
I'M A AS ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN-
FUNDS HOWEVER RECYCLING. ONE OH
AND BY THE WAY SHOULD MENTION
THAT- THE US I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
RE MENTIONED THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER 877-226-8163 ACCESS CODE
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVENTY
TWO SIXTY ONE SIX THREE ACCESS
CODE SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. THE ASSET OF
COMMERCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
A GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU AND
MEMBERS. I KNOW I HAVE TO BILLS
IN FRONT OF YOU AND SO I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THIS ONE
IS SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE. HI
YES WE ARE STARTING WITH- A LIST
WITH. AT NO LET ME SEVENTH. THAN
ERIC. LEVY SEVEN. SO IF I MAY
ASK THAT WE START WITH HOW DO
YOU LIKE TO START WITH. I HAVE A
WITNESS WHO IS OUT OF. DATE AND
IN SHORT IS COAST TIME AND SO
JUST TO OKAY THAT'S- WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL WILL GO AHEAD AND
DO ITEM NUMBER NINE THIS IS SB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE. WHICH ONE.
OKAY THEN YOU SHOULD PRESENT.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MY BILL SB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
REASONABLE AND MUCH NEEDED
REFORMS TO CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM FOR CLIMATE
POLLUTION SO AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE ARE- CONTINUES TO RELY
HEAVILY ON THIS POLICY WHILE
DISMISSING SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT ITS PERFORMANCE. THAT COME
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE INDEPENDENT ACADEMICS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO MORE TO
MEET ITS CLIMATE TARGETS AND
THAT SOME POINT PORTENT BUT I
CERTAINLY WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS FOR
PEOPLE LIVE NEAR THE OIL
REFINERIES LOCATED THROUGHOUT
THE LOS ANGELES AREA. AND
REFINERIES ACROSS THE STATE. WE
KNOW FROM RECENT LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS. AND EXPERT
ADVISORY REPORTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM HAS TOO MANY ALLOWANCES
AND CARBON OFFSETS THAT IT'S TOO
EASY FOR BIG POLLUTERS TO
CONTINUE BUSINESS AS USUAL.
WORSE MANY OF THESE ASSETS
AREN'T DELIVERING CLIMATE
BENEFITS. WHAT THAT MEANS ON THE
GROUND IS THAT YOUNG KIDS LIVING
NEAR REFINERIES ARE GETTING
ASTHMA MORE OFTEN. AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE TAKING THEM TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM MORE OFTEN.
MEANWHILE THE BURDEN OF AIR
POLLUTION FROM FACILITIES
SUBJECT TO CAP AND TRADE
CONTINUES TO FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. MY BILL
WOULD HELP ADDRESS THESE
INJUSTICES WITH A SET OF
PRACTICAL REFORMS FOR THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. WE KNOW THAT
THE R. WANTS TO LINK ITS PROGRAM
WITH A SIMILAR PROGRAM THAT'S
UNDER DEVELOPMENT IN WASHINGTON
STATE. I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WASHINGTON LEGISLATORS HAVE
STUDIED OUR PROGRAM CLOSELY IN
THEIR BILL SPONSOR FORMER
SENATOR CARLYLE. SAID THAT HE
POURED OVER CRITICAL REPORTS AND
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM IN DRAFTING
THEIR LAW. AND THEY DECIDED TO
DO SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE LIVING NEXT TO MAJOR
POLLUTERS. IN CALIFORNIA WE LET
THESE COMPANIES INCREASED AIR
POLLUTION WHATEVER THEY CLAIM
CARBON OFFSETS CREDITS FROM
EXTRA CARBON SUPPOSEDLY STORED
IN A TREE OR METHANE THAT'S NOT
EMITTED FROM A COAL MINE. THE
WASHINGTON POLICY DECIDED THAT
THE USE OF CARBON OFFSETS WON'T
EXPAND THE TOTAL POLLUTION
ALLOWED IN THEIR PROGRAM THEY
WON'T LET OFFSET'S OUTSOURCE THE
HARD WORK OF CLEANING UP THE AIR
. MY BILL AT THE THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE WANTS TO BRING THE LESSONS
WASHINGTON LEARN FROM CALIFORNIA
BACK TO CALIFORNIA. IT WOULD
CREATE TWO REQUIREMENTS THAT
MUST BE MET BEFORE THEY ARE
FORMALLY LINKS ITS PROGRAM WITH
THE PROGRAM IN ANOTHER STATE
FIRST. I WOULD NEED TO DO A
REGULATORY CHECK UP ON THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AT LEAST ONCE
IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS. THIS IS
A REASONABLE ASK IT'S BEEN MORE
THAN FOUR YEARS SINCE THE LAST
CHECKUP AND DESPITE EVIDENCE
SHOWING THE PROGRAM IS OFF TRACK
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS THE FOR.
UP EFFORTS UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
SECOND ARE WOULD HAVE TO REDUCE
THE PROGRAM WIDE SUPPLY
POLLUTION ALLOWANCES TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE USE OF CARBON OFFSETS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
OUTSOURCE THE POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS ARE COMMUNITIES
URGENTLY NEED. AGAIN THIS
REQUIREMENT IS ALSO VERY
REASONABLE IT'S ONE OF THE
SPECIFIC REFORMS RECOMMENDED BY
THE CALIFORNIA'S EXPERT ADVISORY
PANEL. SO WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS DR DANNY CULLEN WORD.
WITH CARBON PLAN AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THIS INTERVIEW I MEAN TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH CENTER KYLE
TODAY SO WE HAVE WE ARE GOING TO
BE CONNECTING AFTERWARDS BUT I.
WANT TO SAY THAT I AM INTERESTED
TALKING WITH HIM AND INTERESTED
IN ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS A
SMOKE A HOPEFULLY IF THIS MOVES
FORWARD. SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS COMPATIBILITY
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
IT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GONNA IF
THE GOAL IS TO DO SOMETHING THAT
IS COMPATIBLE WITH OTHER STATES
AND SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
LINK IT IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE. OKAY ALL RIGHT I DO WANT
TO. I'VE GOT THREE BILLS AT THE
SAME TIME UP AND SETTLING ON AN
AD BUT- I DO I DO APPRECIATE YOU
CONNECTING YEAH YEAH YEAH. I
THINK I THINK THAT'S THE BASIS
OF IT THE BASIS OF IT. IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU ARE.
WORKING WITH OTHER STATES. YEAH
THAT. THERE'S ARE YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A SYMBIOSIS TO IT SO
OKAY. ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE THAT'S
THE BASIS OF THE BILL YEP OKAY.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO DOCTOR
CONGER. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
ALAN CAN YOU THE MEMBERS HERE
THIS WEEKEND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMEDY MEANWHILE WITH OUT OF
STATE- I JUST WANT TO ADD A FEW
MENTIONS IF YOU ADDITIONAL
POINTS TO A FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF
THE KAMAGRA TRADUCTION. B. TWO
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE BILL I
THINK ARE ARE VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THE FALLOUT OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS- AND
PROCESS- THE PROPOSAL TO TALK
ABOUT FOR SOME TIME. THE IDEA OF
A CHECK UP TO THE PROGRAM I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
NEW STEP. UP ON THE PROGRAM. ALL
OF THE EXISTING STATUTORY
CRITERIA THAT ALREADY APPLY.
ASSEMBLY ASK THAT- THE PROGRAM
BE REVIEWED IN LIGHT OF THOSE
CRITERIA BECAUSE AGAIN. WE HAVE
LOTS OF NEW INFORMATION.
PROGRAMS THE LAST TIME THE CSU
DONE. BY THE ONLY SIGNIFICANT
SHE AND REQUIRED THAT WOULD BE
DONE AND- WITH. THE INDEPENDENT
EMISSIONS MARKET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON WHICH I SERVE- SO I
JUST SORT OF LIKE THAT IT LOOKS
LIKE NEW CHANGE OTHERWISE IT
WOULD BE A QUESTION OF SIMPLY
LOOKING AT THE INSISTENCE. IN
ASKING THE PROGRAM IS ON TRACK I
DIDN'T THE DENTIST. THE MOST
CHANGES THE SECOND. MY RITESH OF
THE BILLS. THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW
WASHINGTON'S LEAD IN ADOPTING
APPROACH. WASHINGTON IS ALREADY
REQUIRED TO TAKE THE WASHINGTON
STATE LAW- I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT- IT THE DESIGN GOAL WITHOUT
REQUIREMENTS IS TO AUTOMATICALLY
APPROVE THE APPROACH THE
WASHINGTON STATE IS REQUIRED TO
FIX. SUPPOSED TO BE AGNOSTIC AND
FLEXIBLE WITH RESPECT TO THE
DIRECTION WASHINGTON STATE
TAKES. APPRECIATING THAT
PERFORMING WANNA SAY JUAN- AND
IT HAD NO EFFECT ON THE-
LANGUAGE BACK BECAUSE THE
LINKING PROCESS. ONLY APPLIES TO
NEW LINKIN PARK. AND I WANT TO
ADD IS THAT THIS HAS. FLEX ON
WHETHER JUST LOOK LIKE THE TURN
OF THE BILL PUT. SIGNIFICANT
CLICK. THAT WOULD REFLECT THE
RESOURCES FOR THE BILLING TO
CHOOSE ROLE FOR THE CAP AND
TRADE FOR. AND THE BILL LAW TO
THE OFFICER TO JOSS REQUIRED
WITH THE REALMS OF POLICY
PARAMETERS THE PART OF THE-
ABOUT HIM CAREFUL DEFINING OUR
PRO. TO GETTING TWENTY THIRTY
PARK- WITH THAT- SENATOR AND
THEN OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DR CURRENT PRESIDENT ALL RIGHT
ANYWAY WHO WANTS A RAISE. VOICE
OF FOR THE BILL AND- ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR THIS IS
FOR SB THIRTY NINETY ONE. LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE DETAILS AT THIS TIME. WHAT'S
GOING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO WINDING QUEUE AT
THE MOMENT. OKAY ALL RIGHT I'M
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION ANYONE IN
PERSON ONE RAISE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL ON THE PHONE LINES
MOTOR. YOU HAVE A SELECTED BEGIN
OPPOSITION THIS PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. YOU TO HAVE A LINE FOR
EIGHTY SIX THESE GUYS. LARA
HAIDER FROM ROCHELLE WELL I
DON'T LIKE LOAN SHOULD HAVE ON
THE TICKET SHOULD BE CHECKED TO
MAKE SURE I HEARD THAT THE LORD
SHALL BE. THANK OKAY THANK YOU
HI ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE LINE
FIVE OH FIVE DESPITE. HELLO I
WAS TRYING TO BE ADDED TO STILL
SUPPORT COLUMN- NAME IS SHERRY
JOHNSON REPRESENTING ALL. OR GO
THANK YOU. WELL NOT THAT ANYONE
ELSE. AND WE HAVE A LINE FIVE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS QUITE MONEY IN STRATEGIC
ADVISOR OF THE INTERNATIONAL
EMISSIONS TRADING ASSOCIATION
AND- ISSUES DO NOT BERKELEY
WHERE I STUDY CARBON MARKETS
JUST LIKE MAKE- MET MY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- WE PUT
THE BILL MAKES IT HARDER TO LINK
WHICH IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
GIVING OUT LINKING. CAN INCREASE
EFFICIENCY AND ALSO- FACILITATE
ENHANCED AMBITION MORE
IMPORTANTLY I THINK IT ON
OCCUPIES THE FIELD OF THE
REGULATOR BY FOURTEEN-
REGULATORY CHOICE IN WASHINGTON
ON TO CALIFORNIA. MY VIEW IS
THAT- THE DECISION OF WHETHER TO
LINK IN PARTICULAR WHETHER
CARBON OFFSET HAVE INTEGRITY I
CAN HAVE MANY SOLUTIONS NOT JUST
THE ONE PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
AND THEREFORE IT'S BETTER LEFT
BOBBY A REGULATORY DECISION FOR
A LOT OF THE EXPERTISE IS HOUSE
. THANK YOU. WHAT COULD YOU JUST
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR NAME INNER
TIE YOUR POSITIONING AND I'M SO
SORRY WE DON'T HAVE YOU ON THE
LIST. NO WORRIES CLEAN MONEY.
STRATEGIC ADVISOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL EMISSIONS TRADING
ASSOCIATION. A NONPROFIT
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION THAT THE
COURTS KERR MARKETS. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
WATER FOR THE LAST WEEK GREAT
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH OF WHAT
THE KEY. GREAT OKAY ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION. I CENTER STERN. YES
THANK YOU- JUST TRY TO READING
THROUGH THE BILL RIGHT NOW I
KNOW WE GOT A LOT GOING ON THIS
WEEK SO- POLICIES FOR NOT BEING
BETTER VERSED ON THIS BUT- IS
THERE. WHAT WHAT PREVENTS THE
AIRBOARD FROM DOING THIS UNDER
EXISTING LAW IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT PREVENTS THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD FROM. ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
AND THEY JUST HAPPENED. THIS
WOULD FORCE THEM TO. THEY COULD
UNDER EXISTING LAW. OKAY- YEAH I
MEAN MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
MEASURE. I THE IDEA OF HAVING
FORMAL REGULATION REVIEW SEEMS.
STRAIGHTFORWARD ONE- WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SORT OF
STRUGGLING POLITICAL EFFORTS
GOING ON IN MANY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA THE DON'T HAVE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAMS OR ANY MARKET
BASED MECHANISMS I MEAN REGGIE
ON THE NORTHEAST THIS IS- REALLY
HARD. REALLY HARD SLOGS FOR
STATES LIKE PENNSYLVANIA TO GET
INVOLVED AND- AND OTHERS SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT. I DON'T WANT
TO. PUT ANY DETERRENT IN STATE
LAW FOR SAY A BRIEF STATE LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA THAT'S GOING TO.
TRY TO PUT TO. PUT SOME KIND OF
CARBON MARKET TOGETHER BUT THEY-
WERE SAYING- WAIT FOR WE'RE NOT
GONNA LINK WITH YOU- OR WE'RE
GONNA PUT THIS PUBLIC
CONSULTATION PROCESS. IN PLACE
WITH. I. E. MAC- AND SORT OF.
PUT THEM THROUGH THE WRINGER AS
IT WERE WHEN IF THEY'RE WILLING
TO STEP OUT AND MAKE SOME TOUGH
DECISIONS I GET WHAT'S GOING ON
WASHINGTON- STATE AND IF THEY'RE
TAKING CHANCES. THERE TO- BUT
BUT THE PROVISION THAT ACTUALLY
IT'S IN AND MICROMANAGES HOW THE
AIR BOARD REDUCES THE NUMBER OF
EMISSIONS ALLOWANCE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF OFFSETS INVOLVED IN
LINKAGE I THINK WE'RE SORT OF
CONFLATING LINKAGE AND OFFSETS
TO THOSE ARE DIFFERENT THINGS WE
TAKE OFFSETS FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS BUT- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS LINKAGE HAS TO
DO WITH THE ACTUAL ALLOWING
MARK. SO MUCH THE OFFSETS. I'M
ALWAYS HESITANT TO DO VERY
NARROW- TINKERING WITH. A REALLY
IMPORTANT STATUTE THAT HAS HUGE
MARKET IMPLICATIONS AND WHAT
THIS MIGHT DO TO THE MARKET
PLACE RIGHT NOW IF WE- IF WE TO
PASS THIS SO I GET THE PEOPLE OF
YES WITHOUT THE CURRENT PROGRAM
MR NINE HEARD YOUR LEAD WITNESS
AND I KNOW HE'S HAD ONGOING
ISSUES WITH THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND WE HEAR HIM LOUD AND
CLEAR THAT. BUT I GUESS
I'M JUST I'M CONCERNED THAT
PICKING THIS NARROW APPROACH AND
DECIDING WHAT THAT IS NOW THAT
WE COULD PROBABLY DEAL BETTER
WITH THAT THROUGH THE SCOPING
PLAN- AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE
DEALT WITH SOME OF THIS IN AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT. I DON'T KNOW
IF THE GOVERNOR IS NOT PUTTING
ANY OF THESE CERTIFICATIONS IN
WRITING OR FOR NOT BEFORE
PROPOSING OVER THE LINK WITH
FOLKS WHO HAVE NOT HAD A FORMAL
REGULARLY REVIEW. BUT YEAH I
JUST FEEL WOULD PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE HERE OTHER THAN.
TRY TO FOR THE AIRPORTS- SO.
THAT'S MY CONCERN RIGHT NOW BUT
I'M HAPPY IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND
OR HAVE YOUR PLEA WITNESS
RESPONDED THAT QUICK NO I'M-
HAPPY TO HEAR SOME FEEDBACK. I'M
JUST GENERALLY RECOVER. IN A
MARKET THAT'S A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR CARBON MARKET WITH GLOBAL
IMPLICATIONS THAT WE WANT A
STABLE AS POSSIBLE ANYTHING THAT
DESTABILIZES THAT OR IN ANYWAY
PUTS A WALL UP AROUND
CALIFORNIA. AND SAYS WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN LINKING WITH OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT. I WANT TO
SHARE AND I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW.
ANYWAY THAT THAT'S WHAT'S THAT'S
MY QUICK REACTION BUT MAYBE I
MAYBE MISSED READING THIS AND
OVERSTATING IT SO I'M I'M I'M
HAPPY TO BE- DISSUADED OR OR
WRONG. AT THAT'S THAT'S THE
CONCERN THIS POINT. OKAY GREAT I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE MY LEAD
WITNESS RESPOND. YES I THINK TO
- CENTER STERN CORPS QUESTION I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE BILL
WAS DRAFTED DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
ACTION FROM THE AIRPORT SO ONE
OF THE OPTIONS THE AIRPORT COULD
TAKE. TAKE NO ACTION AGAINST ME
THE PROGRAM EXACTLY AS A
SUSPENDED FINE ORDER FOR THAT
HARD TO BE LIKE THE REQUIREMENTS
THE BILL WITH APPLY IF AND ONLY
THAT IF THE BOARD WANTS TO MAKE
A NEW BIKE HELMET JURISDICTION
OF THAT IS MOST APPROXIMATELY IN
UNDER POTENTIAL CONSIDERATION
WITH WASHINGTON STATE AND THE
LONG SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE IN THE
MARKET ROLES WOULD BE TO ADOPT
PROTECTION WASHINGTON IS ALREADY
REQUIRED TO. SO THOSE ARE
CHANGES I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT BUT THAT IT'S
BASICALLY BRINGING CAL.
WASHINGTON OKAY AND ONE OF THE
OP BEFORE WOULD PREFER ON THE
BILL THE IT IS TO TAKE NOT AT
ALL SO IF THE BOARD WERE TO SAY
RIGHT DIRECTION WANTED TO THEY
CAN CONTINUE THE ONE THAT THE
CURRENT OFF BUT BE ELIGIBLE TO
MAKE A WITHIN PROGRAM IN THAT
INSTANCE I'M- BUT IF ANOTHER
STATE WANTS TO OUT. AND OCT. LAN
FROM AND I MEANT PENNSYLVANIA
BECAUSE THAT THAT GUY IS BRAVE
VETOED A OF ITS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO BLOCK THEM FROM
JOINING THE REGIONAL GREENHOUSE
GAS INITIATIVE IN THE NORTHEAST
BUT IF WE WANTED TO REWARD THAT
KIND OF CLIMATE BRAVERY ON THE
EAST COAST AND LOOK AT LINKAGES
THERE. WE'VE NOW DESIGNED OF
THIS SORT OF PRECONDITION AROUND
A WASHINGTON. PARITY IDEA BUT-
ARE WE BUSY LOCKING THE AIRPORT
INTO TRYING TO FIND PARITY WITH
THE WITH ONE JURISDICTION BUT
THEN IF ANOTHER JURISDICTION HAD
A DIFFERENT SORT OF FRAMEWORK
WOULD IT. WOULD PRECLUDE US IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SAYING IT
WOULD PRECLUDE US FROM LOOKING
WITH THAT JURISDICTION- I
BELIEVE IT WOULD ALTHOUGH I
THINK IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT
THAT THE EAST COAST
RESTRICTIONS. LEVINE AND
PARTICIPATED IN A MARKET THAT I
THINK IS UNLIKELY TO BE LINKABLE
UNDER CURRENT MARKET STANDARDS
IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT STRUCTURE.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY OTHER
JURISDICTION THAT IS PRETTY FAR
ALONG IN THE CONVERSATION OTHER
THAN CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON
TO AN ECONOMY WIDE PROGRAM LIKE
THAT SO I. WOULD ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT. AND I. I MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT HAS LIMITED THE FACT BUT-
THAT'S DENIED OLDER. FOR THANKS
. WHAT THE MEAT FROM DOCTOR WHAT
WITH SO YOU I'M ADDRESS THE
BROADER THE BROADER CONCERNS
BEING RAISED BY CENTER STERN
WHICH IS. WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
HARM OUR ABILITY TO. I HAD TO IT
TOOK TO LINK WITH STATES THAT
ARE REALLY STEPPING UP. WHAT
SENATOR I THINK AGAIN THERE ARE
MAKING PROVISION IN THE END OF
STATE LAW RIGHT NOW THAT REQUIRE
US TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE LINKED
INTO COMPARABLY AMBITIOUS
PROGRAMS. SUPPORT STANDARD RT
EXISTENCE LONG AND I THINK
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
CONSIDERATION THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE WORKING WITH JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE AGAIN COMPARABLY FISH
PROGRAMS. THE WASHINGTON. MORE
THAN OURS IS GOOD- FOR MIKE OF
VIEW- I THINK THE PRODUCT IS DO
WE WANT TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
WORKS WELL IF WE WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE DINING OUT OF HOME OR WE
MORE INTERESTED IN COLLECTING
LOOKING EXPERIENCES AND- TRYING
TO GET THE PROGRAM UNDER. WITH
CLEAR TO FIND WHAT IT'S GOING TO
IT A HIGHER PRIORITY THAN THIS
WOULD BE I THINK THE WAY TO
ENCOURAGE THAT. BUT CAN I TAKE
YOUR POINT IF THE PRIMARY GOAL
IS TO LINK WITH A MATTER OF
MONTHS FORWARD. INCREASING
STANDARDS FOR LINKING WILL
NECESSARILY DISLIKE THAT. BABY
YOU YOU FEEL- BUT YOU FELT YOU
FEEL PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT A
STRONG PROGRAM. LIKE
WASHINGTON'S WILL NOT BE. I
SUBSTANTIVELY. BY THIS BILL THEY
ARE BILLING TO MY ATTENTION. MY
EDUCATION TO REQUIREMENTS THE
PROCEDURAL CHECKUPS THE AIRPORT
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA PRIOR TO THE LINK AND
THE CHANGES IN THE SECOND
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE TO MATCH
THE WASHINGTON STATE COACH
WASHINGTON STATE BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY HAPPENED APPROACHES
BECAUSE STATURE PARTY REQUIRES
THE SAME KIND OF. SURE THAT
WOULD BE MY INTERPRETATION OF
THE AND DRAFTED. OKAY- CENTER
CASKEY. SO I'M GONNA MOVE THE
BILL BECAUSE I LIKE THE BILL AND
I WOULD INTERPRET ME FIRST SO
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS REGGIE ALL
READ SHE DEALS WITH IS THE
UTILITIES THEY DO NOT HAVE
COVERED ENTITIES POWER PLANTS
SIX ALL THE WITH THIS POWER
PLANTS IT'S A MUCH SMALLER CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM IS TO SPEAK OF
THEN WHAT WE'RE DOING SO. BUT
BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY SO MANY.
SOMEBODY- EMITTER CENTER
ADMITTING IT SO IT'S AS MUCH
SKINNIER LITTLE PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE WASHINGTONHAS COVERED
ENTITIES LIKE WE'D GET THE
LARGEST INDUSTRIAL EMITTERS THAT
THEY HAVE AND WHAT THEY'VE
DESIGNED IS A CAP AND INVEST
PROGRAM IF REUVEN CARLYLE WERE
HERE HE WOULD SAY IT'S NOT CAPEN
TREE WE DON'T WANT YOU TO TRADE
THESE ALLOWANCES WE WANT YOU TO
INVEST AND THAT'S THE BEAUTY
YOUR BILL. IS BEFORE YOU CAN
OFFSET WHICH YES THE CARBON
MARKETS THEY'RE OUT THERE
THEY'RE LISTENING TO WHAT WE'RE
GOING ON HERE YOU CAN'T TRIPS
**** NILLY GET ALL. WITH AT YOU
HAVE TO IN THE- YOUR FIX
FACILITIES YOU DON'T GET AND IF
YOU DON'T THEN YOU DON'T THAT'S
WHAT THE MAP OF. STAFF REPORT
ADEQUATELY EXPLAINS THAT YOU YOU
HAVE ONLY GET A 5% LESSER 10%
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE OFFSET IS
OF YOU MEETING YOUR ALLOWANCES
SO THIS PROGRAM WE DECIDED IN
TWENTY TWELVE IT WAS NEVER
SUPPOSED TO BE STATIC. AS I READ
. I THINK THAT BOARD TO HAVE A
FORMAL REGULATORY OF PROCESS
ONCE WASHINGTON HAS PASSED YOUR
BILL WHAT WE'RE AND WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE LINKAGE
BUSINESS SO THEY HAVE TO SIT
DOWN AND SAY CAN WE LINK IT IN
CAN WE NOT WE'RE NOT. IS SO IF
IT IT WAS NEVER DESIGNED TO BE
STATIC IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
EVOLVE AND IF YOU HAVE A BETTER
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. THAT SAYS
YEAH NOT GOING. TO GIVE YOU A
CREDIT ON THESE ALLOW ON THESE
OFFSETS THAT YOU YOU'RE NOT
REDUCING EMISSIONS UNLESS YOU
ACTUALLY REDUCE EMISSIONS THEN
WE- IT INCREASES OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND- SO WE GET MORE
INFORMATION. THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MEET TWENTY THIRTY.
MEASURES THEN YOU WOULD THINK
YOU WANT TO TIGHTEN UP. THE BED
I'M I THINK IT'S- HE. STROKE OF
BRILLIANCE THAT YOU DIDN'T SET
NEW STANDARDS BECAUSE I COULDN'T
CONTROL MYSELF NOT TO THE SET TO
SET NEW STANDARDS AND IT ALSO
THAT BUT I WAS JUST IN TROUBLE
RIGHT BUT NO BUT BY JUST HAVING
THEM GO THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND HARMONIZE THE
WASHINGTON- PROGRAM THEN I THINK
THAT IN WITH THE GET A JAIL
DON'T HAVE TO DO IT THINK THE
GOING TO END UP. THE GOOD THIRTY
IT- BUT PROGRAM IS PROVEN AT THE
STATE IT'S WHAT CAN HAPPEN TRADE
WAS FOR TO BE WE IT. MADE ALL
THE MOST AND THEN OTHER STATES
HAVE COPY YET AND I WOULD SUBMIT
THAT THE NEXT STATE THAT WANTS
TO JOIN US IT. DOING EVEN BETTER
THAN WASHINGTON AND THEY'RE
GONNA SAY THE OR THEY'RE GONNA
DO THEY'RE GONNA ASK TO BE
LINKED TO US BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF BEING THE-
THIRD ALLOWANCES FOR THAT THAT
WE HAVE IN AND ALSO MAYBE OPEN
UP BUT OFF NEEDS FOR OFFSETS BE
DONE. AND IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS
SO. THE QUESTION THERE BUT THERE
IS A MOTION. OKAY TO MOVE BY-
THERMA CASKEY- YEAH I MEAN ONE
YOU KNOW I MEAN ONE THING CENTER
STERN YOU KNOW- IF SO ONE THING
TO CONSIDER IF THEY'RE TOO MANY
ALLOWANCES IN THE CALIFORNIA
MARKET AND THEN WE LINK WITH
ANOTHER STATE LIKE WASHINGTON.
NOW SUDDENLY A HEART ALLIANCES
AS OUR OUR ALLOWANCES AND BECOME
THEIR PROBLEM TO- SO WE GOT IT
THE PARTLY IS ABOUT TRYING TO
CLEAN UP OUR OWN HOUSE. BEFORE
ENGAGING THE SUN PARTNERSHIPS-
HIS EXCELLENCY THAT RIGHT WELL
THAT'S AT THE HEART OF THE BILL
RIGHT ISN'T. AND THAT'S THE-
ISSUE. OKAY I IT'S THE MOVE I
CENTER CASKEY SEEING NO MORE
QUESTIONS I IN MY CLOTHES THAT
WAS THE CLOSE OKAY ACTUALLY I
HAVE A OKAY HMM. THANK YOU ARE
SECTOR PLEASE ADD OFFICE COLOR
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR COME
LONGER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI ALAN I. FELT THEY KNOW. DALLIED NO CONCERN. SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN. STERN NOT
VOTING Y. CASKEY ARE CASKEY I
CRAM I WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
FOCUSED ON ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
YOUR PREVIOUS SIDE CENTER THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THIS IS A
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU- HERE TODAY A
DAY TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IT CREATES A PILOT PROGRAM
IN LA AND VENTURA. RECYCLED
TEXTILE IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY
AND I KNOW ALL OF YOU ALL CAN
RELATE BECAUSE THE YOU ARE THE
MOST FASHIONABLE MEMBERS IN THE
SENATE. ASHLEY COMES AT A HUGE
COST REFERENCE GROUPS. BASHIN
COMES AT A HUGE COST TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES PEOPLE
AND THE ECOSYSTEM FROM WATER
POLLUTION TO TOXIC CHEMICAL USE
THE CLOTHES AND ACCESSORIES WE
WHERE HARM OUR WORLD THE FASHION
INDUSTRY IS THE THIRD LARGEST
MANUFACTURING SECTOR IN THE
WORLD AFTER THE AUTOMOBILE AND
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRIES. AS OF
TWENTY TWENTY THERE ARE FIFTY
GLOBAL COMPANIES WITHIN FASHION
RETAIL AND TEXTILE CHAINS THAT
HAVE COMMITTED TO THE SCIENCE
BASED TARGETS OF THE PARIS
CLIMATE CHANGE AGREEMENT. AS A
CONTRIBUTOR TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THESE COMPANIES ARE AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING THE INDUSTRY
INCLUDING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OVER PRODUCTION AND
WASTAGE. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE
FASHION SECTOR WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME TWO POINT ONE BILLION
METRIC TONS OF GHGS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ABOUT 4% OF THE GLOBAL
TOTAL. DOES THAT IN CONTEXT THE
FASHION INDUSTRY EMITS ABOUT THE
SAME QUANTITY OF GHGS PER YEAR
AS THE ENTIRE ECONOMIES ARE
FRANCE GERMANY AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM COMBINED. THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER IS NOW PURCHASING 60%
MORE ITEMS OF CLOTHING THAT
TWENTY YEARS AGO. WITH THAT X.
IN THEM THIS COMES AT A HUGE
COST 20% OF GLOBAL WASTE WATER
COMES FROM THE PRODUCTION OF
GARMENTS WHILE COTTON FARMING IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY A QUARTER
OF THE WORLD'S INSECTICIDE ABOUT
85% OF TEXTILES ARE SENT TO
LANDFILLS OR INCINERATORS AND
INCREDIBLY 60% OF TEXTILES ARE
THROWN AWAY WITHIN A YEAR OF
BEING MADE. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN CREATES A PILOT PROGRAM
WITH A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP IN THE FASHION
INDUSTRY TO DESIGN RECYCLABILITY
STRATEGIES COLLECTING RESELL
USED GARMENTS. PROMOTE AND
EDUCATE THE USE OF RECYCLED POST
CONSUMER TEXTILE FIBERS. THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO MAKE THE
FASHION INDUSTRY SUSTAINABLE BY
REDUCING WASTE RECYCLING AND
REUSING RESOURCES AND APPLYING A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY THINKING TO THE
INDUSTRY. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS DOCTOR JOANNE BRASH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND MCKINLEY
THOMPSON MORALLY WITH GAP
INCORPORATED AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBM. OKAY
WELL WE'LL START WITH THE JOINT
ON THE ON THE LINE AND THEN-
YOUR FOR MCKINLEY HEY. OKAY.
BOTH IN PERSON EXCELLENT. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR
JOANNE BRASH I HAVE A PHD IN
TEXTILE ECONOMICS AND I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL WE'RE NONPROFIT WITH THE
MISSION OF HAVING INDUSTRY HE CO
FUNDING SHARE OUR WASTE
MANAGEMENT ISSUES SO TODAY- I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- FOR PUBLICLY FUNDED
TEXTILE RECOVERY PILOT PROJECTS
THAT THE PSC IS CONTRACTING
WITH. TWO OF WHICH ARE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES I
WORKING WITH LA SANITATION OUR
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES IS SENDING OVER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND TONS OF
COMMERCIAL TEXTILES TO THE
LANDFILL EVERY. THE EQUIVALENT
OF MILLION METRIC TONS OF GHGS
AND THAT'S JUST COMMERCIAL
TEXTILES AND THAT'S JUST WITHIN
THE CITY LIMITS. SO I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WE'RE REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
THE LOCALLY FUNDED PILOT
PROJECTS AS WELL. THANK YOU.
AWESOME ALL RIGHT. WE CAN BECOME
SIMILARLY THIS YOUR FIRST BILL
TESTIMONY YES IT IS SIR MY
FORMER STAFF ALSO WE CAN ALL
THAT. PERFECT YEAH PERFECT. WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
MY NAME'S MCKINLEY THOMPSON MORE
LEAN ON BEHALF OF GAP INC I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN I GAP INC WE
RECOGNIZE THE TO CREATE MORE
SUSTAINABLE FASHION THE INDUSTRY
MUST ADDRESS THE FULL LIFE CYCLE
OF OUR GARMENTS FROM RAW
MATERIAL TO END LIFE AND BACK
AGAIN THE FASHION INDUSTRY MUST
SLIPPING CREATED THEM TO USER.
PUTS REDUCE WASTE AND HE
HAPPENED TO DO OUR PART WHERE
SIGNATORY TO THE ONE FASHION
CHARTER FOR CLIMATE ACTION AND
FOUNDING PARTNERS OF THE ELLEN
MACARTHUR FOUNDATION'S MAKE
ACTION CIRCULAR INITIATE WE'VE
ALREADY WON THREE OR DESIGNED
DENIM AT BANANA REPUBLIC IN GAS
AND. WE'LL BE CHECKING 4%
RECESSED. TWENTY TWO FIVE WE'RE
INVESTING HEAVILY IN A CIRCULAR
MATERIAL ARE INDIAN INNOVATION
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS CHALLENGES
AROUND TEXTILE RECYCLING WE'RE
PROUD TO LAUNCH OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED TEXTILE COLLECTION
POINTS WHERE CUSTOMERS CAN
RECYCLE THEIR USED GARMENTS WE
RECYCLED OVER TWO TONS OF
CLOTHING YES WE KNOW THAT THE
CHALLENGES A MULTIFACETED ONE
THAT NO SINGLE ENTITY CAN SOLVE
ALONE. REYES PROUD. SENATE
EFFORTS TO CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON DESIGNING
FABRIC RECYCLING STRATEGIES
COLLECTING AND RESELLING HIS
GARMENTS AND PROMOTING THE USE
OF RECYCLED POST CONSUMER
TEXTILE FIBERS. BURKE CITED FOR
THIS PILOT TO HELP INFORM NOT
ONLY HOW TO CREATE A TEXTILE
RECYCLING PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
HOW TO MAKE IT SCALABLE
SUSTAINABLE LONG LASTING I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR CALM WATER FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT US SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. IF YOU. PROCUREMENT
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO- ANYONE%
ELSE HERE IN PERSON WHO'D LIKE
TO WIN SUPPORT GOING TO THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE ON THE ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATE LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR. SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. SPEAKING SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHAT'S GOING TO GO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE
CLASS. AND WHEN WE HAVE NOT
GIVEN UP. HE SAID. WE DO HAVE
LINE FOUR HUNDRED WAS WHAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ELECTION CHAVEZ THE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER WHY DID YOU. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO
ANY CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
CONCERNS HERE IN PERSON. I KNOW
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION WE
RECEIVED AND- BUT- HOWEVER THE
PHONE LINES. IT'S LIKE TO BE IN
A POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO ONE TO GIVE OKAY
GREAT I THAT AIM IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE A CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU CARE CENTER CALM WATER
I'D LIKE TO BE AN AUTHOR. AND I
REALLY- GLAD THAT THEORY AND
ANALYSIS I THINK IT'S AN OFFICE
THAT NOTES THAT- NOT ONLY IS
WHATEVER NOW WE'RE PRODUCING A
LOT OF THESE TEXTILES THAT PART
THAT ARE GOING INTO LANDFILLS
BUT- THAT YOU KNOW WE- THERE
WERE A FEW OTHER BILLS AND I
CAN'T REMEMBER THE EXACT DETAILS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THESE. MICROFIBERS AND OF COURSE
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT MATERIALS THAT ARE-
WHATEVER IN CONTRIBUTING TO THAT
IN THAT. BABIES IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF THESE
MICROFIBERS IN THERE YOU KNOW
BAY BOTTLE IT JUST SAYS- WHEN HE
CAUGHT- FORGET WHAT THAT TERM IS
FOR WHEN. BODY DURING YOUR PRIME
NUMBER BUT ANYWAY. AND NOW WE
KNOW THAT IT IS A LOT FROM. IT
IT'S NOT JUST THE BLANKETS OR
THAT IT'S FROM ALL THESE
CLOTHES. AND IT'S IN THE
REMEMBER MEANT IT'S A PHYSICALLY
IN US IT'S- YOU KNOW PRETTY SOON
THEY SAY YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE
EATING. WE DON'T HAVE TO EAT IT
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING
WE'RE JUST BECAUSE WERE IN JUST
WERE BRIEFING AT THE WHOLE BIT.
ANYWAY SO THIS IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT THE OTHER THING.
THAT IT TO KERR TO ME THAT WE
HAVE THESE GOALS NOW REGARDING
DIVERSION FROM LANDFILL FOR
ORGANIC WASTE AND THE PURPOSE TO
AVOID METHANE. THAT ANY OF THESE
MATERIALS THAT ARE. FOSS FUEL
BASED. BREAKING DOWN IN THE LAND
PRETTY- NOTHING THEY ARE THE
SAME AS IF WE PUT FOOD WASTE
THEY MIGHT TAKE LONGER TO BREAK
DOWN BUT THEY'RE THE SAME AS IF
WE PUT PAPER FOOD WASTE OR THOSE
OTHER ORGANICS IN A LANDFILL SO
THERE'S YOU KNOW MULTIPLE.
FORTUNATELY NEGATIVE DIMENSIONS
TO THE FACT THAT I LOVE CLOTHES
ANYWAY- THERE ARE MULTIPLE
OFFICE STAND. THERE AND- YEAH SO
I THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
BUT I ALSO THINK WE MIGHT HAVE
TO OVER TIME THINK ABOUT HOW TO
EVEN PREVENT THIS FROM GETTING
INTO LANDFILLS SO- ANYWAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE BILL. BY
TO BE A CO AUTHOR NORMAN THE
BILL. Q. SENATE- I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE WITNESSES IF I
MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST QUORUM
I'M VERY FAST IT ABOUT THIS BILL
AMENDS REPORTED I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD IDEA I WANT. THE IT
MAY. BUT CAUGHT MUST HIS CAUGHT
MOMENT KNOW THERE'S LOT OF-
WILHELM SYNTHETIC IN OUR CLOTHES
BUT IT CAN IT CAN NOT BE
REPURPOSE LIKE WE DO- PAPER WE
CAN TAKE PAPER WE CAN RECYCLE
AND WE COULD PUT RIGHT BACK IN
THE PAPER AGAIN IS THERE IS
THERE ANY- TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR LIKE I KNOW COTTON
IS. YOU KNOW. YES A LOT OF THOSE
NATURAL. THROUGH MECHANICAL
RECYCLING PROCESS. YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY MECHANICAL RECYCLERS IN
STATE HOPEFULLY A FUTURE BILL
COULD INCENTIVIZE THAT BUT- A
LOT OF THE MOST MECHANICAL WRIST
LIKE. FOR COTTON ANOTHER NATURAL
FIBERS ARE. EAST COAST MEXICO
SPAIN INDIA. YEAH THAT THAT
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS. AND GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP THESE.
FIBERS IN USE WITHOUT USING TOO
MUCH ENERGY INTO MUCH WATER TO.
YOU WANT TO GET MORE INFORMATION
AT THE WHAT WHAT MECHANICAL.
RECYCLING PROVIDES BASICALLY
SHREDDING AND RE TWISTING THE
FIBERS INTO YARN. WELL IN
QUESTION I SEE GOOD WILL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I'M
ASSUMING THAT WHEN WE'RE USING
THE TERM RECYCLE IN THIS CASE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CREATING A
COLLECTION SYSTEM BUT THAT IT
PROBABLY AND I HOPE THIS IS TRUE
INCLUDES POTENTIALLY REDUCE
BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE LIKE
GOODWILL INDUSTRIES THEIR
INTENTION WOULD BE TO. AERIAL AT
. ALL THINGS THAT ARE STILL
USABLE AND OF COURSE THAT WE
HAVE THREE ARTISTS BUT THEY ALSO
GAMES REUSE RECYCLE YEAH THEY
ALSO GET. I MEAN YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS RIGHT WE GO AND DROP OFF
A WHOLE BUNCH OF STUFF TO
GOODWILL AND MAYBE THEY USE
MAYBE THEY CAPTURE LIKE 30% OF
WHAT'S DROPPED OFF. AND THEN THE
REST SORRY THE CLOSURE WILL
ACTUALLY AND IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
RESELL IT AND SO THOSE THAT WHAT
ITEMS. CAP IS STILL IN UP IN
LANDFILL. SO THIS IS A- BECAUSE
THEY STILL GREEN NO I BY RESALE
FOR SURE- SO THIS WHAT IMPACT
THIS. BUT WE'D STILL KNOW THAT
MANY ITEMS ARE STILL BEING
DISCARDED AND THEY'RE NOT. PLACE
IN IN A SPACE WHERE THEY CAN BE
RECYCLED. AND GOOD WILL IS OUR
GRANT PARTNER WITH ONE OF THE
RECOVERY PILOTS WHERE WE ARE
ESTABLISHING A REPAIR ACADEMY.
AMENDING SOME OF THOSE. TO
ACTUALLY GET THOSE GARMENTS BACK
INTO USE TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
DUMPING THEM ON SECOND HAND
CLOTHING MARKETS THAT DEFINITELY
DON'T HAVE RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS YEAR WE HAVE
AS AN AUGUSTA WAS CORRECTLY
THERE'S A GREAT LITTLE
BREAKDOWN- OF KARAKUL NUMBERS ON
PAGE THREE OF YOUR ANALYSIS AND
- 10215% GARMENTS ARE DIRECTLY
RESOLD 30% CUT DOWN TO MAKE
WIPING CLOTHS AND RAGS 20%
CONVERTED TO RECYCLE FIBERS. AND
45% SENT OVERSEAS. AND 5% SENSE
LANDFILLS HERE. I WONDER WHAT
THE OVERSEAS NUMBERS END UP
LOOKING LIKE THAT'S THE HALF OF
IT BUT. OKAY YES IT OF COURSE
HAVE ONE LAST COMMENT. MY SONS
YOU KNOW WE WERE FARMERS SO WE
WEAR OUR JEANSTAILORED GOT THEY
HAVE HOLES IN THEM AND SO.
THERE'S A MARKET FOR THOSE WORE
OUT ONCE THAT THAT BY KIDS ARE
LIKE PEOPLE WANTING TO BUY THEIR
PANTS AFTER THE BOTTOM NEW IN
THEIR WORLD BECAUSE YOU GO TO
THE STORE NURSES RIGHT ALL CUT
UP SO THERE IS A MARKET FOR
THOSE. TIMES YOU SAID EBAY I'M
TELLING YOU YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT- PUT HIM ON INSTAGRAM. I
LOVE TO BE OUT IS BECAUSE
THERE'S WELL SENATOR. APPRECIATE
THE BILL AND- GIVE YOU
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE I
LIKE THE DISCUSSION THE
DISCUSSION OF THE CLOTHES ALL
RIGHT FANTASTIC- CONSULTANT
PLEASE COLOR OF. THANK YOU SHE
COMPLIMENTS ARE YOU ACCEPTED THE
MAN'S IRATE YEAH YES. THE BEST
RECORD FOR THE CONSULTANT I AM
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT. THE
MOTION IS TO PRODUCE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS. AS AMENDED. IN ORDER
SKINNER YES THERE IS CITED BY
SENATOR GRACE ANY. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR COM LOGGER OF THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN ALLEN AYE BATES BATES AYE
DOLLY AYE AYE GONZALEZ SKINNER.
INNER AYE STERN HOLLISTER
EYEWEAR CASKEY CASKEY I OKAY.
ARLOTT THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
ARE LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER TEN
AT CENTER BACKERS BILL SB TWELVE
OH THREE. YOU MAY RECEIVE IN
REDDING. JIMMY WELCOME BACK. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL SB
TWELVE OH THREE IS BY HAVING THE
STATE GOVERNMENT SAID EXAMPLE BY
GETTING TO NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ITSELF BEFORE
ASKING EVERYONE ELSE THE STATE
TO DO SO. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
LEADING THE WORLD IN REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS AND ASCETICAL FOR THE
WHOLE STATE BEING AS YOUR BY
TWENTY. OF FORTY FIVE WE'RE
ASKING OUR COMPANIES AND OUR
CITIZENS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS DRAMATICALLY.
IN ORDER TO HIT THAT TARGET.
IT'S A PLANNING GO FIRST
AGENCIES SHOULD TO AIM TO
ACHIEVE NET ZERO FROM THE PHONE
OPERATIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
TEN YEARS AHEAD OF THE STATE AS
A WHOLE. I'M HERE THAT MEANS
REDUCE EMISSIONS FOR STATUS
SHE'S. BUILDINGS AND VEHICLES
AND ELECTRICITY IT WILL CONSUME.
REQUIRES AGENCIES TO PUT
TOGETHER PLANTS IDENTIFY WHAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO GET IN AT
ZERO BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. HOW
MUCH IT WILL COST. IT WILL
DIRECT THEM TO CLUE THIS ACTION
IN THE PLANNING PROCESS HE'S AND
BUDGET REQUEST. IT CRAFTING THIS
BILL WE'RE WORKING. WE'RE
BUILDING ON THE WORK THE MANY
REST AGENCIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DOING REPORTING EMISSIONS
INVENTORIES ANNUALLY. AND MAKING
PROGRESS AND REDUCE EMISSIONS
SUBSTANTIALLY SINCE TWENTY TEN.
THIS BILL OF RIGHTS A CLEAR
TARGET TO MOTIVATE CONTINUED
PROGRESS. YOU ARE AGENCIES TO
ACHIEVE NET ZERO AS COST
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE THE BILL
PROVIDES MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY IN
THE TECHNOLOGIES AND APPROACHES
AVAILABLE IT ALSO DIRECTS DGS IS
OFFICES THING ABILITY TO ACT AS
A CENTER OF EXPERTISE. GEN SEES
IN PLANNING AND EXECUTION. I CAN
ALWAYS THE CONCERN AGENCIES HAVE
NOT YET DEVELOPED PLANS FOR
GETTING TO NET ZERO AND IT WILL
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE FEASIBILITY AND COST OF
ACHIEVING THAT CIRCLE ONCE THEY
DO SO. PASS THIS BILL IS NOT
MAKING A BINDING COMMITMENT TO
NET ZERO. BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
OR COMMITTING TO UNKNOWN FUTURE
BUDGET EXPENDITURES. WHAT SHOULD
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DECIDE HOW FAR AND HOW FAST TO
GO TO FUTURE BUDGET PROCREATION
ONCE AS PLANS ARE DEVELOPED.
STILL THIS BILL WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARDS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS GOING TO
TAKE TO GET TO THAT ZERO AND
HAVING THE WHOLE STATE
GOVERNMENT START HEADING. IN
THAT DIRECTION. I WANT TO THANK
YOU CAN ALSO SEND A CLIMATE
WORKING GROUP WHICH HAS ENDORSED
THIS PROPOSAL TO THE CENTRE
RIGHT COUNTS HE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME WITH. AND WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS AND IMPROVING THE BILL
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND CAITLIN ROPE IN SUCH SUTTER.
EDF THE SENIOR MANAGER OF US
CLIMATE POLICY BEYOND TO TESTIFY
GREAT YOU FOR JUST UNDER CURRENT
GO TO THE FRONT. RUNNER CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AGAIN KEEP ON RECORD.
THE FINAL I. AM VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT BETTER BACKERS SB TWELVE
OH THREE ESTABLISHING. A GOAL
FOR ALL THE REGIONS THE- OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND AS THE
RESTRAINT CARE GOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE REPORT
ONCE AGAIN MAKES CLEAR. THE
WORLD IS SWIFTLY MOVING TOWARDS
ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES OF
WARMING. THAT REPORT ALSO MAKES
CLEAR THAT GLOBALLY WE HAVE THE
TOOLS THE TECHNOLOGY POLICY
OPTIONS AND THE RESOURCES. TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY TRANSITION OF
THE PACE AND SCALE REQUIRED. SB
TWELVE OH THREE ONE STEP IN THE
TRANSITION FOR CALIFORNIA. BY
ASKING STATE AGENCIES TO
INVENTORY THE EMISSIONS FROM. ON
BOTH SIDES. AS WELL AS- BY THE
STATE. INSURANCE TO REDUCE
EMISSION. AFTER THAT NERO ENGINE
TO THE A PLAN TO THOSE GOALS
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE A BIG STEP
FORWARD IN UNDERSTANDING HOW TO
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE NET ZERO
ECONOMY WIDE. AND WILL ALSO
BUILD ON THE SUCCESS ALREADY
SEEN IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN MOVING TOWARD
MASS ZERO. AND AS SENATOR BACK
MENTION YOU IMPLEMENT AGENCIES
PLANS WILL STILL BE CONCLUSION
AND FUTURE APPROPRIATIONS BY THE
LEGISLATURE SIGNIFIED HE KEEPS
TURNING HOW TO PRIORITIZE THE
MISSION REDUCTION. ASK THE
GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP PLANS FOR
ITSELF TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
EMISSIONS CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S LONG LEGACY OF
CLIMATE LEADERSHIP. AND
LEVERAGES THE STATE'S
PROCUREMENT POWER TO JUMPSTART
PROGRESS ACROSS SECTORS- DEMANDS
FOR NEW CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES.
ACTUAL PLAN TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
FROM STATE OPERATIONS INCREASE
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS AND HELP
CHART A PATH FOR THE REST OF THE
SEEK TO ACHIEVE. EUROPE IS ALSO
A STEP THAT MANY OTHER STATES
CAN FOLLOW FURTHER ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
I. T. REPORT IS A AND MEDICARE
FOR WE HAVE THE KNOW HOW TO
ADDRESS THE RAPID CHANGE OUR
CLIENT. IT IS ALSO CLEAR THAT
POLITICAL WILL IS HOLDING THE
WORLD BACK FROM DEPLOYMENT TOOLS
AND RESOURCES THAT ALREADY THAT
. CALIFORNIA HAS THE POLITICAL
WILL TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
AND NOW IS YET ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
AND AFFIRM THAT OUR STATE IS
GOING TO LEAD THE WAY. THIS TIME
IN MAKING SURE ALL STATE
OPERATION EARNEST WITH PASSING A
ZERO EMISSION. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR IPHONE SB TWELVE
OH THREE. THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO ANYONE HEARING
PERSONAL SEARCH FOR SUPPORT READ
. THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
READ OUT OF SOME BEHALF IN
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FIND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT FOLKS ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR SB TWELVE OH THREE. SPEAKING
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CRYSTALLINE
FIVE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PHIL MURPHY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
WE HAVE LINED FIVE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TV FANTASY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINED
FIVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. KENNECOTT REPEATEDLY TOLD
VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WHAT FINAL FOUR OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. THIS
IS A MACRO ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE LINE FOR
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS WILL PREPARE FOR THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT LIFELINE FIVE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS EVEN MORE I'M A RESIDENT
OF SAN MATTEO A STUDENT AT
COLLEGE OF SAN MATEO AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE ZERO
THREE FOR NET ZERO EMISSIONS
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FOR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THE ON BEHALF OF THE
CLIMATE REALITY SILICON VALLEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FOR THE ONE TO GO
THE STAFF VERY GOOD LET'S GO TO
THE OPPOSITION IS ANYBODY HERE
IN ROME. TWENTY ONE HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AGAINST MR
RECORDS BILL SB TWELVE OH THREE
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MONITOR. FOR
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE.
OPPOSING S. B. TWELVE OH THREE-
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO WINDING QUEUE AT
THE SYMBOL CLOSER TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BRING IT BACK TO
THE DIE DICE ANY QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
QUALITY COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE.
BUT TO CLOSE CENTER RECORD. I
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS A MOTION
THAT I SEE FROM SENATOR- SKINNER
. I'M YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SENATE REBEKAH IT'S THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR- SKINNER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DID
NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE OH THREE BY
SENATOR BACKER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. BATES DALLI DALLI NO
GONZALEZ SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STERN AYE WHY CASKEY
HI MY COUNTY I HAVE A FEW VOTES
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN YES
CENTER SKINNER. CAN KEEP OF THE
ROLE OPEN- I SAW. ASCENDER A
CHOI BOGUE HERE THAT I WAS GOING
TO PRESENT ON SENATOR- GROVES
ISSUE SB THIRTY NINE- THEN
CENTER DOLLY TO THE DAIS OR THE
PODIUM IS YOURS THIS IS THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN NINETEEN BY GROVE
FORMALLY BEING PRESENTED BY CHOI
BOGUE NOW BEING PRESENTED BY
DOLLY CENTER DOLLY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED WELCOME BACK MR SEE
HOW I AM HERE PICHICHI. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I AM
PRESENTING S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETEEN ON BEHALF OF CENTER
GROVE. THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS TO IMPROVE
THE BILL AND AMENDMENTS IN
MINUTES IN COMMENTS TWO THREE
AND FOUR THAT CLARIFY A NARROW
THE MONITORING REPORTING
PROPOSALS. WE WILL WHAT WE WILL
BE TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS. EACH
YEAR CALIFORNIANS CONSUME ONE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS
OF OIL A DAY THAT'S ROUGHLY SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
BARRELS A YEAR. BUT ONLY A
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
BARRELS WERE PRODUCED HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BY
CALIFORNIA WORKERS. WE IMPORT
THE REST OF THAT OIL WHICH IS
TRANSPORTED HERE MOSTLY ON HUGE
TANKER SHIPS. THE AMOUNT WE
SPEND ON IMPORTED OIL IS IT
ENORMOUS. IF OIL IS PRICED AT A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A BARREL
CALIFORNIANS PAY FIFTY BILLION A
YEAR TO IMPORT THE OIL WE NEED
TO USE EVERY SINGLE DAY. WITH
FOREIGN OIL IMPORTS WE HAVE
PLACED CALIFORNIA'S ANY ENERGY
SECURITY INTO THE HANDS OF
COUNTRIES THAT ARE ACTIVELY
HOSTILE TO CALIFORNIA'S USE WHEN
IT COMES TO HUMAN RIGHTS. LABOR
RIGHTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHTS
. THE TOP THREE COUNTRIES. WE DO
BUSINESS WITH ACCOUNT FOR TWO
THIRDS. OF THE FOREIGN OIL WE
IMPORT THAT'S FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND BARRELS.
WELL DAYS OR A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL YEAR.
THESE COUNTRIES ARE ECUADOR
SAUDI ARABIA AND IRAQ. ALL THE
IMPORTED OIL IS BROUGHT TO
CALIFORNIA BY SIX HUNDRED TANKER
SHIPS A YEAR THOSE TANKER SEND
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF CARBON
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE. EVERY YEAR
FROM THE FUEL THEY CONSUME TO
POWER THE NEEDS TO OUR AND THE
POWER THEY NEED THEY NEED TO
OFFLOAD- THIS BILL. MUCH OF THE
OR IT COULD BE REPLACED BY
CALIFORNIA'S IN STATE. PRODUK
PRODUCERS PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
JOBS IF WE WERE ALLOWED TO
EXPAND PRODUCTION. THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS OPERATE
UNDER THE MOST STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS IN THE
WORLD. SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
WOULD SIMPLY IMPLORE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALIZE THAT MUCH
OF THE CRUDE OIL IMPORTED INTO
CALIFORNIA COMES FROM FOREIGN
NATIONS. WITH CHEMISTRY WITH
DEMONSTRATED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
AND FOREIGN NATIONS THAT HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS LOWER
THAN THOSE IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
MEASURES WERE ALL TO REQUIRE A
CAL JIM TO REPORT ON ITS WEBSITE
THE AMOUNT OF PARTICULATE MATTER
RELEASED INTO THE AIR FROM OIL
TANKER SHIPS EMISSIONS. IN AN
EFFORT TO HIGHLIGHT THE AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS FROM THE STATE'S
DEPENDENCE ON FOREIGN OIL.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS IN
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE READY TO
MEET THE DEMAND FOR CALIFORNIA
OIL. MORE MORE THAN A THOUSAND
JOIN PERMITS ARE CURRENTLY
AWAITING APPROVAL AT CAL JIM AND
FIFTY FIVE YOU I SEE PERMITS
HAVE BEEN AWAITING FOR APPROVAL
FOR ALMOST FOUR YEARS. APPROVAL
OF THESE PERMITS WOULD EXPAND
PRODUCTION IN IN STATE REDUCING
FOR THEM FOREIGN IMPORTS.
GENERATE GENERATE THOUSANDS OF
HIGH PAYING JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS IMPROVE OUR STATE'S
ENERGY SECURITY AND BE DONE
UNDER THE MODE THE WORLD'S MOST
STRINGENT ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
WILL HOPEFULLY START A PROCESS
TO BRING BACK TO CALIFORNIA THE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN
LOST TO FOREIGN COUNTRIES DUE TO
THE SHARE OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
VALUES AS WE RESPECT. AT ALL
RESPECT FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. I
HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
MAYOR THE MAYOR OF TOP OF TAFT
MISTER DAVE NORA AND SEAN
WALLENSTEIN FROM CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S I THINK THE MERITS ON
THE COASTLINE. M. YOU'RE YOU'RE
VERY WELCOME MISTER MAHER WE'VE
IN THE PROJECT FRENCH HAVE YEAH
AND WE'VE BEEN LISTEN WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT YOU ON NPR. THE
MAN TALKING ABOUT OIL INTO. YEAH
YOU MAY PROCEED. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE CHAIR
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SPEAKING
WITH YOU ALL. THE BILL THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING IT MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE IS ABOUT ACTUALLY
TAKING STOCK IN WHAT OUR
DECISION IS HUGE TO US IN THE
AFFECTED THOSE DECISIONS. BEYOND
OUR BORDERS I MEAN WE ARE STATE
CONSUME A GREAT DEAL OF
CONTROLLING THEM. AND YET EVEN
THOUGH IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WE ONLY IMPORTED FOUR AND A HALF
PERCENT OF ALL THE OIL THAT WE
USE. CALIFORNIA FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES TODAY THAT NUMBER IS
CLOSER TO SIXTY IVE PERCENT. WE
USED FOR HIM AND HE WILL. HI
YEAH LIKE IS TALKED ABOUT IN
BILL THE SOURCE OF PETROLEUM FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY WE IGNORE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HUMAN RIGHTS
AFFECTS THAT WE ACTUALLY FINANCE
ECUADOR IS CURRENTLY OUR LARGEST
PROVIDER OF IMPORTED OIL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ECUADOR
THEY'RE IN- SEE NATIONAL OIL
COMPANY CONTRACTS WITH CHINA. I
DIDN'T. ACTUALLY DRILLING AND
PRODUCING OIL IN ECUADOR MUCH TO
THE DETRIMENT OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AND INDIGENOUS PERSONNEL. WHAT
ARE USED TO BE THE GREATEST
CARTONS THANK NATURAL CARBON
SINKS IN THE FACE OF THE GLOBE
AND IS NOW A CARBON EMITTER.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PURCHASING SOME 60% OF ALL THE
OIL THAT IS EXPORTED FROM
ECUADOR. WE UNFORTUNATELY ARE
FINANCING THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
AMAZON RAINFOREST WELL WE CHOOSE
TO FEEL LIKE WE'RE GOING GREEN
RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE SAME CAN BE SAID
FOR WHAT WE IMPORT UNFORTUNATELY
FROM RUSSIA. THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL GOING ON IN THE WORLD THESE
DAYS IN RUSSIA BEING AT THE
FOREFRONT A LOT OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS IN MISSOURI'S. THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS. CALIFORNIAN
PORTED ON AVERAGE FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND BARRELS OF OIL AND
PRODUCT A DAY. EVERY DAY FROM
RUSSIAN. SO WE DID WAS HELP FEEL
FILL THEIR THEIR WAR CHEST AND
BY PROXY THAN WE ARE THEN
HELPING FINANCE HUMAN MISERY AND
DESTRUCTION TAKING PLACE IN
RUSSIA WE AS A STATE. OTHER THAN
THIS IF WE'RE GONNA LEAD THE
WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO. THE
REALIZATION OF IMPACT ON THE
CLIMATE WE HAVE GOT TO LOOK
BEYOND OUR BORDERS WE HAVE GOT
TO TAKE STOCK. IN THE ACTIONS
THAT WE PUT INTO PLACE FOR THE
EFFECTS OF THOSE ACTIONS.
GLOBALLY THAT IS WHO WE ARE AND
THAT IS THE WAY WE SHOULD LEAD
WHERE OUR WORDS FELLA SINGLE
STORY OUR ACTIONS UNFORTUNATELY
HELD A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STORY. WHAT BETTER THAN THAT
NINE WE CAN DO BETTER WE PRODUCE
OIL RIGHT HERE AND STAY
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE MOST
STRINGENT STANDARDS AND PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK WE DON'T VIOLATE
HUMAN RIGHTS. VARMINT CALIFORNIA
IS TRANSITION TO A GREENER
FUTURE WE HAVE BEEN FOR DECADES
YOU WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WITHOUT DESTRUCTION I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND RESPONSIBLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON SINGLE
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU
MISTER MOORE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED OUR LET'S LET'S NOT
HEAR FROM US ON. THE WILD SIDE
FROM A STEP. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- JOHN WALTON FOR
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THREATEN FIFTY OIL
AND NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. SERVICE AND
SUPPLY COMPANIES- AND ROYALTY
OWNERS OBVIOUSLY HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- THE MAYOR DID A
VERY GOOD JOB EXPLAINING- WHERE
CALIFORNIA GETS ITS OIL- WE GET
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR OIL
FROM COUNTRIES LIKE ECUADOR IN
FACT- TWO YEARS AGO THEY BECAME.
THEY SURPASS SAUDI ARABIA AS THE
NUMBER ONE IMPORTER OF CRUDE OIL
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SHOCKINGLY- THEY ARE PRODUCING
THAT CRUDE BY BULLDOZING AS THE
MAYOR SAID THE AMAZON RAINFOREST
IT IS SHOCKING- THE WILDLIFE AND
THE FLOOR DOWN THERE THAT'S
BEING DESTROYED AS WELL. AS
DISPLAY. PEOPLE NOW THIS WEEK IS
HAPPENING- TO MEET THE ENERGY
DEMANDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT DOESN'T HAVE TO
. A SUPER REPRESENTS OIL AND
NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE PRODUCE CRUDE IT
IS CLIMATE COMPLIANT UNDER AB
THIRTY TWO- AND UNDER THE
ASSOCIATED REGIME UNDER AB
THIRTY TWO WE DO IT RIGHT WE DO
IT BETTER THAN ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD CHAVEZ SORRY THE MERITECH
OF WELL I'M THE TYPE BIT BUT
REGION VASILY WHY YOU ALL JUST
BEEN ABOUT THIS- THE PART THE
PORTION OF THE BILL THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEMBERS IS.
THE STATE BEGINNING TO ME THIS
DOCKS THAT ARE BEING FROM
TANKERS RIGHT THAT'S BLOWING
INTO THE LA BASIN THEY ISSUED A
REPORT YOU'VE MAYBE HEARD SAY
BEFORE- I INTO. WHEN TWENTY. OF
THE L. TEN VESSEL OFF THE COAST
THAT IS A MAJOR CONCERN HERE AND
A LOT OF THAT BLAME GETS PLACED
ON OUR MEMBERS WHO PRODUCE
CRUDE- IN THE RIGHT WAY
UNDERNEATH THE AIR BOARD THE
EIGHTEEN ANTI THAT'S THE A
COMMUNITY STUDY NOT OURS SO WE
APPRECIATE A BILL THAT IS GOING
TO BEGIN THE MEASURE- THAT THAT
POLLUTION THANK YOU FOR RECESSED
. THANK YOU OKAY. RIGHT LET'S.
TO THE PHARMACY FOR FOLKS WANNA-
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN PERSON.
OKAY ON THE PHONE LINES- WHO
ONCE SERVED VOICE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN. MODERATOR. AS A MATTER
THAT. I'LL JUST MENTION THIS
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WITH AS AMENDED
SO- IS ANYONE IN PERSON HE WANTS
TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
AND IT WILL GO BACK IF THE
MATTER GETS BACK ON- FROM. ONE
WELL. THERE'S SOMEBODY THAT'S
PROBABLY MERIT THINK MAYBE.
REALLY CUT OFF THE COASTLINE AND
GO TO THE COLLINS. BACK. HOW'S
EVERYTHING IN TAFT. WELL
MODERATE MODERATE WELL IT'S
ABSOLUTELY YEAH THE GUITAR I'VE
BEEN THROUGH THERE. OKAY
MODERATOR KIKI CAN YOU ARE YOU
AROUND. HIS TO BILL BE LEFT
DESTITUTE GIVEN OUT. THEY THE
BATTLE CREEK AREA LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO-
QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
YOUR OPINION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY AND
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I APPRECIATE. COULD YOU GET BACK
ON OKAY SO LET'S. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS- THIS CYNICAL SKI MOVE
THE BILL OKAY. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY I WAS THE- THIRD I THINK
YOU FOR STEPPING IN SO ABLY- FOR
A COLLEAGUE AND- AND I AND I YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT YEAH THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE I THINK OF WHERE. OUR
FRIENDS ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY I'LL
REYES LEGITIMATE CONCERNS ABOUT-
ASPECTS OF- OF THE WAY WERE
MONITORING- AND TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ALL THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH OUR
ENERGY. AND WE'RE TAKING THOSE
CONCERNS SERIOUSLY WITHIN WE GOT
PLACE FOR THE BILL WHERE. ARE WE
DO WHAT WE HAVE A QUICK QUESTION
ON A MONITOR. I ATTRIBUTE THE
YEAH MY YES THE SAID ANYONE
WANNA WOULD GIVE THEIR OPINION
IS WHAT HE SAID- YEAH MAN YEAH.
YEAH I'M I'M I SUPPORT THE BILL
IN ITS THE MOVE BY CINEMA CASKEY
YOU MAKE LAKE THANK YOU- I AM
VERY HONORED TO BE ABLE TO. HAVE
A BILL GET OUT ON BEHALF OF.
CENTER GROVE. I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I THINK IT IS- HANG
ON YOU KNOW AS CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY IN IN. ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO OTHER STATE. OR THAT
IS DONE MORE AND THAT IS THAT IS
THAT IN THE WAY THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS FOR AT THE SAME TIME- WE'VE
- BY LEADING WE IF WE'VE LEARNED
THAT TIME. WE ARE ARE DRIVING
OUT.THIS IS A CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ARE IMPORTING THOSE GOODS
THAT WE NEED FROM OTHER AREAS
AND IN THIS CASE IT'S OIL. SO
I'M HAPPY TO SEE THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD IT WILL HELP US GET SOME
DATA- THAT WE NEED. QUITE
FRANKLY AND WE SHOULD BE- YOU
KNOW PUTTING CALIFORNIANS TO
WORK. AND DOING IT IN A MORE
RESPONSIBLE WAY HERE INSTEAD OF
DAMAGING- THE AMAZON RAINFOREST
QUITE FRANKLY WHEN IT COMES IN
FROM ACT OR SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR MY CHART. I
DON'T SEE COLOR. ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN BY
CENTER GROVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ALAN
HI. ALAN ALL RIGHT BATES. VALLEY
DALLY I'D CONSOLIDATE. SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN. RECOUNTS SKI.
HI THE CASKET GUY RIGHT. I THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALI. ARE LET'S GO T. TODDLE TIME
NEXT TUESDAY ANNOUNCES JOINTLY
AUTHORED BILL. I WILL GO TO ITEM
ELEVEN THIS IS S. B. TWELVE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY-
TURN MEMBERS. SO I I'M SURE THAT
YOU ALL HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE
JUST THE BREAKING NEWS YESTERDAY
RIGHT THAT THERE'S SIX MILLION
PEOPLE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE FACED WATER
RESTRICTIONS AND SEEM LIKE EVER
BEFORE IT COULD VERY WELL BE IN
A SITUATION LIKE. YOU KNOW MANY
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
AT THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND WHILE
I WOULD LIKE TO BLAME THIS ON.
THE DROUGHT ALONE- I I'D BE
DISHONEST. AT IT'S JUST ONE OF
SEVERAL FACTORS FROM LACK OF
STORAGE TO DAMAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION IT IS A LARGE PART DUE
TO. AN ANTIQUATED OF A WATER
SYSTEM THAT HAS LED TO THE YOU
KNOW THE MISSED THE
MISMANAGEMENT OF OUR MOST
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCE FOR
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE
A- POINT OF NOTING THIS THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE I
PARTNERED UP WITH A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE WATER THAT'S NOT
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
SUBJECT TO A VERY HAPPY AND
THANKFUL TO HAVE CENTER COURT
CORTEZ YOU HERE WITH ME TO-
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF SB TWELVE NINETEEN.
BUT WATER SCARCITY IS YOU KNOW
AS I SAID BEFORE IT'S NOT JUST A
CENTRAL VALLEY ISSUE IT'S NOT
JUST A CALIFORNIA ISSUE IT'S A
GLOBAL ISSUE IN. REPORT AFTER
REPORT TELLS US THAT WATER.
SCARCITY NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
REALLY IN IT AND A NEXUS WITH
FRAMEWORK WITH FOOD HEALTH
ENERGY AND SECURITY ALL PART OF
IT. IN FACT THE TWENTY TWELVE
COMMITTEE INTELLIGENCE
ASSESSMENT REPORT ON THE STATE
OF GLOBAL WATER SECURITY
INDICATED THAT. OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS THIS WAS BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE MANY COUNTRIES
IMPORT TO THE UNITED STATES WILL
EXPERIENCE WATER PROBLEMS WERE
JUST POOR WATER QUALITY OR
FLOODS THAT WILL RISK
INSTABILITY AND STATE FAILURE
INCREASED REGIONAL TENSIONS. AND
DISTRACT THEM FROM WORKING WITH
UNITED IT'S ON AND IT WAS POLICY
OBJECTIVES. THE PORT THE REPORT
ALSO STATED THAT DURING THE NEXT
TEN YEARS THE DEPLETION OF
GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES IN SOME.
AREAS GOING TO POUR WATER
MANAGEMENT WILL POSE A RISK TO
BOTH NATIONAL GLOBAL FOOD
MARKETS. THAT WATER ENSURE
BASINS WILL INCREASINGLY BE USED
AS LEVERAGE AND THE USE OF WATER
AS A WEAPON OR TWO FOR THE
TERRORIST. UP PROJECT OBJECTIVES
WILL ALSO BECOME MORE LIKELY.
I'VE BEEN WORKING TO FIND YOU
STRATEGIES AND WAYS TO
COLLABORATE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
DROUGHT WE ARE FACING A PROTECT
US FROM WATER AND FOOD SCARCITY.
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE. AND I
EIGHT I. LAST YEAR THE SENATE
MADE- AND PUSH NAVIGATOR FOR
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CONSTRUCTION HAS ALREADY BEGUN
TO RIP TO REPAIR THE STATE'S
WATER CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS THIS IS
THE BEST INVESTMENT WE CAN MAKE
TO CONSERVE THE LIMITED WATER
SUPPLY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DELIVERED TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. BUDGET THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. BUT MORE FUNDING IS
STILL NEEDED FOR REPAIRS BUT
UNTIL FULL REPAIRS ARE MADE WE
WILL CONTINUE LOSE WEIGHT TOO
MUCH PRECIOUS WATER AS IT
TRAVELS THROUGH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- IT'S WATER THAT WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE IN IN THIS
CLIMATE. AND JUST LAST YEAR
THERE WERE MANY TOWNS ACROSS MY
SENATE DISTRICT. THAT OTHER
WELLS RAN DRY AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE KNOW THE SIX MILLION
PEOPLE FROM PARTS OF LOS ANGELES
AND TORRANCE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTIES THAT RELY HEAVILY ON
THE- ON THE STATE WATER PROJECT
COULD EXPERIENCE THE SAME. SO
THE IMPACT THE POOR WATER
MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
THREATEN THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF ALL PEOPLE. AND TO
COMBAT THAT SENATOR CORTEZ NINE
PARTNERSHIP TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
THE TRANSPARENCY THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
HOW DECISIONS FOR UNDERWATER
MEAT. TODAY THERE ARE TOO MANY
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AT EACH DEAL
WITH A PIECE OF WATER MANAGEMENT
WITH SIMILAR BUT SOMETIMES
CONFLICTING GOALS. AND THOSE
MOST IMPACTED BY THE DECISIONS
THEY MAKE BOTH MOBILE OFTEN LOW
INCOME AND OR AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS AG. ARE
TOO OFTEN NOT PART OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THE LAWS
OF THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS
DO NOT APPLY. TO THE CHALLENGES
THE NEEDS OF THE CALIFORNIA WE
LIVE IN TODAY. WE INTRODUCED
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETEEN ALSO
KNOWN AS A STATE WATER
RESILIENCY MODERNIZATION ACT TO
PRIORITIZE THE PRESERVATION AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF WATER USAGE.
AND ENSURE THE WATER IS
PROTECTED FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
ABUSE. MODERNIZING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO MEANS INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY. MODERNIZING MEANS
THAT WE HAVE BETTER CONTROL OF
WATER FEET INCREASES. SOME OF
THOSE FEE INCREASES BEING FELT
ACROSS EVERY PART OF CALIFORNIA
WILL CONTINUE TO RISE MORE THAN
LIKELY. MODERNIZE IT ALSO MEANS
THAT WE DO BETTER PROVIDING
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
THAT WE DON'T DELAYED BECAUSE
PROJECTS THAT OUR- MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
DESPERATELY NEED. MODERNIZING
MEANS WE HAVE A CYBER SECURITY
ACROSS OUR WATER SYSTEM AND
ACKNOWLEDGES THE NEW ERA OF
CYBER WARFARE WE ARE IN TODAY.
AND HOW IT COULD BE USED AGAINST
US COLLEAGUES FOR WATER
MANAGEMENT MAKES US ALL
VULNERABLE AND REALLY I THINK IN
MY HUMBLE OPINION THREATENS. OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR VERY OWN
EXISTENCE. SB TWELVE NINETEEN
WILL IMPROVE OUR WATER
MANAGEMENT BY CREATING A
COMMITTEE THAT WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR MORE INTEGRATED
WATER MANAGEMENT FRAMEWORK. A
MODERN SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP US
ACCOUNT FOR EVERY DROP OF WATER
AND FOLLOWS THE MOST RECENT
SCIENCE. A MODERN SYSTEM THAT
WILL HELP US ALL CONSERVE. I'D
LIKE TO GIVE TIME NOW A TO
CENTER COURT TO THE TO SPEAK ON
THE MATTER AS WELL THANK YOU.
THE FIGURES SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL BE BRIEF- F. AFTER
THAT- THOROUGH PRESENTATION- BY
OUR COLLEAGUE- CENTER TARO- I
THINK WHAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BILL IS A
COUPLE THINGS I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT THE BOTTOM OF
THE- PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS.
IS WHAT LOOKS LIKE JUST ANOTHER
ENUMERATED. BULLET POINT IF YOU
WILL. ABOUT VARIOUS FINDINGS
THAT SHOULD BE MADE DURING THIS
PROCESS THAT'S CALLED OUT IN THE
BILL- BUT- THAT STATEMENT IS
REALLY ALMOST MORE OF A
CONCLUSION. TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE HAS A MODERN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SAID WATER WAS
REGULATIONS. AND STATE LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE STATE TAKE A TOP TO
BOTTOM REVIEW OF HOW WATER
RESOURCES IN THE STATE ARE
MANAGED IN I'D IN IDENTIFY
NECESSARY REFORMS. THAT'S
NECESSARY REFORMS FOR A WATER
SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO SERVE.
EVERYBODY EVERY STAKEHOLDER- IN
EVERY ISSUE OUT THERE IS THAT
THE BISHOPS. IN A COMPREHENSIVE
YES BUT TO DO THAT- THE BILL
CALLS FOR A MAIN COMMITTEE-
WHICH WOULD BE SET UP. IT IT THE
SET UP ITSELF WOULD BE IN A VERY
TRANSPARENT WAY. UP OKAY. IN A
BLUE RIBBON TO- OF STAKEHOLDERS
- THAT CAN MAKE THAT PROCESS AS
TRANSPARENT AS THEY WOULD LIKE-
AND SO I DON'T WANT TO- HIS.
KHALKHAL WITH OPPOSITION. WITH
THAT DONE BEFORE IT'S IT STATED
OR- OR OR- BUT PERHAPS- IT OVER
ANTICIPATED- BUT- YOU KNOW TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD AT LEAST IN THE
ANALYSIS- THAT- THAT SOMEHOW
THIS KIND OF WORK COULD BE DONE.
IMPLIED NOT AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE
IS NOT REALISTIC OF COURSE IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. THANK YOU.
VERY HEALTHY JUST WALDRON
APOLOGIZE- THE PROCESS IS
NECESSARY WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE A MODERNIZED WATER SYSTEM
WOULD WANT MODERNIZE WAY TO LOOK
AT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WATER
SYSTEM AT ANY MOMENT NOTHING
EVEN EQUIPMENT THE ICE SO THAT
WOULD APPLY TO WATER RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED IT IT OF COURSE S. B.
THE PROCESS OR ANALYSIS TO BE
PAID FOR TAXPAYERS EXPENSE-
TRANSPARENCY IS NOT ONLY NOT A
PROBLEM OR OBSTRUCTIONISM OR
ANYONE TRYING TO IMPEDE- THE
REFORMS BUT THE OF ACTUALLY
CALLS FOR ARMS INTO THE PROCESS
WHERE THERE WOULD BE LEGISLATORS
FROM HOUSES WILL. KARAMANA WROTE
ROUGHLY A TO WHAT WE HAVE- IN A
POST COMMITTEE- LIKE WE'RE
CONVENIENT HERE TODAY SO- YOU
KNOW I'M VERY PROUD- YOU KNOW TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND-
AND WOULD URGE- I POKE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I'M A
MODERATOR I BY DO WE HAVE THE
TEST OF THE- WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- FRANK GALLERIES. I
DON'T SEE HIS WIFE CONNECTED IF
HE IS DIALED IN AS A PARTICIPANT
MAKING HIM WONDER VERO OKAY YOUR
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT HE'S
HE'S NOT GOING AUTHORITIES SO IT
IT WHO WANTS OF ONE HERE IN
PERSON WITH THE VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL WILL GO TO MODERATE
IF YOU COULD SWITCH TO THE OPEN
PHONE LINES. IF ANYONE WANTS TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL SB
TWELVE NINETEEN. I WOULD LIKE
THIS OUR VOICES SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE KID UP
HERE FOR THE. AND THE FIRST ONE
IS FIVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
AM I ALLOWED TO I'M EXPRESSED
OPPOSITIONAT THIS POINT OR DO I
NEED TO WAIT WHAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
KNOW DRIVERS IF YOU JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR QUESTION.
ANDREAS VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION- I'M CALLING FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA I'VE WORKED WITH
THE WATER BOARD FOR MANY MANY
YEARS- AND CLEAN WATER ACTION ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- REGRETFULLY OPPOSES
THIS BILL WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER
COMMITTEE I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO DO THIS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY. IF
ANYONE ELSE ABOUT SPEAK AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
AND THERE ARE NO FOR THE WHY DID
YOU AT THIS TIME CORRECT OKAY
ARE AT LATIMES FOLKS YOU WANT TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- WE
DON'T HAVE A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WE JUST. HEARD FROM
ONE. PERSON BY ANYONE IN PERSON-
YES HERE WE ARE OKAY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON KYLE JONES WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
OPPOSITION- WE DO THINK THIS IS
AN UNNECESSARY PROCESS LIKE ME
BETTER HANDLED BY. EXISTING
OVERSIGHT PROCESSES THROUGH THE
BUDGET IN ORDER TO FIND THE
REFORMS THAT WE NEED- AND WE DO
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW I THINK I
THINK THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF FEES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ON WATER USERS
ACROSS THE SECTOR I THINK THAT
WAS A RESULT OF A SHIFT OVER A
DECADE AGO. TO SHIFT THE WATER
POURED FROM A GENERAL FUND
BASED. TO A FEE BASED STRUCTURE
AND MAYBE THERE'S TIME TO
REVISIT THAT TO SUPPORT BETTER
SUPPORT. THE WORK THAT THE WATER
BOARD DOES THAT IS CRITICAL FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT WE DON'T FEEL THAT THIS IS
THE APPROACH. TO DO IT. WE ARE
TRAVEL THANK YOU. OKAY FIGURE
OUT HOW BECAUSE I AM YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS OKAY- LET'S GO TO
THE FUNDS ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME.
I'M SORRY ONE FOLLOWING ZERO
DEFECT. AND LIMÓN PLEASE WITH A
BLANKET OF.
AND THAT FLIGHT NUMBER IS. WE
HAVE FIVE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ELENA
ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF NASCO
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO FOR THE WIND TO
GIVE. OKAY ALL RIGHT TO THE SITE
IS BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE- I
LOOK I YOU KNOW IT'S- CLEAR TO
ME THAT WE DO NEED A REAL RE
EXAMINATION OF OUR WATER SYSTEM
AND I GUESS I'M A PART OF I
WANTED TO USE TO CRANK OUT
BECAUSE- I READ THE- OPPOSITION
LETTER. AND I KNOW THIS BILL IS
THE PRODUCT OF A GRAND
NEGOTIATION WHEN ABOVE AND
LEADERSHIP IN THE HOUSE- I GUESS
. YEAH THERE'S SO MANY
INTERESTING MODELS OUT THERE I
YEAH I WITH YEARS AGO DURING THE
LAST MAJOR DROUGHT WITH A NUMBER
OF US TOOK ACV TRIP TO AUSTRALIA
AND LEARN ABOUT THEIR SYSTEM
THERE WHICH IS JUST FASCINATING
BY THE WAY- YEAH THEY HAVE
SIMILAR. WATER RIGHTS- STATED
SIMILAR- COMMON LAW RIGHT HERE
IN RIGHTS TO WHAT WE HAVE.
SIMILAR OF COURSE COMING FROM
THE U. K. RIGHT WHICH IS NO END
OF RAIN AS OF THE NO NO WATER
PROBLEMS THEY'RE HIDING COURSES
SIMILAR CLIMATE TO ALL WE HAVE
HEREWHERE WHERE WHERE FOR FOLKS
ARE ARE WE WERE WE HAD REAL
PROBLEMS WITH WATER ACCESS. AND
THEY THEY BASICALLY TOLD ME
AFTER SYSTEMS THEY HAVE A
COMMODITIES MARKET FOR WATER YOU
CAN GO ONLINE RIGHT NOW AND
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT ALL THE
WATER LEVELS ARE IN EVERY
RESERVOIR RIVER IN SOUTHEAST
AUSTRALIA WHICH IS WHERE
EVERYBODY LIVES. THERE'S A
CERTAIN AMOUNT IS ALLOCATED PER
PERSON AND THE REST THE WATER IS
A MARKET SO THAT WHEN. WATER
MOTOR MARKET DEMAND IS MORE
WATER WHAT IS LESS EXPENSIVE AND
IT REALLY DOESN'T SET OF EYES.
YOU TO CONSERVE- NOT JUST. THEY
BEING TOLD TO BECAUSE THERE'S A
MY- MECHANISM TO PUSHING THEM IN
THAT DIRECTION. AND IT IS
EQUITABLE IN THE SENSE THAT IT
RECOGNIZES THE FACT THAT EVERY
BUT THERE'S ONLY CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF WATER AVAILABLE. AND YEAH
WITH THE YEAH. PEOPLE CAN PAY
THE COSTS ARE NOT- WELL YOU KNOW
ONCE THE ONCE THERE'S WHAT ONCE
THEY GET THEIR OWN PERSONAL
ALLOCATION THERE WOULD BE MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY. IS
INDIVIDUALLY TAKEN CARE OF FOR
THEIR PERSONAL NEEDS. I'M SO
HAPPY FOR MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S
GREAT TO TAKE A STEP BACK TAKE A
BIG LOOK AT WATER RIGHTS. AND I
GUESS WHAT I GUESS WHAT I'M- I
YOU KNOW I GET. IT IN THE LETTER
IT TALKED ABOUT AYE AYE ANDERSON
IS MISTRUST REMINISCE SPECIALLY
WITH THE- MEASURE THE VETO OF S.
B. Y. AND I. YOU KNOW I
RECOGNIZE THAT I RECOGNIZE THE-
YOU KNOW IT MAY MAYBE THE FACT
THAT- THAT THE DAY WOULD WANT. A
MORE EXPLICIT DIRECTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS REFORM OF
THE YOU KNOW THE WATERING SYSTEM
AND ALL THE INEQUALITIES THERE.
ALSO ARE A CERTAINLY EITHER A
COUPLE THINGS THAT I THINK WE
OUGHT TO TINKER WITH WITH THE
WORDING OF THE BILL BUT I GUESS.
I DON'T SEE WHY. THIS APPROACH
IS NECESSARILY. GONNA BE
ANTITHETICAL TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS IN WHITE- IN
IN IN A WAY WHY WHY WHY DO WHY
WHY WHY WOULD YOU ARE YOU ON A
PLACE WHERE YOU COULD SEE SOME
OF THE GOALS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
COMMITTEE MET THROUGH A BILL.
LIKE THIS IF WE CAN. FIGURE OUT
THE APPROACH- AND ENGAGE. YOU
KNOW ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES IN
A WAY THAT TO ENSURE THAT THAT
THE CONCERNS ARE BEING
INCORPORATED. YEAH I THOUGHT SO
I AGREE ENGLISH COMMON LAWS
BERMAN PRETTY TERRIBLE FOR IN
STATE MANAGEMENT AND I THINK AS
A GUISE OF THE ENVIRONMENTALLY
HARMFUL JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE THERE
PROBABLY ISN'T GOING TO NEED TO
BE SOME SORT OF CHANGE ON HOW WE
ALLOCATE WATER RIGHTS IN
CALIFORNIA. PERSONALLY I THINK
WE SHOULD ALWAYS MAKE SURE THE
DRINKING WATER RIGHTS COME
BEFORE ANY OTHER CONSENTED RIGHT
WHICH IS A STERLING APPROACH IT-
FANTASTIC APPROACH- WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT JUST THE
APPROACH BEING IN THIS MODEL I
THINK IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO
WHO WHO IS WHO IS DEFINING WHAT.
IT MEANS MODERNIZE MEANS AND- WE
ARE WE'RE JUST CONCERNED ABOUT-
MAKING SURE THAT THE GOALS AT
THE OUTSET OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
REALLY ARE THEY GONNA BE FOCUSED
WITH MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL THIS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BENEFITS OR MATT. IS
THERE GOING TO BE A PUSH TOWARDS
TOWARDS OTHER THINGS THAT MAYBE
THE COMMUNITY IS CONCERNED ABOUT
AND I JUST- SEEING WHERE THE
BILL ORIGINATED BECAUSE CONCERT
WITH US SO WE ARE AND HOW HOW IT
ORIGINALLY LOOKED AT W.
APPRECIATE AND SO NATURI AND
WATER- WE RECOGNIZE THAT. THAT
THE- LEVEL OF CONCERN ABOUT HOW
THE PORT ITSELF IS REGULATING-
WHERE IS FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT
HAS BEEN HELPFUL IN IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHY WE WORK TO PUT THE SECOND
PART BILL. THANK REPORTABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND THERE- SO WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE BOARD IS
PRESERVED AND WE GOT THAT.
ORIGINAL PROPOSALS. OFF THE
TABLE. YEAH YEAH BUT FOR MY FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT SETTING UP A PROCESS THAT
THAT THAT IS THAT IS THE- WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT MODERNIZATION
MEANS. THAT THAT COMES FROM OF
FROM THAT PLACE THAT THIS COMES
WROTE FROM WHAT NEEDS TO BE
MODERNISED GETTING RID OF THE
WORD OKAY WILL MAYBE WE'RE NOT
GETTING RID OF THE BOARD
ANYMORE. BUT IT'S STILL COMING
FROM THE SIDE OF THINGS THAT THE
BOARD HAS BEEN AN IMPEDIMENT.
THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM AND HOW
THE HOW THE STATE'S GOING AND
THAT WE NEED TO JUST MOVE
EVERYTHING TO A DIFFERENT AGENCY
OR OR TEAR DOWN WHAT'S ALREADY
THERE- AND SO WE JUST HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROCESS AS
WRITTEN. OUT I'M THAT IT'S
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT. IS GOING TO BE DESIGNED IN
A WAY TOWARDS. THAT WHAT'S FROM
GETTING TOWARDS ENVIRONMENTAL
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AIMS- AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
THAT WE CAN TRUST WHEREAS- AND-
WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS IF THAT'S
NOT THE CASE. THAN IS THAT GOING
TO STALL NEEDED PERFORMS FROM
HAPPENING IS THAT GOING TO YOU
KNOW TAKE UP THE OXYGEN IN THE
ROOM AND WHAT HAVE YOU. YEAH I
GUESS I MEAN THIS IS THIS IS NOT
LIKE THE STATUS QUO IS GREAT
EITHER- AND SHE'S ASKING. WITH
THE OTHERS ARE ASKING FOR IT FOR
A REAL LOOK I MEAN USING THE
ANSWERED IT FOR US TO JUST SIT
DOWN AND TRY TO. WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE. I MEAN IT WILL LET LET
LET ME THIRTY YOU- SENATOR IT
WHAT. IT OBVIOUSLY I THINK YOUR
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL REALLY TOOK A
LOT OF PEOPLE BACK I MEAN IT WAS
OF. A SERIOUS BACKLASH AMONG
YOUR COLLEAGUES. ABOUT THE IDEA
JUST TO SPENDING THE WATER
BOARD- I THOUGHT YOU KNOW COURSE
NOW THIS IS A TOTALLY.
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE BILL. YOU
HAVE A HEARING. I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF KYLE'S ARTICULATED-
I KNOW IF I WERE TO VOTE FOR
THIS TODAY WOULD BE DONE WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT.
THOSE SOME OF THOSE KEY CONCERNS
ARE GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE ANALYSIS THAT'S-
BEING. HI THAT'S BEING BROUGHT
TO BEAR THROUGH THIS PROCESS BUT
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR INTENT.
WITH THIS BILL AS IT STANDS NOW
LOOK I UNDERSTAND IT. FOR THE
CONTROL. THE OPPOSITION IS
COMING FROM RIGHT THAT WE
ORIGINALLY WITH THIS BILL WE HAD
TO. INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO GET RID
OF THE WATER BOARD LOOK THE REAL
LET'S BE REAL THE WATER BOARD
IT'S- IT'S NOT THE MEMBERS IT'S
JUST IT'S THE SYSTEM. RIGHT THAT
IS JUST NOT WORKING AND THAT'S
WHY IT NEEDS TO BE REVAMPED. AND
IT'S HONESTLY A LITTLE. IT'S
VERY DISAPPOINTING THAT- THE%
OPPOSITION I MEAN THERE'S- THIS
IS A BILL THAT- WE MADE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT WORK SO IT
LOOKS AT THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE
RIGHT. WE TOOK A WHOLE APPROACH
VERSUS JUST. FOCUSED ON ON ON
THE WATER FORGE PEACE OR HAVING
TO PUT IT AS WELL I THINK THIS
IS MORE OF A PERSONAL OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL RIGHT THAN ANYTHING
ELSE WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE WE DO NEED REFORMS. NOW
I DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER WHAT
THE OUTCOMES OF WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD WHAT YOU KNOW
PUT PROPOSED AND PUT IN FRONT OF
US THIS IS. THIS IS A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN DOING THE
WORK THAT ARE THE EXPERTS IN THE
AREA THAT ARE THERE ARE COMING
TOGETHER TO. PRESENT SOLUTIONS.
TO LEGISLATORS AND SO- I DON'T
HAVE ANY OUT I MEAN. PROBABLY IF
APPOINTED. YET THERE ARE
DIRECTLY SPEAKING I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THAT I WOULD
HAVE SOME SORT OF INFLUENCE IN
FRONT. AT YOU KNOW OVER WHAT THE
WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE FACTS. I
MEAN THAT'S RIGHT IF LIKE-
HEATER BUT I GET IT AND YOU CAN
LOOK AT ANYTHING ELSE RIGHT AND
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WERE
NERVOUS GIVEN THE ORIGINAL BILL
BUT BUT THAT BUT THAT IT'S A NEW
BILL RIGHT I MEAN WE'VE ALL BEEN
THERE. I GET THAT THEY'RE
NERVOUS BUT THE PROBLEM THE
PROBLEMS ARE STILL THERE AND IT
SURE DIDN'T TAKE IT PERSONAL
RIGHT SURE YOU SHOULD BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AND I'M SURE THAT. KYLE COULD
AGREE TO SOME MODEL THAT GOT RID
OF THE WATER BOARD IN RETURN FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAD REALLY STRONG
SAFEGUARDS THAT HE WOULD FEEL
GOOD ABOUT I MEAN I'M SURE YOU
DRAFT A OF AN ALTERNATIVE WATER
BOARD PLAN THAT WOULD BE BAD.
CURRENT THAT BEING YES SO. IN
FACT THAT IS BECAUSE WHAT THE-
WHAT. THE IN YEAH BUT IT MIGHT
JUST IN A CONTINUE TODAY BE IT'S
JUST BEEN VALIDATE WAS THAT THE
ORIGINAL OPPOSITION LETTER PRIOR
TO THE FIRST COMMITTEE HEARING
SAID THE SOLUTION IS GONNA BE
OUT. IN MUCH OF THE REST OF
BILLS FINE ESSENTIALLY IN
PARAPHRASING AND THIS IS THERE
NEEDS TO BE A TOP TO BOTTOM
REVIEW ALL RIGHT THEN WHAT I SO
THAT'S ALL TO YOUR POINT. THAT
WAS. FOR THOSE THOSE AMENDMENTS
IN IN BEYOND WERE- WORK WERE
ACCEPTED. THEY WERE HERE TODAY
WITH THIS DRAMATICALLY REVAMPED
BILL THREE DISSOLUTION IN IT.
BUT WHAT WAS. SAID JUST A MINUTE
AGO IT'S NOT A PARAPHRASE
SOMEONE TRY TO QUIT EXACTLY IS
OUR CONCERN IS WHERE THE BILL.
CAME FROM. WHICH IS PERSONAL. I
TAKE THAT PERSONALLY AS SOMEBODY
WHO SPENT TWENTY YEARS PRESIDING
OVER THE BAY ESTUARY PROJECT AS
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL. THEY WERE
RECEIVING A COMPLAINT FROM THE
UPPER MIDDLE COMMUNITY JOINING
UP WITH SOMEBODY. THE CERTAINLY
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT WITH A LOT
OF THAT CULTURAL INTEREST COMING
FOR TOGETHER SAYING THERE NEEDS
TO BE A TRUMP ON REVIEW.
REGARDLESS IN ALLSTATE CORP
FOLDERS IN THIS BILL HAVE BEEN-
THIS BILL HAS BEEN OPENED UP
WITH WHAT I CALL THE SECOND
COMMITTEE STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE.
BUT TO INVITE STAKEHOLDERS TO BE
PART OF THE PROCESS IN A VERY
FAST WAY THOSE. TO WHERE IT CAME
FROM. BURKE FROM A PERSONAL. AND
WHAT IT SAID IN THE PAST. THAT'S
NOT SURE OKAY I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND BUT SURELY OR INTENT
IS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS TO
BE A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
ANALYSIS STORY THEY'RE NOT TO GO
OVER THERE IS IT WOULDN'T GO
AWAY INCLUDING AMOUNT JUSTICE
CONCERNS. ABSOLUTELY YEAH AND
THEN AND THEN OKAY. AND IN IN IN
IN SURELY I MEAN IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO TOP TO BOTTOM REVIEW-
YOU KNOW. I WOULD THINK YOU'D
ALSO BE INTERESTED AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED LIKE IT'S IN IN AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE WATER RIGHT
SYSTEM. AND YOU HAVE NOT WITHOUT
WITHOUT KIND OF CREATING ANY
OUTCOME SUGGESTED THAT THAT
OUGHT TO BE EXAMINED. THERE'S NO
LIMITATIONS ON THAT THE BILL I
THINK THE BILL DOES A GREAT JOB.
OF SORT OF STATING THAT THE
EXCUSE ME FORGET JUMPING THAT-
THIRTY. THE BILL DOES A GREAT
JOB. OF OPENING UP IS
ESSENTIALLY- ALL OF THOSE AREAS
BUT I THINK. THE STRUCTURE AS
THE BILL CONTINUES TO BE VETTED.
ADDING AFFIRMATIVELY DDING
TOPICS OR SUBJECT MATTER LIKE.
YOU'RE JUST PROBING INTO- TOOK
TO MAKE SURE. THAT IT'S CLEAR
WHEN OKAY COMMITTEE ON THE
SICKLE COMMITTEE CONVENES BUT
THEY DON'T THAT THEY DON'T
MISINTERPRET THEIR MISSION OR
DON'T NARROW THEIR MISSION. SO
THAT SO THAT- SO THAT ALL ISSUES
ARE LOOKED AT OKAY THAT'S THE
IDEA. HI OKAY YOU DON'T WANT
LIMITING LANGUAGE HERE. BUT
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO CREATE
AS BROAD AT THE END IS DEEP A
LAUNDRY LIST IF YOU WILL OF. OF
KNOWN ISSUES- IN IS PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE DOESN'T MEAN. AN
AD. ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S ANY
CONCERN THERE ANYTHING'S BEEN
EXCLUDED OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
AM I YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I WOULD
I WOULD YOU KNOW. I WANT TO SEE-
AND I THINK YOU'VE HEARD. WHERE
I'M COMING FROM AND I YOU KNOW I
WORKED COMMITTEES TRADITIONALLY
COME FROM AND SO WE WANT TO SEE-
JUST TAKE A LOOK TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
GRADED ON THOSE ISSUES. I'M I
HEAR THAT THE CONCERNED WELL
WELL WE DON'T WANT WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T DELAY. OTHER
LEGISLATIVE ACTION ON WATER
RIGHTS AND WATER POLICIES. I
GUESS MY PROBLEM IS I'M NOT
SEEING A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
THOSE AREAS- YOU KNOW GET GET WE
GET GIVEN THE STATUS QUO AND I
DON'T SEE WHY THIS. CAN'T BE A
MECHANISM. WHAT WHAT WHY THIS
WOULD NECESSARILY- DELAY IN FACT
IF DELAY PROGRESS EFFECTIVE
ANYTHING IF WE IF WE IF WE'RE
ABLE TO. WEAR THIS RIGHT IT
COULD ACTUALLY HELP TO ADVANCE.
OUR COLLECTIVE. NEEDS IN IN
THOSE AREAS- IN A WAY THAT WOULD
BE BOTH GOOD FOR REGULAR
CALIFORNIANS GOOD FOR
ENVIRONMENT. THAT'S REALLY. THE
REASON I WOULD HAVE. YOU KNOW IT
WOULD BE IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD SO. I'M. YES I DID I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY PUT A NINE
RECOMMENDATION I'M I'M
COMFORTABLE NOW WITH THIS
CONVERSATION I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS KYLE- BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IT YOU KNOW I HEAR
YOU. I UNDERSTAND. THE CONCERNED
ABOUT- THE FRAMING OF THE
OPPOSITION IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE
FOR ME IT'STHE RIGHT IN THEIR
IN THEIR LETTER ARE THERE IS
MISTRUST QUITE FRANKLY AND IT'S
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE ORIGINAL
WORDING THE BILLTHAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED SB ONE IS A LOT OF
THINGS THAT HAPPEN. THAT HAVE
CREATED MISTRUST. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WECAN'T COME
TOGETHER. TO CRAFT A GOOD
SOLUTION HERE THAT REALLY WILL
WILL WILL WILL. WILL WILL. PUSH
US. TO ASK FUNDAMENTAL. TEN
THOUSAND FOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS THE SYSTEM THAT I THINK
IT'S JUST. BECOME SO FLAWED. AND
IS REALLY NOT SERVING OUR STATE
CONSERVE OUR ENVIRONMENT
CONSERVING REGULAR FOLKS. THIS
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING I'M I'M
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND WOULD ASK OUR
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME-
ANYWAY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS OR YEAH YEAH YES CENTER
DOLLARS. SO THE OPPOSITION IS
LISTED TODAY IS THAT FROM BEFORE
OR NOW IT'S ACTUALLY POST
AMENDMENT TO GET IF YOU LOOK AT
PAGE TEN IT ACTUALLY SAYS AS
AMENDED- THE EIGHTY CERTAINLY
FOR ABOUT YOUR BLUE RIBBON
HOUSES PAGE TEN IF IT IF YOU
COULD SEE THEIR ARGUMENT IS
RIGHT THERE ON PAGE TEN OF THE
WAY THEY WERE VERY OPPOSE THE
FIRST TIME AROUND- BUT THEY
STILL CONTINUE HAVE CONCERNS AND
I WOULD INVITE YOU TO READ PAGE
TEN BECAUSE IT IT DOES A GOOD
JOB OF OUTLINING THEM AND-
THEY'RE VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH
WHAT. KYLE WAS ARTICULATED. WELL
I'M I'M LOOKING AT. THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPOSITION AND I DON'T I
DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION FROM.
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS OR BOARD
AGENCIES OR OR- I SEE IT MAINLY
FROM. ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS RIGHT
YOU KNOW CLEAN WATER ACTION
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER SO THE
THIS LIST IS. OPPOSING THIS BILL
AS AMENDED RIGHT TODAY. YES OKAY
HOW DOES THE KIND OF PERSON I
THINK. SO I AM THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE- OKAY WELL THAT
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO KNOW WAS
WAS WERE IRATE. YEAH THIS IS
COMMITTEE WHO'S WHO'S GOING TO
BE A POINTING. TO THE COMMITTEE
AND- WE GET KINDA GIVE YOUR
VISION OF WHAT WHAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LOOK LIKE. OF-
GO AHEAD AND TAKE TURNS SO- YOU
SEE A PAGE- THAT PARAGRAPH ONE
OF THE TOP THE ANALYSIS SENATOR-
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE SECTOR
NATURAL. HIS SECTOR PROVIDE MORE
PROTECTION CONVENE A COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENTS SMITH. TO THE
GOVERNOR INTO THE LEGISLATURE
STRATEGIC VISION. PROPOSED
STATUES RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MODERN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SAID
A WATER LAWS AND REGULATIONS- IT
GOES ON TO SAY REQUIRES THAT THE
CONCERT THE COMMITTEE- CONSIST.%
OF THE SECRETARIES FROM NATURAL
RESOURCES UC ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION AGENCY DEPARTMENT. OF
CULTURE. IN THE PRESIDENT PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TWO MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES AND TWO
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY. TAT'S WHAT
I'VE BEEN KIND OF REFERRING TO
THANK. LATER IN PARAGRAPH FOUR.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT I JUST SAID
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR OR THE
COMMITTEE OR THE COMMITTEE
ITSELF TO APPOINT A BLUE RIBBON
CITIZEN COMMISSION OR TASK FORCE
IN ADDITION TO THAT IN ADDITION
THE BLUE RIBBON CITIZEN
COMMISSIONER TASK FORCE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND ANY OTHER GROUP THAT THE
GOVERNOR OR THE COMMITTEE DEEMS
NECESSARY OR DESIRABLE TO ASSIST
IN CARRYING OUT THESE
PROVISIONS. SEEMS PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE BUT AGAIN I THINK
I CAN SPEAK FOR BOTH OF AUTHORS
TO SEE IF THERE'S- IF THERE'S
SOMETHING MISSING THERE- WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR IT SPECIFICALLY
RATHER THAN JUST AS GENERAL.
DISTRUST WELL WHAT I'M AND I
DIDN'T I WASN'T POINTED AT YOU
NOW AND I KNOW THIS LOOK THIS
IS- AS YOU CAN TELL I MEAN YOU
YOU YOU CAME OUT WITH A- THE A
VERY. BOLD STATEMENT. IN
ORIGINALLY IN THIS INTENT OF
THIS BILL AND TRUST ME NOT. ALL
EVERY MEMBER THAT I'M ASSUMING
IN THIS LEGISLATURE HEARD ABOUT
IT BECAUSE PEOPLE OF MY DISTRICT
ARE CALLING UP SAYING. WHAT THE
HELL'S GOING ON DOWN THERE. TO
START OUT WITH. AND SO- AND WE
ALL KNOW THAT. CALIFORNIA HAS
HAS CYCLES AND WE'RE IN A WE'RE
A REALLY TOUGH CYCLE RIGHT NOW
AND THERE'S BEEN THAT THE CYCLES
ARE GETTING THEY SEEM TO BE
CYCLING QUICKER. WHETHER IT'S-
TOO MUCH WATER AS WE SAW IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR
WE SEE. YOU KNOW AND MANAGEMENT
THAT WATER IS. SOMETHING THAT WE
THERE'S BEEN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SPENT IN COURTROOMS. ARGUED OVER
WATER IN CALIFORNIA AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GONNA STOP ANYTIME
SOON- THE ONLY WAY IT STOPS IS
WHEN WE CREATE ONE MORE WATER.
AND THERE'S OPTIONS TO THAT
WHICH WE DON'T TALK ABOUT VERY
OFTEN AND MAYBE THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD COME OUT WITH SOME-
CONCERNS LIKE. THE SALINIZATION
MORE STORAGE AND TIMING OF HOW
WE DO THINGS WITH WATER THAT'S
WHAT I THINK WOULD BE AWESOME IF
WE ASK IF WE ACTUALLY CAME OUT
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS WERE WITH
BUT EVERY TIME THE SOLUTIONS ARE
AFFORD. BY WHATEVER GROUP IS
PUTTING THEM FOR THE CBS WASHED
IN CALIFORNIA POLITICS SO. SO I
WAS NERVOUS I WAS THE ONLY
OFFICE BILL I'M I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BILL I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTCOME. IS GOING
TO BE AND HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
SHEPHERD ALONG THE WAY. AND SO-
BUT IF. OUR IS YOUR IS YOUR
SENSE THAT THIS BILL WILL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY AND IT GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS AFTER THIS IS
WHERE IT'S GOING. YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S ALL I DO I JUST THIS IS
THIS IS A- THE WORLD IS IT MAKES
RELEASED ME VERY NERVOUS YEAH-
AND AS SOON AS AS SOMEBODY WHO-
LOOK WE THERE'S NO DOUBT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING BUT IT'S IN THE
DAY- I'VE SEEN NEIGHBORS AND
COMMUNITIES COME APART. AND I
KNOW YOU'RE WITNESSING IT
BECAUSE YOUR NEIGHBOR YOUR YOUR
OUT OF WATER. IN IN PORTER BILL
YEAH I GET IT- BUT WE NEED WE
NEED SOLUTIONS SO- WHAT'S THAT
IS THAT MARK TWAIN LINE YEAH-
WHAT WHISKIES MADE FOR DRINKING
WATERS MADE FOR FIGHTING OVER
WILL KNOW THAT. THERE'S ON OF
WHISKEY. WELL I MEAN I YOU KNOW
I THERE'S AN AREA THAT- IN IN MY
IN MY NEW DISTRICTS IT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE CENTER STARNES
BUT I'M I'M I'M GETTING AND
REDISTRICTING- THAT TIME IS. YOU
KNOW DOESN'T DOESN'T HAVE ITS
OWN OFFER IT'S NOT AT THE WATER
PROJECTS NOT GIVEN ANYMORE WATER
AND THEY'RE JUST BESIDE
THEMSELVES AND THEY DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT TO DO- YES. THESE ARE
BIG ISSUES. WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
THIS SOMETHING IT'S GOING TO BE
MEANINGFUL ASK BIG BIG QUESTIONS
- IT INCLUDING THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION. AND SO ON. YEAH. YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT- THE
PHILADELPHIA ANYTHING. I GUESS
I'LL JUST JOIN THE NERVOUS NELLY
SAPIR. IT'S. VERY PRODUCTIVE-
PRESENTATION AND THE OPPOSITION-
AND THAT MY COLLEAGUES TALKING
IS A TRY THAT MELTED DOWN. AND I
THOUGHT YOU WERE. VERY EFFECTIVE
TODAY- THE AUTHORS HE SAID IT
JUST SETS UP A COMMITTEE AND
SETS UP A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
WE'RE ALL NERVOUS ABOUT IT BUT
AFTER IF I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
AND I JUST WALKED IN HERE AND I
SAID WELL THEY GOT THESE WATER
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY
WANT TO GET THE SECRETARY SAID
REVOLVED IN CEMEX. THE
LEGISLATURE SET UP SOME
COMMITTEES I WOULD BE SURPRISED
AT THE OPPOSITION WHO ARE MY
FRIENDS AND WELL THEY WERE MY
FRIENDS WE START THIS YEAR AND I
DIED. THAT THIS WOULD BE OKAY SO
HOW. I WAS GONNA. I WAS GOOD AT
STAYING AT THE BE TRUTHFUL BUT
I'LL MOVE ON MOVE IT. WE GOTTA.
WE GOTTA DO SOMETHING- AT IT IT
DOESN'T AND I'M DOING IT WITH
THE CAVIAR AT THAT IT DOESN'T
STOP STOP THE BUDGET. DOESN'T
STOP ANY OF THESE COMMITTEES-
ANY OTHER AUTHORS FROM ENTERING
LEAD PROPOSING LEGISLATION OR
FUNDING MECHANISMS THAT MIGHT
IMPROVE THESE ARE. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE STATE IS-
A FACING IN THE WORLD WATER. YES
AND I. THE INTENT OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATORS OF BOTH THE YOU IS
TO NOT CHANGE THIS BILL LATER ON
TO ADD ANYMORE- IT IS TO
BASICALLY GET A STUDY IS THAT IT
I MEAN I THINK. THIS BILL HAS A
WAYS TO GO HAS TO GO THROUGH OUR
HOUSE TO THE OTHER HOUSE. AND SO
CAN YOU TELL ME THAT YOUR INTENT
IS TO NOT TAKE ANY FURTHER-
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD. THAT
WOULD. CHANGE LAW. THIS WOULD BE
THIS WOULD BE BE A STUDY BILL.
SCROOGE THANK YOU COMPARTE
ASKING IF IT'S TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT LOOK LIKE THE ORIGINAL
VERSION FOR EXAMPLE NO THIS IS
THE BILL. FOUR OR MANY CHECK ME
I KNOW YOU GOT TO GET IT THROUGH
YOUR TRYING TO SHEPHERD THROUGH
MY POINT IS THAT. I RARELY COOK
I READY CO AUTHOR BILLS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES A CHANGING OF BILLS
THAT I HAVE TO OPPOSE AND SO
WHAT I'M ASKING IS I'M TRYING TO
GET TO A POINT WHERE I WANT TO
HELP YOU GET YOUR BILL OUT OF
YOUR DAY I THINK IT'S GOING TO
GET OUT BUT I'M NOT SURE. BUT I
ALSO WANT SOME SOME. I WANT TO
BE COMFORTABLE WITH THE FACT
THAT IT'S- THE BILL'S NOT GONNA
GET CHANGED AND- WHEN ASSEMBLY
INTO SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE RIGHT HERE. YEAH AND-
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I ON OUR
END I THINK THAT WE HAVE- A BILL
THAT IS. THAT IS SOLID THAT
LOOKS KIND OF ATWATER AS A WHOLE
RIGHT WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF IT. THAT WILL
PROVIDE US WITH YOUR THROAT
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT IS. DONE IN
A WAY THAT IS TRANSPARENT AND
WHATNOT RIGHT THAT- BUT I. AT
THE SAME TIME I CAN'T GUARANTEE
THAT. YOU KNOW- AMENDMENTS WILL
BE IMPOSED ON THIS BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD I CAN'T GUARANTEE
THAT TO YOU BUT I CAN. I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU THAT IF YOU'D LIKE
TO JOIN AS A CO AUTHOR WE WILL
KEEP YOU ENGAGED. AND INFORMED
AND YOU'LL BE AN EQUAL PARTNER
AND IN THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
OKAY YEAH. I'M YEAH YEAH THAT
THAT HELPS THAT HELPFUL I DON'T
KNOW HI I DON'T KNOW OF TO THINK
OF THIS OKAY- CENTER SKINNER ANY
NO OKAY ALL RIGHT TO MOVE A
SUMMER CASKEY- WE'RE ALL KINDA.
JUMPING OFF THE CLIFF TOGETHER-
AT S. CONCERN PLEASE CUT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MISTER BANKS BY
CLOSE YES I'M SO SORRY YEAH.
YEAH SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THANK YOU FOR HEARING US OUT
TODAY ON THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED
WE'VE COME TOGETHER RIGHT
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
WITH- OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW. BACKGROUNDS
AND HISTORIES AND IN TERMS OF
WATER BUT AND I GET THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF MISTRUST- COMING FROM
DEPARTMENTAL COMMUNITY ENOUGH TO
EVEN SAY THAT. I'M I'M A LITTLE
LAKE YOU KNOW CONCERNED AS WELL
RIGHT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
OUTCOMES THAT THAT WILL COME
FROM THIS THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT
BUT- WHAT I HAVE TO TRUST THE
INSTITUTION AND THE PEOPLE THE
WORK THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING-
THE WORKING ON WATER AND- AND I
THINK THAT THIS DOES SO IN A WAY
THAT IS. THAT IS NOT GOING TO
THE- THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
BIASED OR OR YOU KNOW. LOCUST ON
ONE THING OR THE OTHER AND
OBVIOUSLY BE ENVIRONMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS. VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AS WELL EVEN
THOUGH. SOME DON'T DON'T BELIEVE
THAT BUT IT I THINK THAT IT WHAT
IT MAKES ME NERVOUS TOO AND I
WANT- THE MEMBERS HERE TODAY TO
KNOW THAT BUT LIKE I SAID ONCE
AGAIN IT'S ABOUT. BUILDING
BRIDGES COMING TOGETHER AND
FIGURING OUT AND SOLVING THE
PROBLEMS OF. OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WE REPRESENT ACROSS THE STATE
AND A PARTICULARLY ON THIS
PRESSING ISSUE BECAUSE- EIGHT.
IT'S JUST TOO IMPORTANT. OKAY.
LOOK SPOKE WITH US ZERO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT IT'S ALWAYS COLOR ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN S. B. TWELVE
NINETEEN MY SENATOR HER TADO
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THAT FIRST
BE BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN AYE
ALLEN AYE BATES. BATES AYE DOLLY
. SALLY NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN. I
CASTING MY CASKEY I. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. IT NEEDS FORGOT FORGET WE
WILL WE'RE NOT GONNA LEAVE
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
WORK WE GOT WE SAID WE HAVE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH YOU JUST
MOVE THANK YOU- CAN SIMPLY CALL
THE- ROLL ON CONSENT. THE ITEMS
ON CONSENT TO OUR ITEM NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE AND. THIRTEEN ALLEN
HI ALLEN ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES
HI DOLLY DOLLY I GONZALEZ
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN Y.
CASKEY HIGH AYE CASKEY AYE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY LET'S GO-
THROUGH THE ROLE AND THE TO
START CASTING VOTES- LET'S GO TO
THE START WITH THE THANK YOU
SARAH CASKEY. YOU'RE HERE THE
WHOLE TIME AND- I WAS A PRISONER
UNLIKE THE REST OF THESE
REGULATIONS. JOHNDROE I'M STILL
BATES MANLY MANLY YEAH THAT'S
TRUE YEAH. MISTER BATES GETS THE
HONORABLE MENTION. NOT A
YESTERDAY YEAH YEAH OKAY ALL
RIGHT LIST ARE YOU EVEN IF. HI
FI YOU GET A MOMENT UNTIL. THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OKAY I'M LET'S GO
TO THE VOTES AS WIENER S. B.
EIGHT EIGHTY SIX. ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX AYE
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO WITH THE-
CARE VOTING I AND- BY SERVE NOT
VOTING. BATES NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ SKINNER. AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN. OKAY WE'LL WE ARE
OPEN- IT WILL GO TO HERS FOR A
NINETY ONE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
EIGHT NINE ONE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTIONS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION BY
BRENT. THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR NOT
LOADING BATES. BATES NOT VOTING
DOLLY. DALY NOT VOTING. AND
GONZALEZ SKINNER. I. FOR FOUR
ZERO. OKAY SO- WE WERE WAITING
FOR A NON. YOU'RE SO WAITING FOR
GONZALEZ IS ALSO OKAY- SB NINETY
NINE ITEM THREE. I REMEMBER
THREE SB NINE EIGHT NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS FOR FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS THREE
TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
AM THE VICE YOU'RE NOT VOTING.
BATES IT'S NOT VOTING FRAWLEY.
GONZALEZ SKINNER SKINNER I OKAY
I WAS GOOD I AM FOR SB NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT MCGUIRE. I
REMEMBER FOR SB NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR REQUIRE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS FIVE
TWO ZERO WITH THE GERMANY I'VE
VICE CHAIR. VOTING I. GONZALEZ
SKINNER SKINNER HI. OKAY SIX
ZERO THERE SHE IS OKAY- LET'S GO
TO- THE CONTENT COUNTERED IN. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDARS IS ITEM
FIVE AND THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND BE ORDERED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. FIVE YOU WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
POSTER- STERN EARNED AYE. OKAY
ARE LET'S DO SB FOURTEEN TENNIS
CABALLERO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
FOURTEEN TEN AS AMENDED. I
REMEMBER SIX SB FOURTEEN TEN BY
SENATOR CAFIERO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
VOTERS FIVE TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING. I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ ICE SKINNER
SKINNER HI SEVEN ZERO THREE
CLOSER ON THAT. YES YES OKAY
AREA KINGO ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
ITEM SEVEN SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
LAYERED. AS- WITH OUR
UNDERSTANDING. I THE NUMBER
SEVEN SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHERE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED ME REFERRED TO A
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
SKINNER YEAH WE- WILL YEAH. YES
YES. YES SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER
EYES AT SEVEN ZERO OKAY SEVEN
THERE'S BEEN CLOSER ON THAT. AND
WE CAN WALK YOU THROUGH THE
ARRANGEMENT THAT WAS MADE.
GENEVIEVE VERY INVOLVED WITH
OKAY ITEM EIGHT- SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN COMMA- THE FABRIC
RECYCLING BILL MOTIONS TO PASS
AS NDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN VICE
CHAIR VOTING II GONZALEZ. HIS
CALM WATERS AND SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FABRIC. GONZALEZ I THE
SEVEN ZERO OKAY WHO CLOSER ON
THAT. R. S. B. THIS IS NOT ITEM
NINE SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE COM
LONGER. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I'D ADVISED HER BUT
YOU KNOW GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I.
THAT FIVE TWO TWO. FIVE IF YOU
CAME CLOSER ON THAT THANK YOU-
I'M IN TENNESSEE I'M SORRY X.
NOW CORRECTION CORRECTION. ATTY
IT'S FOUR TO FIVE YES STERN
EXTRA SERVICE TEAM IS CORRECT
I'M SORRY THAT'S RIGHT OKAY BOTH
LOCAL ZERO HE WAS HERE IN
INTERVIEWS DONE OKAY- ADAM YOU
KNOW IT- ON THAT AT. PERHAPS WE
CAN HOLD THE ROLE OPEN IF STERN
IS COMING BACK. YES 99% IS GONNA
. SB THREE. FOR THE- NO NO THE
FOUR VOTES IT IT DOES HAVE FOR
VOTE. THERE WILL BE A FIVE. OKAY
DOES THAT CHANGE ANYTHING. OKAY
PART WHAT WHAT LET'S LET'S HOLD
IT OPEN AGAIN BUT I BUT I CAN'T
LEAVE THIS ROOM OKAY WELL OKAY
WILL HOLD IT WILL HOLD ONFOR
NOW LET'S GO TO ITEM TEN- SB
TWELVE A THREE BACKER. THE STATE
AGENCY BILL. I REMEMBER TEN. SB
TWELVE OH THREE BY SENATOR
BACKER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO- THREE
TWO ONE SKEWS ME- ALLEN HI ALLEN
I BATES NO BATES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I. YOU CAN WE CAN
CLOSER ON THAT ONE THAT'S FIVE
TWO YES THAT'S FIVE TO TWO. OKAY
LET'S GO TO ITEM ELEVEN SB
TWELVE NINETEEN. I REMEMBER
ELEVEN SB TWELVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR HER TADO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
THAT DOLLY. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
NOT VOTING. STERN. YEAH OKAY
ASSEMBLY SO THAT'S ALL RIGHT I
ITEM TWELVE GROVE SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN AS AMENDED. I REMEMBER
TWELVE SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN BY
SENATOR GROVE TO MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRS VOTING I
BATES HI. THESE ARE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I STERN. OKAY WITH THIS
ROOM IS NOT HERE FOR THAT OF A
CONVERSATION OKAY ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO BACK TO TOP OF THE
ROLE. I THINK YOU'RE GOOD I
THINK- BATES IS GOOD TO GO BACK
THE FIRST FOUR ITEMS WE STILL
HAVE TO GET GONZALEZ WHAT'S- UP
. I AM WHEN WIENER SB EIGHT
EIGHT SIX AS AMENDED. NUMBER ONE
SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER- THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS FOUR
TWO ZERO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI.
STERN. OKAY SO WILL DEVELOPMENT
FOR HENRY ITEM TO SB EIGHT
NINETY ONE K. HERTZBERG ON THE
STORM WATER DISCHARGE COMPLAINTS
LICENSES MOTIONS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
SHARE VOTING I. BATES NOT VOTING
- DOLLY. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
DON'T RECALL ZERO I'M I'M ALMOST
AND PAYING YEAH THAT ALRIGHT
LATER UNTIL YOU VOTED NOT VOTED
ON PROGRESS OKAY I AM THREE SB
NINE EIGHTY NINE HERTZBERG. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- OF TERROR VOTING
I'D UNCLE. YEAH I AGREE. BATES
DOLLY- GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
GREAT ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S A
CLOSER ON THAT WAS GOOD ITEM FOR
THIS IS SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE
MCGUIRE. SB NINE SEVENTY BY
SENATOR REQUIRE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIRS
FLOATING ICE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
FIVE SEVEN ZERO OKAY. HI I THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOOD. YEAH I'M SO
I'M GONNA GO RUN OVER TO A
MEETING I'LL JUST TEXT ME- WILL
TAKE A TEMPORARY RECESS- AND
I'LL COME BACK I'M NOT LEAVING
THE BUILDING. CAN YOU TAKE A
RECESS. WHAT BUT HOUSING
EVERYBODY RECESS WHEN I WAS THIS
MORNING. THE BILL LAST.
WHAT IF I'D LIKE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TEMPORARY
RECESS TO GIVE CENTER STERN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT HIS BILL
HEALTH COMMITTEE HE'LL COME BACK
EVER LET ME KNOW. AND WE WILL.
MAKE THIS WORK- SO WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO TEMPORARY SAYS THINK
EVERYONE. HEY WHILE I LEARNED
TODAY FROM. FROM A FROM A STUDY
WEEDS. OKAY.
WE ARE BACK FROM OUR RECESS
WELCOME BACK EVERYONE WE'RE
GONNA HERE A COUPLE MORE BILLS-
WHY WHEN AT NIGHT- AT LOUISE
FIRST START BY CLOSING THE ROLE-
ON ITEMS NINE MINUTES SB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE. WE'RE IN
THE CLOSER ROLE ON THAT
FORMALLY. AND THAT'S FORTY TWO
FOUR TO VOTE. I'M AND THEN LET'S
LET'S REOPEN THE FOLKS LET'S
LIFT THE CALLS ON A COUPLE OF
ITEMS LET'S START WITH SB EIGHTY
SIX THAT'S THE SENATE WINNERS
BILL. I AM NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT
EIGHT SIX AYE SENATOR WIENER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR RUNNING ICE STERN ALL
RIGHT STERN HI. OKAY WE'LL GO
NEXT BUT WILL CLOSER ON THAT THE
SIX TO ZERO SIX ZERO OKAY. NOW
GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- CONSENT
ITEMS ARE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AND
THIRTEEN. STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
AYE OKAY WILL CLOSE THE REBELS
ARE OUTSIDE UNANIMOUS SEVEN ZERO
VOTE. LET'S GO TO HER TADO S. B.
TWELVE NINETEEN ANIMAL LEVIN.
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
CHAIR VOTING ICE STERN. STERN I
CAME WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT
HAS SIX ZERO FIVE FIVE ZERO
ZERO- AND THAT'S GOING TO GROW
OF- S. B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE STERN. STERN
AYE SEVEN ZERO ZERO CLOSER ON
THAT. ALL RIGHT I BEFORE WE SAID
I DO WANT IT DOESN'T POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TODAY'S
ADMINISTERED PROFESSIONALS. I
DAY AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE ME FOR
ALL OF OUR INCREDIBLY HARD WORK
FOR COMMUNITY. SAID REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TO DO. SO I KNOW
THAT AND THE WHOLE TEAM WAS A
GREAT DEAL AND- YOU YOU DID SUCH
GOOD WORK JUST GETTING THESE
PACKETS TOGETHER TAKING CARE OF
ALL LOGISTICS ARE SO MUCH
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATE WITH RUNNING
A HEARING- THAT WE HAVE-
INCLUDING OF. AND SO I'M
THINKING MAYBE THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INCREDIBLE ADMINISTER
PROFESSIONALS WHO HELP TO MAKE
THIS BUILDING WILL HELP OF OUR
WORK AND SO ON SO MANY LEVELS. I
WITH THAT- WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
MEETING WE'RE GONNA BE BACK. SO
THERE'S NO NON FISCAL BILLS. WOW
THEY WERE DOING SOMETHING WRONG
OKAY WITH THAT I WILL ADJOURN
THIS MEETING WILL BE BACK IN
JUNE.